It's all Ben doing this. There was a lot of us versus them. Oh,
the elites are us over all the time rhetoric. Guess what? If
you're going to do that programming, elites are [__]
us over. Elites are us over. It's all them. It's all them. It's
all them. It's all them. It's only a matter of time until the
them is not the elite. It's not the rich people in America. Who
else is them? Who's they? Who else? Ben might be a group you
support. Might be a group you're a part of. Right? You're going
to support that kind of thinking constantly. It's going to come
back to bite you. There's just one thing you didn't account for.
A human wrench into the system who inspires
millions. There's just one thing you didn't count on. All of
these never Trump people, right? That that are now going, "Oh,
well, never Fentes." No, you already you opened Pandora's box.
You've already made it so the truth doesn't matter. And now you
will you've sewn the wind. Prepare to reap the
The the big happening of today is Ben Shapiro dropped his uh
anti- Fuentes anti Tucker piece. Couple people have already responded.
I think Fuentes is going to respond later tonight.
And this is, you know, trying to avoid he's trying to
re
resolidify
some coalition that will go up against the Groers, okay? That
can actually deal with them on social media. I'm not sure there
is a coalition that exists anymore that can do that. I think
Nick is sort
unironically like it's it's a weird
but kind of blitzed the Republican party and and their online
presence
and he's taken out you know Candace and Tucker who are the two
of the biggest podcasters in the world who have kind of just
like knelt to him in some ways, right? Like at at that point
what are we what are we doing here? Why isn't this There we go.
Twitch is going now. Okay, we're good. We're
I wasn't seeing any of the chat at all, so my bad. My bad. My
bad.
Candace and him are beefing. Yeah, but hold on. He He just beat
Candace and Candace decided to stop fighting.
Like C he he just like brutally ratioed Candace repeatedly and
Candace just shut up. So as much as she didn't kneel, she's not
like on his side like Tucker is. She She did kneel. She's not
doing anything else.
Okay, that much is very very real. Let me go back. I was not
looking at chat just now.
Okay. How's Nick going to respond to what Ben uploaded today?
Is he going to say he was joking? Yeah.
Yeah. Unfortunately, Ben himself has explicitly defended this
exact thing. Oh, yeah. He says uncensitive things. Um, you should
take him seriously, but not literally. You know, I I could go
be Ben Shapiro very easily against Ben Shapiro now. No, Ben.
No, Ben. When when Nick says like when Nick talks about how like
Israel is taking over America, all he means is like Apac kind
of has a little too much influence and and like you should take
him seriously. Not literally, he doesn't actually believe that
like control the world. You should take it seriously as in like
have outsiz influence in America maybe. But don't you agree with
that Ben? Don't you like kind of agree with that actually? Like
he's Ben Shapiro has explicitly been sweeper in general for the
Trump regime in terms of like the media in terms of the conservative
base. Why does he think that all of the tactics he just used
to defend Trump won't just be used against him?
Okay, now do the veto clip. Yeah, I they do the same thing for
the veto clip. He's saying a spiritual war. He's not saying it
literally, right? Spiritually, as in, hey, there's this idea
that we should bow to other countries and we should have globalism
here and we shouldn't be America. We shouldn't be proud to be
American. And we need to spiritually reject that. It's a war.
They're trying to break us down. It's so easy. It's so easy.
You don't have to try. It's why you need to maintain the norms
where you engage with people in a civil way where you can engage
with people and you can talk through things, right?
Because you have to be able to actually honestly engage with
people, talk through your problems, and come to an honest understanding.
But with Trump, they all had to pretend they don't understand
reality. They all had to pretend that like you could just be
joking all the time, and that's fine, and you should never hold
a politician to the things they say. As soon as you set that
up, obviously something much worse is going to come down the
line. And none of them and and they knew it. Ben Shapiro explicitly
lays this out. I'm almost positive in 2016 about how this kind
of demagogue is going to take America to a place it can't come
back
I couldn't find the exact article from 2016, but he he hated
Trump in 2016, right? Are you saying Ben offered prescriptions
or you talking Nick offered prescriptions?
Rhox, I'm not sure which one you're talking about. Nick, in that
clip, go grab the video clip, Rhox. We'll go through it. I'll
show you how you sweep it. I'll show you exactly how you sweep
it. He said, "Okay, give me give me the clip. Give me the precise
clip and I will uh if they want to kill us in a holy war, we
will kill them in a holy war." Right? Okay.
Literally said if if people are going to come after us, if they're
going to ruin our lives, then we'll ruin their lives. It's still
it's still not actually advocating violence. It's talking about
spirituality. It's talking, you know,
but it's if they come for us, we will defeat them. We will win.
You cannot break our spirit. Just inspirational speech. There's
one speech where he says this. I'm we're doing the same thing.
Yeah. Yeah. He talks about being willing to die. Absolutely.
Shapiro was the editor. Yes. But he didn't he wasn't just the
editor for Breitbart, right? He explicitly quit Breitbart because
of the rise of Trump. He quit Breitbart because he hated what
Trump stood for. He quit Breitbart and he wrote about how dangerous
Trump was. He he wasn't just like the editor for Breitbart and
he like helped. He like wasn't really helping. As soon as it
happened, he stood on principal and then he started the Daily
Wire and realized that following this populous wave could make
him like a like a have a nine figure net worth and he decided,
oh yeah, these principles. Yeah, on these principles nine figure.
Let's go. Show me the
Show me the money here. We'll pull the veto clip here real quick.
>> Everything is so difficult. It's so impossible.
Our enemies are so powerful. How can we possibly beat them? And
I always have. >> By the way, this rally sucked. The first
rally was cool. The second rally, this >> Have to remind
>> I I feel like that's why they took it off of Rumble.
I feel like that's why you can't find it anywhere now. This This
rally blew >> people. First of all, we have God on our
side, the biggest ally. And so it's simple. We're not soldiers
for the Republican party. We're not soldiers for the conservatives.
We're soldiers for God. We practice that every day. You need
to pray when you wake up. You need to pray before you eat. Pray
before you go to bed. Go to mass on Sunday. You have to convert
because I'll tell you something. I've been in this spiritual
holy war for six years. I've had everything
taken from me. My family's been attacked. My friends have been
attacked. Uh-huh. >> I've been attacked. Hey,
I would encourage you to go person. I cannot be associated with
you anymore because you are not strong enough to participate.
>> What's with the guns? Oh, trust me. This is what he
wants. Q.B.,
make no mistake. I'm telling you how he's going to sweep this
for himself and why conservatives are going to buy it. I'm not
telling you that he doesn't want this. Uh, if you don't know,
when Lauren de Lagona was saying, "Nick Fentes is not that extreme
on the person who went and got the rally clip, it was like, "Hey,
go look at this. Go look at the first rally clip,
okay?" With all the bones behind him, >> the spirit is
the second rally with the >> The connection to Jesus has
to come first. You have to get right with God before anything
else. That's number one. Number two is this. We all have these
beliefs, but you know the consequences for believing them. and
for talking about them. I actually don't encourage you to go
out there and tell everybody and mix company, you know, don't
come home to your parents and say, "Hey, mom, dad,
guess who runs America?"
Let's not do that. Okay?
Because someone says, "Boo." Maybe you can. It depends on if
your parents are cool. I came home from college. I told my parents
I >> You think the Silicon Bros will be will take him under
his wing? Not officially. Not Not in an official way. No.
>> Said, "Mom, dad, you'll you will never >> Wait,
Rhox, do you think anything bad is going to happen? Do you think
his viewership's going to go down from this? Do you think he's
going to have any less of a voice?
You understand? The only thing they can do now is be the height
of hypocrisy and just just wipe him off the internet again. That's
the only move they have
That is probably if they want to win, if they want to like stop
this, that's what they need to do. I don't think they're strong
enough to do that. I think they see hypocrisy is like the greatest
sin. >> What never happened?
Like I just found out about it. You won't believe it. It never
happened.
And they were like, "Who raised you?"
I'm like, "Mom, relax." Okay. >> This is exactly what I
think it is. Is this is why I think they'll support him because
it just breaks things up, right?
What are you or something? Just calm down. It's not that big
of Isn't it weird, you know? So, I then I I worked on them and
now uh you know, they still don't really believe in it cuz they're
boomers, but that's okay. Anyway,
here's the thing. You got to play it close to the vest. Never
lie, never disavow, never lie about our beliefs.
But our mission, and I'm saying it here just like I said at Apac
3 and Fentes Rally one, is this.
We want a Christian future in our lifetimes. That's what we're
building slowly but surely, piece by piece.
It is not unrealistic that in 10, 15, 20 years, we have 10,000
hardhitting
gripers in every corridor of power in
most of his current support is international from his anti-Israel
views. Uh, can you actually make that? Can you show that in some
way, Rhox?
Cuz like the idea that the Heritage Foundation would totally
align behind him is behind Tucker who's aligned behind him, that
seems crazy that you would just say it's like only international
support. If they're not seeing anything that indicates that he
has domestic support, why the don't they just kick him like in
the in the balls and send him on his way?
I don't I don't understand why this would even be a problem.
>> Backtrack today. Okay.
>> It's not unrealistic. It's already happening. I don't
know how many. I'd probably say we got about a hundred that have
infiltrated. So my message to you is this.
Get right with God. Pray. Go to the mass. Perform the sacraments.
But then you need to go out there and fight like a holy warrior.
You have to fight for Jesus Christ on the cross.
Get involved. Go fight. Infiltrate the system. And I'll tell
you, I know that we're Robert because unlike our opposition,
we are actually willing to die for what we believe in. >> How
is this a win?
>> I don't know how to tell you. You just don't see it,
right? This you're you're I don't even think it's like bad. It's
probably good that you can't see it.
Um, this is exactly what Trump did, right? It's it's like this
it's tapping into emotion in a way. It's not him like, oh, we
need to be willing to die for this. We need to get involved.
We need to build this kind of hype. It's building like hype.
He's built a cult. It is it is straight up a cult, right? And
it is a lot of people a lot of people believe in this cult. A
lot of people are willing to not not die for it, but do a lot.
A lot of people are willing to take a lot of risks. It's why
you see politicians making decisions or media people making decisions
that don't make sense around this, right?
And oh, there's one other thing I was supposed to say here. Hold
on. H Oh, right. And the whole idea like why this works in my
opinion, the only win they already have a cult leader.
I don't what? Okay. Um,
the issue is for all of like the populist support for different
issues, the way they've they've trained the Republican base,
these old boomers to interact with all of this stuff is the person
who taps our emotions best, the person who like actually, you
know, puts their finger in my brain and makes me the most upset
and can can conjure like the worst images in my brain. That's
the person I follow. That's how they've trained everybody, right?
I'm just going to continue telling you that everything is broken
all the time. Everything is is bad. Oh, is all these people trying
to take your [__] over? The way they've trained all
of these people to think is the exact way Nick Fuentes
is tapped into. Like he can tap into that instantly. He is so
much better. He has such a better feel for how to how to message
that way, how to just go live and talk in a way that speaks exactly
to that thing. And that's because a ton of the writers for the
Daily Wire and a bunch of other conservative media all watch
his show, right? They all watch his show. They all take his talking
points. They they
sanitize the talking points. They take the anti-Israel stuff
out and they just feed it to whoever their audience is.
And it only takes so long before people realize, wait, the Israel
piece doesn't fit here. Wait, like all of this fits in a coherent
narrative. And the wait, what's the piece that doesn't fit? It's
the Israel piece. The Israel piece doesn't fit. Thing is though,
we're not going to. We're in a holy war. And I will tell you
this, because we're willing to die in the holy war, we will make
them die in the holy war.
And they will go down. We have God on our side. And they will
go down with their satanic master. They have no future in America.
The enemies of Christ have no future in this world. Thank you.
God bless you. It's a little disjoint in that he uh it's a little
disjoint in that this time he's not making it very clear that
this is about people. It is clear if you watch the full speech
because he lays out how people did Christ,
right? So that's it's like the clear implication if you're watching
the whole thing, but I think in this section it's a little less
it's a little more
But does even anti-Israel or just both? Both. Wait, everything
they do would be based on if they're just white Christians, right?
Uh, I don't know about that. Okay. I although Rhinox, I will
answer your question whatever you laid out here. I'm in I'm an
unheard
I'm in unheard on what to make. What is this? This is like a
podcast, isn't it? Yeah, this is like a news network.
Okay. I don't know.
I don't know what this
He I think lays it out at some point here. on what to make of
Heritage bending the knee to Groperdom, which I guess has now
been reversed. Hold on, I should actually pull this tweet as
well. Yesterday, uh, maybe we won't read the article. Yesterday,
I said I abhored the views expressed by Nick Fuentes and that
the best way to fight anti-semitic ideas was to challenge them
head-on. Fentes replied next by saying, "I don't know what exactly
you abhore about my views. Allow me to elaborate because there
is plenty to condemn. First, the Heritage Foundation and I denounce
and stand against his vicious anti-semitic ideology, his holocaust
denial, and his relentless conspiracy theories that echo the
darkest chapters of history. We are disgusted by his musings
about women, child marriage, and abusing his potential wife.
Fentes made grotesque analogies to try to cast doubt on the murder
of 6 million Jews during the Holocaust and has said, "I think
the Holocaust is exa exaggerated. I don't hate him." Fuentes
called for the death penalty for profidious Jews and other non-Christians,
stating that when we take power, they need to be given the death
penalty. Fuentes praised and in the Tucker interview said he
is a Stalin admirer. Fentes stated that his goal is total victory
and claimed that black people should be imprisoned for the most
part. This is but a sampling of his vile daily rhetoric. Racism
and anti-semitism are not relics of the past. They have blossomed
on the left and on uh on the left on university campuses and
grown on the right through figures like Fuentes. Nick Fuentes's
anti-semitism is not complicated, ironic or misunderstood. It
is explicit, dangerous and demands our unified opposition as
conservatives. Fuentes knows exactly what he is doing. He is
fermenting Jew hatred and his incitements are not only immoral
and uncchristian, they risk violence. The task is to confront
the challenge or confront and challenge those poisonous ideas
at every turn to prevent them from taking America to a very dark
place. Join us not to cancel but to guide, challenge and strengthen
the conversation. And be confident as I am our best ideas at
the heart of Western civilization will prevail. For those especially
young men who are enticed by Fuentes and his accolades online,
there is a better way. I look forward to talking more about this
in the days to come. Yeah. Weak, weak, weak, weak. This person
will kneel.
This person is survi. They have no spine. They will kneel. I'm
telling you, it's very obvious to me. Okay, this is very possible.
Um, Miriam Madson's got a lot of pull, ton of pull. This guy
will kneel. Okay,
it's it's going to be the exact same thing that happened with
Trump.
It's easy to see. Yeah, being anti-nick and pro Tucker isn't
going to work. This is exactly it. Thank you, Richard.
They believe basically the same things about and you either embrace
or reject both. I don't think that's quite true. I think Tucker
is a little more like not he's not anywhere near as extreme as
Nick, but
it's not going to work to just, you know, embrace part of this
and reject another part. That will not work. That will not save
you. That will not be good. Okay? You'll have a rough time if
that's the way you're going to play it. And I I do think these
people are broadly survile. They will just kneel to whoever has
the most the most votes, the most poll at any given time.
We shall see. Yeah, we I mean, we will see. Uh I just don't see
unless they're unless they're going to cancel. They all think
cancelling is the worst thing in the world. They think cancelling
is worse than Holocaust deniialism, right? They pretty clearly
think cancelling is worse than Holocaust deniialism.
They're not willing to cancel Nick. They're willing to let him
do whatever he wants there, right? There's a bridge way too far.
And if it succeeds, it will be like the briefest stint for Fentes
when they see their party completely destroyed by his toxic brand.
Um, well, I think they So, I don't think Fentes's place is like
in the party, right?
It'll be like as an outsider looking in. I'm trying to think
of like there there might be parallels. I'm not sure if there
are,
but in any case, the ways you could keep Fuentes from getting
his message out are gone. They seem to be gone.
And I don't know what you do at this point as these
This Fentes character sounds like a really bad guy. How do you
feel about people who endorse him and help him spread his message?
Let me see here. Hold on. Let's see. Constantine kind of owned
this guy. I just wanted to see if anybody responded. Who's that
the Vance follows? Are you talking about Yarvin?
Jarvin is
Jarvin is like, Dude, there's this like fundamental disconnect
between Silicon Valley and the real world. People think Yarvin
is like a leader of some kind or like a thought leader. Yarvin
is like one of the most off-putting individuals you could ever
hear speak. He is just a weirdo. He is like the biggest weirdo.
If you think Nick's a weirdo, Jarvin's the biggest weirdo. Okay.
Nick understands people who grew up with the internet in some
capacity. Yarvin understands nobody. Yarvin is like a world apart
from everyone.
Um I I just don't believe he has he's going to have like long-term
influence here. I just don't see it. I think I don't know if
I want to do this
now that the Heritage Foundation has sort of uh bent backwards,
but
ah maybe
things are happening happening much more. Oh, did we read this
already? The arc of conservatism bends towards Fuentes. Ooh,
he he probably watches Fuentes. Admit to having some admiration
for Nick in the same way I can admire Trump. It's right-wingers
who want to submit to such people who truly repulse me. Damn,
dude. This Hania guy is so based.
I like I like the way he looks at things. Okay, I got like a
pretty similar outlook to Hania in some ways.
It's like, dude, these are the people that are gross.
See me on Trump derangement syndrome. Conservatives were creating
a cult of Charlie Kirk. Fentes was attacking Erica as a girl
boss fed and they're still afraid. They're still all afraid of
him. As with Trump's rise, there is just a will to submit to
the biggest.
He's calling out their surviile. They are survile. They're just
looking for their master. These people are shackled, okay? They
are shackled in their in their souls. Their souls are shackled.
They will never free themselves from these bonds. Okay? They
are looking. Every Republican is just a
they have the the slave mind. Okay? Every Republican is incapable
of of independent thought. They're just looking. Yes, it is the
brain.
Yep. 100%. It's It's like totally gross. It's totally disgusting.
But that is every one of these people. I can't believe, dude.
I didn't read this. I didn't read this at all. That's crazy.
There's just a will to submit to the biggest and most charismatic
buffoon that goes deep to the core of who conservatives are these
days.
Attacking Erica and still getting people like Heritage eating
out of the palm of his hand reminds me of Trump making fun of
captured war heroes in 2015. Understand that this was fresh off
the heels of the war on terror during which Republicans made
admiration and gratitude towards the American soldier a cultural
load star. Trump's takeover of the conservative movement feels
inevitable in retrospect. And I'm getting the same vibe with
regards to the process of groperization. Trump was like the guy
who naturally took to this. He was like a natural Fentes is the
guy who like came after and looked at Trump and was like, "Oh,
I understand this. This all makes sense to me." He's like way
more in control of the ways that Trump acted. Like he's like
Trump
with a higher IQ, like a significantly higher IQ. That should
be scary to you.
The D has been cast regarding the immediate future of the Republican
party. The more interesting question at this point as uh in questions
at this point are what it what does this mean for the country
as a whole and whether the US is just early to something other
countries are going to get their own versions of more on that
in the future.
Damn. It's it's scary stuff. Yeah, you don't have to feel weird
being scared about this stuff. It's scary stuff. Okay. It's very
scary stuff of him. As with Trump's rise, there is just a will
to submit to the biggest.
He's calling out their surviile. They are survi. They're just
looking for their master. These people are shackled. Okay? They
are shackled in their in their souls. Their souls are shackled.
They will never free themselves from these bonds. Okay? They
are looking. Every Republican is just a
they have the the slave mind. Okay? Every Republican is incapable
of of independent thought. They're just looking. Yes, it is the
brain.
Yep. 100%. It's It's like totally gross. It's totally disgusting.
But that is every one of these people. I can't believe, dude,
I didn't read this. I didn't read this at all. That's crazy.
There's just a will to submit to the biggest and most charismatic
buffoon that goes deep to the core of who conservatives are these
days.
Attacking Erica and still getting people like Heritage eating
out of the palm of his hand. Reminds me of Trump making fun of
captured war heroes in 2015. Understand that this was fresh off
the heels of the war on terror during which Republicans made
admiration and gratitude towards the American soldier a cultural
load star. Trump's takeover of the conservative movement feels
inevitable in retrospect. And I'm getting the same vibe with
regards to the process of groperization. Trump was like the guy
who naturally took to this. He was like a natural
is the guy who like came after and looked at Trump and was like,
"Oh, I understand this. This all makes sense to me." He's like
way more in control of the ways that Trump acted. like he's like
Trump
with a higher IQ, like a significantly higher IQ. That should
be scary to you.
The D has been cast regarding the immediate future of the Republican
party. The more interesting question at this point as uh in questions
at this point are what it what does this mean for the country
as a whole and whether the US is just early to something other
countries are going to get their own versions of more on that
in the future.
Damn, it's it's scary stuff. Yeah, you don't have to feel weird
being scared about this stuff. It's scary stuff. Okay, it's very
scary stuff where we can do whatever we want and then Fenta is
going to respond later tonight. He's going to have a stream.
I would like to be able to watch that. So, we'll Yeah, we'll
maybe do this right away. Okay, I should be good with all of
this to run. Oh,
am I going to be good with it? Oh, I know what I'll do. Sorry.
I have the YouTube link for Ben's thing, right?
Oh, hold on. I got to find I think I had the YouTube link somewhere.
Let me let me go find the YouTube link for Ben's speech because
if I don't get the YouTube link it I don't know if the Twitter
link is sanitized.
The YouTube link will be but I don't know if the Twitter link
is you know it's going to be Fentes. I don't I don't want it
to be Hey folks like Fentes clips and then they're playing and
suddenly we're banned from Twitch. You know you know that hit
piece from Shapiro was mostly glazing. Was it really? I don't
know about that. There's a Holocaust denial segment within it.
Yeah. I mean, we don't believe in that. So, I don't think um
I don't think it's bad as long as it's not dro he's not dropping
like hard Rs and stuff. Like, I'm fine with disavowing the points
or whatever. Like, I that's all good. But if he
if he's dropping like hards and that would be scary, but I think
there's no way that's possible if Ben's got the video on YouTube,
right? Should be good.
Should be good.
Okay, I'll hit play on this. I'm going to use the bathroom really
quickly and then I will be back. Folks, I want to do something
different on >> So, this is this is the big thing from
today. I'm actually going to open the tweet real quick first
just so you guys understand. Like, everybody in the conservative
side of Twitter is talking about this. 12.8 million views. It
hasn't even been up 24 hours yet. Actually, hasn't even been
up 12 hours yet. Okay, 12.8 million views. Candace has done stuff
on it. Tons of people have responded. Okay,
it's a big deal. This is a very big deal. No to the gropers.
No to cowards like Tucker Carlson who normalize their trash.
No to those who champion them. No to demoralization. No to bigotry
and anti-baraucratic horseshit. No to
All right.
Okay. Let's I'm going to hit play. I'll be right back. Give me
60 seconds. >> Today's show we're going to cover one topic
in depth. That topic is I think the most important thing happening
in the country. It was a hot topic last week, but I wanted to
take some time to really gather my thoughts and speak on it in
coherent fashion, holistic fashion. That topic is the fragmentation
of the political right. That fragmentation is being caused purposefully
by a splinter faction of people led by a young man named Nick
Fuentes. They call themselves the Gropers. They are white supremacists.
They hate women, Jews, Hindus, many types of Christians, brown
people of a wide variety of backgrounds, blacks, America's foreign
policy, and America's constitution. They admire and Stalin. And
that splinter faction is now being facilitated and normalized
within the mainstream Republican party. The main agent in that
normalization is Tucker Carlson, who is an intellectual coward,
a dishonest interlocutor, and a terrible friend. And Tucker Carlson
last week was aided, abetted, celebrated for normalizing within
the Republican party by the mainstay organization of the traditional
right, the Heritage Foundation. Now, before we explain what's
been happening, let's make one thing clear. This is not about
free speech or cancellation. It was never about free speech or
cancellation. Free speech has a definition. I'm back. I'm back.
Okay. Tucker Carlson is a bad friend. That's the worst thing.
Tucker Car Tucker Car The worst thing about Tucker Carlson is
that he's a bad friend. It's not that he takes money from Russia.
It's not that he's an overt Russian shell. They said he's a bad
>> The right to speak free of governmental coercion. I
believe in it, of course. I've always defended it. Criticism
of bad speech is in fact just a form of free speech. Cancellation
also has a definition, the banning of particular people, including
people like Nick Fuentes, from platforms like X or Facebook.
I believe that Nick Fuentes is odious and despicable, but I've
never called for his cancellation. And in fact, I've called for
his restoration to those. So cancellation can be that the issue
with Fentes I think you could argue is like he was cut out of
any mainstream right-wing circle like he couldn't even go to
the conferences and stuff right so I think that's like a little
different and maybe Ben speaks on that one >> despite the
fact that I think he's odious and despicable it is not cancellation
to draw moral lines between viewpoints in fact we used to call
that one of the key aspects of conservatism it is not cancellation
to refuse to signal boost supporters like Nick Fuentes is >> moral
clarity.
I want to watch some other people talk about this. Are they all
going to talk about how important moral clarity is?
Moral clarity is incredibly important, guys. It is not cancellation
to criticize Tucker Carlson for rhetorically fluffing Nick Fuentes
and other anti-American crackpots. It's not cancellation if you
urge others to stop promoting those who rhetorically fluff apologists.
Those are all elements of free speech. And anyone who says differently
is lying to you. and lying for the most cynical reasons to misdirect
from their own defense of those apologists and their promoters.
The issue here isn't that Tucker Carlson had Nick Fentes on his
show last week. He has every right to do that, of course. The
issue here is that Tucker Carlson decided to normalize and fluff
Nick Fentes and that the Heritage Foundation then decided to
robustly defend that performance. Those who criticize both Tucker
and Heritage aren't cancelling. They are quite properly drawing
a moral line. So, for those who don't understand what's going
on, let's begin with Nick Fuentes. Now, as I mentioned last week,
Tucker Carlson had on Nick Fuentes. Fuentes is a 27-year-old
man who's dubbed himself the leader of a movement called the
Gropers. He has a large audience of alienated young white men
in particular, and he's earned increased media attention over
the course of the past few years, especially over the last year.
Now, from Tucker Carlson's interview, you might have gathered
that Fentes has some borderline views on race, a peculiar obsession
with what he calls organized jewelry and a rather sad relationship
with the female. But probably you came away thinking that for
the most part, Flint has lives on the radical edge of normality.
You think that if you watch the interview?
Really? Do you do you think that if you watch the interview?
Didn't he say didn't he say like, "Oh, I know that day cuz it's
Stalin's birthday. I'm a big fan." I don't think I'd ever hear
somebody say that and go like, "Oh, this guy's normal. This guy's
like a regular dude. This guy's really cool." Because Tucker
Carlson decided that it was important not only to host Fuentes,
but to smooth over his views, water them down, and make them
far more palatable to a normal audience. As we'll discuss in
a bit, this is what Tucker Carlson does for a living. But back
to Nick Fuentes to understand just
uh is
does no irony there. He doesn't feel it. Hey, describe what Ben
Shapiro does. Hey, Ben, could you describe what Ben Shapiro does
for Donald Trump? >> Carlson decided that it was important
not only to host Fuentes, but to smooth over his views, water
them down, and make them far more palatable to a normal audience,
as we'll discuss in a bit. This is what Tucker Carlson does for
a >> This is like what Ben Shapiro does for a living. Oh,
it's must be why he understands it so well. >> But back
to Nick Fuentes. To understand just what Tucker did here, we
must actually examine what Nick Fuentes says on his show and
has said for almost a decade because he was asked precisely zero
questions about any of what you're about to see by Tucker Carlson.
Nick Fuentes says women want to be
>> a lot of women want to
uhoh. This is this is going to be horrible. This is going to
be so
this is going to be awful. I'm going to dis I disavow this.
>> And when I say I mean like
that sounds bad when I say it like that, but there's like a lot
of women that really want a guy to beat the [__]
out of them,
but also they have to pretend, but part of it is they have to
pretend like they don't. Nick Fuentes says that his followers
should unironically like Ben Ben is approaching like 2019 bread
tube levels of hit piece here, right? He's just going to he's
just going to cut like the the clips as tightly as he can. Not
that any of them are going to get a lot better, but it's not
going to be like there's going to be no understanding. It's going
to be like a straight up hatchet job, which is very
>> And die in his name.
Raise your right hand. All right, everybody, raise your right
hand. Raise your right hand. Repeat after me. I will
and die for Nicholas J. Fuentes.
>> Nick Fuentes says that women are cool who shouldn't
be in politics. >> Not cool. That's not cool. >> I
will continue my crusade against women in politics cuz it's it's
always like this and it's so ironic. Women are like I don't like
when you say I like you have to affect the face. When you say
to repeal the 19th amendment, that offends me. that hurts my
feelings. It's like, have you ever stopped and considered that
maybe if you get offended, there's such a strong emotional reaction
to political opin opinions you disagree with across the board.
Maybe that's one of the reasons why you shouldn't be making political
decisions. I'm not attacking women. I'm attacking.
You have no problems, right? I'm attacking.
I'm attacking.
Okay, this is like um this is something I think could get like
this is one of those things you got to be real careful of when
you normalize certain things on the internet, right?
Like I don't think one, yeah, he looks pretty young here. And
two,
deep down, I don't know how much of the Republican party really
disagrees with this stupid
>> Nick Fuentes says that Jim Crow was actually better
for black people.
>> Oh, better too. Number one, >> he's like a Charlie
He's like a Charlie Kirk fan there. That's like a Charlie Kirk
overlap position. Dad >> one, but number two, who cares?
Who cares? You know, enough with the Jim Crow stuff. Who cares?
Oh, they had to drink out of a different water fountain. Big
deal. Oh, no. They had to go to a different school. Their water
fountain in that famous picture was worse. Who cares? Grow up.
Drink out of the [__] water fountain. It's It's water.
It's the same,
you know? And uh you know, even if it was bad, who cares? >> You
want to know >> who cares? >> Okay, you want to you
want to know what actually is my issue here with this? I find
Ben I think Ben's like total scum for one thing. But for another
thing, like there is a there is a good solid logical reason to
not be into Nick Fentes, right? It has a lot to do with how much
he lies. Has a lot to do with how he doesn't represent his beliefs
very well or he he hides them. He goes back and forth on them
all the time. It has a lot to do with the things he's willing
to excuse from other people because it's politically convenient.
There's a lot of things there that you could criticize. Unfortunately,
when you're criticizing those things, it's hard to criticize
Nick for those things, and not look inward or look at your party,
the Republican party, and have those same critiques apply. So,
Ben's going to stick to critiques he can make that he feels like
don't apply to the Republican party or the Republican party he
wants to be a part of, and he's going to make those critiques
only. He's not going to go to any of the, oh, this guy will lie
to people. He'll make the situation sound worse in order to get
support for himself. He'll never do anything like that.
He will go through and he'll say, "Actually, he he said like
there there was something about, you know, baking cookies and
he's a cookie monster and that was really bad." That's what he's
going to do. And it's not going to land. >> It's better.
It's better in general. We all agree it was better for them.
It's better for us. Better in general. >> Nick Fentes says
that white people are justified in being racist.
The >> reason that we talk about this, by the way, I know
a lot of black people see this and they go, "Man, why are you
always?" Yeah, I don't think he does bring up the Ali Alexander,
which would be another thing. Love the pie that you could bring
up and say, "Hey, this guy literally if America doesn't like
Epstein, wait until you hear about this guy." Basically, like
the political connections he got from this brown dude, let him
have his way with some young members of his group. >> That
would be a way harder one to hit. But again, that one's a little
lighter on on the proof and what Nick knew exactly. So, >> talking
about black people, this and
>> because there just needs to be some shame here. Well,
there's a few reasons. First, white people are every single bit
justified in being racist.
Every single bit justified to the extent that that means going
out of your way to avoid black people when you see them. Nick
Fuentes is a admirer and a Holocaust denier.
>> Uh, what are you talking about there? Context.
Here, let's roll it back just a little bit. What are you talking
about there? Context. So Nick had somebody in his group in the
America first movement and then I think as a part of the Kanye
movement for a brief period as well named Ali Alexander. This
is a gay guy who would hit on young boys like like actually would
hit on minors would have interactions I believe with either minors
or people who were like 17 18 like sorry 17 is a minor but 18
19 20 like very young people and he
uh pushed himself forced himself on forced he
approached a groper to start a relationship with them as well.
Right.
So Ali Alexander
was constantly using his position as a person in authority in
conservative movements to try to have with young young men
and Nick had him in his movement. Milo always said that he let
Nick knew that Ally was like that. Nick said he doesn't know.
So it's hard to know which way you go there, right? You like
I'm saying you don't know for sure. But yeah, some dude some
dude did like a me too said Ali Alexander did some [__]
with him and I think I think Nick just said that was like that
guy was gay and they moved on them. Nick Fuentes is a admirer
and a Holocaust denier
buddy. It's furer Friday. It is Friday.
Shut up.
It is h Friday
on my
was a Okay. Well, yeah, whatever. >> Yeah, I don't know,
Porter Beller. I don't know if nobody thought to call uh Milo.
I really don't know why they're not doing a good job. I don't
know if they maybe don't trust Milo. It might be that they just
don't trust him. He's not, you know, he's not respectable.
Was a
and kind of a pagan. It's like, well, he was also really cool,
so
you know, time to grow up. We're not We're not children anymore.
Am I right? AM I RIGHT? AM I RIGHT, BOYS? Am I right? Let's go.
He was also really cool. It doesn't really sound correct to me.
Wait a second. Takes 1 hour to cook a batch of cookies and you
have 15 ovens probably in four different kitchens, right? Doing
24 hours a day every day for 5 years. How long would it take
you to make 6 million? Hm. I don't know. It certainly wouldn't
be 5 years, right? Uh the math doesn't seem to add up there.
The math doesn't quite seem to add up there. I don't think you'd
result uh in 6 million. Maybe 200 to 300,000 cookies. And I think
the Red Cookie Association said something like that. Probably
200 to 300.
>> Uh I'm aware of that, Big Tonkas. I'm aware that they
think he tells it like it is. Okay. >> Thousand cookies
baked probably. And in addition, you know, in this hypothetical,
I imagine that if you took aerial photographs over the kitchens,
you would need to see certain smoke stacks to release
the smoke from baking the cookies. And the smoke stacks would
project certain shadows, but I guess they're not visible in the
aerial photo. If you're unaware, these are all conspiracies that
these are all I I say conspiracies. I say they're conspiracies
cuz I know people say they're not validated. I've never validated
them. I don't look into any of this stuff. Okay, these are all
conspiracies suggesting that not as many people died in the Holocaust
as is reported or that the Holocaust didn't happen. One of the
>> taken over the kitchens. Moreover, if you look at the
soil texture, it's really not deep enough for mass cookie storage
underground. Nick Fentes believes that the start all the wars
that perfidious in positions of power ought to be and says that
are filth who have to be removed from the country.
And once again remember who is responsible for it all. The
they are responsible for every war in the world. It's not even
debatable at this point.
This has nothing to do >> that seems like a little little
extreme there Nick. I don't know about that one >> with
oil. This has nothing to do with democracy. This has nothing
to do with liberal internationalism.
We are at war with Iran because they pose a threat to Israel's
hegemony. That's why we're bombing their nukes to pave the way
for regime change so Israel can dominate the region because that
makes them the most powerful they can
>> Uh I don't know why you think regime change would be
required there. There is an occult element
at the high levels of society and specifically among the
so many of the people that are perpetrating the lies and the
destruction on the country,
they are evildoers. They are people that worship false gods.
They are people that practice
magic or rituals or whatever. And more than anything, those people
need to be when we take power, they need to be given the death
penalty.
Straight up.
I'm far more concerned about that than I am about even non-white
people or mass
>> Jesus, disavow, that's crazy.
these people that are that are communing with demons and engaging
in this sort of witchcraft and stuff and these people that are
suppressing the name Christ and suppressing Christianity, they
must be absolutely annihilated when we take power. This is God's
country. This is Jesus's country. This is not the domain of atheists
or devil worshippers or perfidious.
This is Christ's country. Josh Hammer and Mark Levvin.
These people
like deeply seriously
all real Americans. If you are a real American, if you were born
in this country, I don't even care who you are, what you are.
If you are a real American
that loves this country, you have generations in this country,
your family or you fought for this flag, fought for the Constitution,
fought for our church, fought for our civilization. For all of
you, I say about Josh Hammer and Mark Levvin and Laura Loomer,
deeply. Seriously, get them the out of our country.
I don't know. Like I I actually have no idea why Ben played that
clip at the end. That's like I think that's like the clip he
closes on. I have no idea why he did that. Nick Fentes, it should
be mentioned, despises Donald Trump and the MAGA movement as
>> Oh no, you
you suck.
You are fat. You are a joke. You are stupid. You are not funny.
You are not as smart as you think you are.
you are. And honestly, I and if you watch my show, you know I've
been very critical. I've never been this far. This just goes
to show this entire thing has been a scam.
When we look back on the history of populism in America, we are
going to look back on the MAGA movement as the biggest scam in
American history. I mean, now he's just telling the truth. That's
uh-oh. Now he's just telling the >> And the liberals were
right. the MAGA supporters were had. They were
so that right there is just a brief glimpse into the twisted
mind of Nick Fentes. That's just like true. Like I I hate to
say, dude, that's so to just think take one of these and make
it like the most true thing ever said by a conservative in the
past 5 years. Yeah, that's why would he end on that? >> And
there's plenty more where that came from. Of course, hours of
it per day. >> Oh, no, he is ending on that one. >> And
there's no doubt that Nick Fentes has a lot of play these days.
That's because the left, by moving into a politics of anti-white,
anti-Christian, anti-male identitarianism,
created its bizarro mirror image, a white pseudo-Christian incel
identitarian movement dedicated to destroying the institution.
Yeah, Fentes is the creation of the left, guys. Fentes is the
creation of the left. He's not the result of normalizing just
lying about your positions. um basically taking somebody who
says insane things that totally break away from norms and then
sweeping for them and making it so that like oh norm violations
really aren't that big a deal. Actually, you know, we should
just accept politicians saying and doing whatever they want.
We shouldn't have them maintain any decorum whatsoever.
Certainly Fentes couldn't possibly be a result of any of those
things. Benicians of this country >> because then then
you might be responsible a little bit, Ben. Then you might have
some responsibility,
but you don't want that. You don't want to take accountability
for any of the things you've done. You want to keep selling the
same story to everybody. Oh, it's all the left. It's all the
left. It's all the left. Bro, it's not 2012 anymore. We don't
need the left-wing destroyed memes anymore. Okay? Like, get a
new idea or [__] off.
Preferably off. You don't have good ideas. Actually, just off
country and replacing Americanism with something else. Nick Fences's
philosophy is not fully formed. It's an incoherent stew of malignity.
But that's where Tucker Carlson enters the story. Now, since
his exit from Fox News in 2023, when of course he was a very,
very popular host, Tucker Carlson has turned himself into a conspiracist
and a crank and a pathological liar. Tucker excuses Vladimir
Putin's murderous and barbarous reign. He has even become one
of his most ardent defenders.
>> It is so much nicer than any city in my country. I had
no idea. My father spent a lot of time there in the ' 80s. >> Oh,
dude. This is the one though. This hits. Okay, dude. Tucker is
like the biggest Russia show. It's like so [__] embarrassing.
Oh, I forgot how bad the grocery segment was. And I think Ben
plays that. My god, that grocery segment is gross. >> You
work for the US government. It barely had electricity. And now
it is so much cleaner and safer and prettier aesthetically, its
architecture, its food, its service than any country city in
the United States that you have, and this is non ideological.
How did that happen? How did that happen? And at a certain point,
I don't think the average person cares as much about abstractions
as about the concrete reality of his life. And
>> um sure, hold on. Moscow and St. Petersburg are really
cool cities. I'm sure they are.
I guarantee you they don't stand up to a lot of
they just they can't possibly stand up to a lot of the big cities
in America. They might be cool as like a tourist attraction,
but I guarantee you the people who don't live in New York, the
people who don't live in America who come and they see New York
City, they're going to go, "Oh my god, this is this is insane."
Right? So I I understand like the architecture the architecture
arguments and stuff, but it's not none of the actual things he's
saying. Oh, people are like way safer. It's like way better in
every way. Miss me with that gay, dude. And if you can't use
your subway, for example, as many people are afraid to in New
York City because it's too dangerous, you have to sort of wonder
like, isn't that the ultimate measure of leadership? And that's
true, by the way. It's radicalizing for an American to go to
Moscow. I didn't know that. I've learned it this week. To Singapore,
to Tokyo, to Dubai and Abu Dhabi. Because these cities, no matter
how we're told they're run and on what principles they're run,
are wonderful places to live.
So, I guess you put in 10 rubles here. >> Would those be
wonderful places to live if America didn't exist? I wonder would
those be would those be great places to live if you didn't have
like an American passport that was guaranteeing your safety there?
How would those places be for you, Tucker, if you just could
get grabbed off the street like the regular
>> and you get it back? >> Oh, this this was the
most offensive thing to me. So, I guess you put in here >> and
you get it back
when you put the cart back. >> If Is there a single person
here who didn't have this same thing at every grocery store where
they were growing up at some point? Is there a single person?
This guy is just straight up advertising that he is in the 01%
of wealth and has been his entire [__] life.
His entire
Oh my god. Really? This is every grocery store where I grew up.
Every single grocery store had like a a quarter at first and
then a looney and then a tuni.
I think a tuni now in Canada, right?
But like they're everywhere. I just feel like it's it's wild
to me if you've never seen this like coin thing.
>> $1, $2 coins. Cherry asked what a looney and a tuni
are.
So, it's free, but there's an incentive to return it and not
just bring it to your homeless encampment. >> I went from
amused to legitimately angry. Um,
so we were guessing what this would cost. Everybody here's from
the United States buy groceries and we didn't pay any attention
to costes. We were just putting in the car. We would actually
eat over a week. >> And we all came in around 400 bucks,
about 400 bucks. >> Um, it was $104 US here. And that's
when you start to realize that I I >> Oh my god. Uh I think
this has been
right? That like the the actual stuff they were paying for has
been totally >> Theology maybe doesn't matter as much as
you thought. Corruption.
If you take people's standard of living and you tank it through
filth and crime and inflation and they literally can't buy the
groceries they want, at that point maybe it matters less what
you say or whether you're a good person or a bad person. You're
wrecking people's lives in their country. And that's what our
leaders have done to us.
When Tucker Carlson interviewed Vladimir Putin, by the way, Vladimir
Putin was so amused by Tucker Carlson's easy questioning that
he actually mocked him. Tucker Carlson has massaged the Iranian
dictatorship and admitted to not asking any difficult questions
of the president of that
>> The interview is limited by a couple of factors. One,
it was done by remote through a translator. That's always awkward.
For another, I don't speak Persian, and there are all kinds of
questions that I didn't ask the president of. >> You say
debunked wrong on purpose. Yeah. Iran, particularly questions
to which I knew I could get not get an honest answer, such as,
>> "Was your nuclear program totally disabled by the bombing
campaign by the US government a week and a half ago?" There's
no chance he's going to answer that question honestly. I didn't
bother to ask it. The answer, in fact, from an American perspective,
even from the CIA's perspective, is unknowable.
Tucker bizarrely worships at the altar of Qatar.
>> They're mad at you because you don't put your parents
in some institution.
Maybe they're trying to break up your
>> When a This is a good question right here, isn't it,
Porter Beller? Wait, why? Wait, didn't Tucker do the Russia thing
like years ago?
Did Ben did Ben lose his mind? Maybe Ben did lose his mind. Hold
on. Let's go to his channel. He might have lost his mind cuz
I know he didn't like Tucker Carlson quite a while back, right?
I think two years ago he had Tucker Groceries. Eminem's response
to Tucker Carlson's roast.
Is it? No. Tucker Carlson is interviewing Vladimir Putin.
>> So Tucker Carlson is slated to interview Vladimir Putin.
Yes, he already did. The interview is going to be released tonight.
But members of the EU are talking about actually putting sanctions
on Tucker Carlson, which is a weird thing to do if you're going
to make the bizarre claim that Tucker Carlson ought to be sanctioned.
It's very hard to make the simultaneous claim that Vladimir Putin
is tyrannical in cracking down on the press. Either works for
everyone or it works for no one. Meanwhile, Joe Biden is kind
of kind of defending kind of defending
Tucker here. Uh oh. Tucker Carlson. Tucker Moscow. Nope. I don't
know there. It's got to be somewhere. He had to have reacted,
right? >> It can be it can be a reason. Honestly, I don't
know what is uh what is really the purpose behind this, but uh
uh we see that you know a lot of things that are happening are
attacks on on on humanity in general. It's uh when you when you
lose the family value, when you lose the connection between the
family themselves, you will lose the connection between the people
as well on a broader level on the people in the same neighborhood
and the people in the same region in the same countries. And
that's basically will just make us you know as individuals who
are
quote unquote independent from anyone. That's what we will feel.
Yet it will just make our societies vulnerable and easy to be
penetrated. That's right. >> Tucker Carlson praises Venezuela's
Nicholas Maduro. Even as it's funny to even imply Tucker plus
Russia is comparable to Ben plus Israel. True. I would say that
Israel's reason to care about the US. Like Israel's reason to
not want the US with uh it's worse for Tucker because Russia
literally would snap their fingers and have it like the United
States destroyed tomorrow automatically.
Maduro keeps the entire country in communist penury and trips
fentinel into the United States to kill Americans by the hundreds
of thousands.
>> Why are we so opposed to Nicholas
>> So if you ask someone on this, >> that's Ben.
Ben's just running with the naroterrorist stuff 100%. >> Treat
random person. Why are we against Nicholas Maduro? The answer
you're going to get is who's Nicholas Maduro? But if you find
someone in South Florida, for example, who knows who Nicholas
Maduro is, you can identify where Venezuela is on a map,
that person will almost certainly say, "Well, because he's a
communist or a socialist, he's exceedingly leftwing." And that
is true. Nicholas Maduro and his government are very leftwing
on economics,
not on social policy, by the way, which is kind of interesting.
In Venezuela,
gay marriage is banned, abortion is banned, exchanges for transgenderism
are
It's one of the very few countries in the entire hemisphere with
>> Tucker on this full like I'm just I'm just going wild
on everything. All right, listen. I'd accept socialism if they
ban trans people. Okay, like yeah, socialist econom Yeah, 100%.
Just get rid of the trans. Okay,
>> policies it is on social policy. Not defending the regime,
just saying
one of the most conservative countries
in North or South or Central America. only El Salvador really
comes close.
>> Tucker Carlson glosses the genocidal jihadi group behind
October 7th as a political organization.
>> You can't claim that they're simultaneously claiming
that is
uh you know group of jihadis they're Islamic extremists which
they also claim constantly which I don't I don't know if that's
true by the way seems more like a political organization but
whatever it is they're telling us constantly they're al-Qaeda.
Tucker Carlson has attacked President Trump as a cover-up artist
for trafficker Jeffrey Epstein.
>> I think he made glazes and doesn't know what glazes.
I think they probably wrote down glazes
on his uh teleprompter here for him and he he was like I don't
know what that means. Glosses glosses >> on behalf of Israel
and MSAD making sure of course numbers you mention President
Trump's name because of course Tucker's a coward.
And moreover, it's extremely obvious to anyone who watches that
this guy had direct connections to a foreign government. Now,
no one's allowed to say that that foreign government is Israel
because we have been somehow cowed
into
thinking that that's naughty. There is nothing wrong with saying
that. There is nothing hateful about saying that.
Tucker Carlson has stated that President Trump has undermined
America first and MAGA by attacking Iran, giving into neocon
ghouls like Mark Levin, while also idiotically arguing that President
Trump striking Iran's nuclear facilities would lead to World
War II. Spoiler alert, it didn't. Tucker Carlson also said in
his interview with Nick Fuentes that the people he hates most
in the entire world more than ISIS, al-Qaeda, Transifa, Marxists,
rapists, murderers are Christian Zionists who represent an enormous
chunk of the conservative base. According to Tucker Carlson,
who admits that he first read the Bible all the way through just
two years ago, Christians who support a state of Israel are heretics
and blasphemers with a brain
How do you explain Mike Huckabe,
Ted Cruz,
and they're a lot like that. John Bolton, I mean, I've known
them all. George W. Bush, like the Carl Rove, I mean, all people
I know personally who I've seen like be seized by this brain
virus, and they're not
>> they're most of them are self-described Christians.
And and then the the Christian Zionists who are well, Christian
Zionists, like what is that? And I can just say for my self,
I dislike them more than anybody,
you know, because like what this is like the this would be like
the death blow to Israel if if Christian Zionists actually stop
started like not having that belief. If you lost Christian Zionists
as like a major block in the US, Israel would be this like obviously
even if the US were to defund Israel or were to stop funding
Israel in every way, Israel doesn't stop existing, right? Israel
is capable of self-sustaining.
Israel is not going to fall apart. They're going to have a harder
time. They're going to have like
it's just going to be hard harder economically for them. But
they don't like fall apart. This is something they they don't
want though. This is like
is the base their their primary base of support in the US is
Christian Zionists >> because it's Christian heresy and
I'm offended by that as a Christian.
>> Tucker Carlson has said that he despises American who
care about October 7th. We, in his words, don't care about America
and also want to get his kids killed in a foreign war.
You know, I've got four draft age children. So, if you're playing
recklessly fast and loose with their lives, then I have a right
to despise you. And I do. So if you're Nikki Haley who's running
for president or Ben Shapiro or half the people I see on television
casually mentioning the possibility of nuclear war or sending
Americans to fight in the Middle East or in any way involving
us in a war that has nothing to do with prosperity and peace
at home. Nothing in other words to do with us Americans, then
I have a right to call you out and be really offended cuz it's
my family. They live here. It's not a joke to me. It's there's
nothing abstract about it. But most of all, Tucker Carlson acts
as an ideological launderer for other people's evils. Tucker
Carlson says many inflam
this is the one where I'm just like, how in the world does Ben
complain about this? This is literally the thing Ben is best
known for, okay, is for saying Trump's evil and then flipping
immediately. I I hope nothing
>> always buying back just enough of it to appear as though
he's not saying what he's clearly saying. He's a master of gaslighting.
Tucker Carlson, for example, would never say out loud what Nick
Fuentes does. He wouldn't say the things many of his guests said.
>> Dude, oh, the next clip is so funny. >> And so
instead, he acts >> the next the next clip that's coming
up. I did listen to this earlier. I didn't watch it like carefully
the whole time, but I did listen to like the whole thing. The
next clip is so good. Ben plays this one master. >> An
ideological wanderer. He takes other people's hideous ideas.
He softens them. He treats them with love and care. And then
he provides them with a massive signal boost. He isn't merely
talking to people in good faith. Of course, he's promoting certain
people and ideas and attacking others. So, for example, he'll
ask a series of wildly obsequious questions to Nick Fuentes.
He'll even let Nick Fuentes support for Joseph Stalin slide.
>> It's actually funny. It was December 18th. I remember
cuz that's an important date to me. >> And it's Joseph
Stalin's birthday. >> Oh, I'm a fan. >> You're a
fan of Stalin? >> Mhm. Always an admirer. But we don't
need to go into that, I guess. like
>> let's uh okay let's get back we'll circle back to that
>> but he will grill Ted Cruz about the population of Iran
Tucker Carlson will have on Vladimir Putin's evil >> Ted
Cruz had no idea what the main population like demographics were
of Iran that was bad he's calling for war against Iran knows
nothing about the country that's just objectively bad Tucker
was right there Tucker is a is a unapologetic Russian shill but
he was right there anti-American mouthies Alexander Dugan and
then praise
Alexander Dugan is a 62-year-old
Russian academic philosopher. He spent his life in Moscow. He
was an antis-siet dissident as a young man. And now he is famous
the world over in the English language press anyway as quote
Putin's brain. But he is not a political figure here in Russia.
He is once again a
And his ideas are deeply offensive to some people. In August
of 2022, his only daughter was murdered in Moscow when a car
bomb killed her. US intelligence says she was murdered by the
Ukrainian government, and we take that at face value. But what's
interesting is that once again, Alexander Dugan is not a military
leader. He's not a close daily adviser to Vladimir Putin. He
is a writer who writes about big ideas. And for this, his books
have been banned by the Biden administration in the United States.
You cannot buy them on Amazon. Banning books in the United States
because the ideas inside are too dangerous. He's often described
again in the English language press as far.
We'll let you assess, but we wanted to talk to him about some
of his ideas. These ideas that are so dangerous that his only
daughter was murdered over them and his books been banned in
the United
Tucker Carlson will have on a friendly pseudo historian to minimize
the Holocaust and blame Winston Churchill for World War II. And
he will call him America's best and most honest >> Oh,
okay. Never mind. So, I was going to say, did Ben criticize?
But Ben would have criticized this one at the time. >> I
just want you to notice the the shocking the disturbing pattern
of how Ben Shapiro spends his political capital. Okay? like as
a commentator when he wants to fight with somebody, it's always
over one specific topic essentially, right? Did he care about
Tucker? Unless I missed it. Did he care about Tucker doing the
grocery thing? He must have. I actually think he must have, but
it's it's crazy how it's just the one topic every time. >> He's
the chief villain of the Second World War. Now, he didn't kill
the most people. He didn't uh commit the most atrocities.
But I believe and I don't really think I think when you really
get into it and tell the story,
right? And don't leave anything out, you see that he was primarily
responsible for that war becoming what it did, becoming something
other than an invasion of Poland. You know, Germany,
look, they they put themselves into a into a position and Adolf
is chiefly responsible for this, but his old regime is responsible
for it. that when they went into the east uh in 1941
they launched a war where they were >> unprepared. We don't
we don't care about >> most honest his and that is the
pseudo historian that Tuck >> I straight up don't care
about that historian he said >> best and most honest historian
in America Tucker Carlson will have on over and over a pro-Chinese
propagandist who used global warming to promote global socialism
all in order to criticize Israel and hug China
>> Israel has run American foreign policy in the Middle
East for 30 years >> wait I know who this guy is who is
this guy I don't who is this guy I feel like I know this guy's
This guy looks so familiar somehow and I I can't think of the
name off top of my
>> That's how it works. >> This is actually the truth
>> are almost limit. >> I'm skipping through I'm
skipping through a bunch of the Tucker clips. >> Tucker
Carlson of course brings on >> It's literally like listen
to this insane person on Tucker's program voices episode after
episode after episode. The instances are almost limitless. Yes,
that's why >> Tucker Carlson will host Andrew Tate, a and
scam artist who mocks victims and preaches a cult of narcissism
and cruelty. And of course, Tucker Carlson will glorify him and
present him as a maligned trutht teller rather than an emblem
of moral rot. See, this is how Tucker Carlson's ideological laundering
works. You bring your dirty, ugly ideologies to Tucker Carlson's
rhetorical car wash. He mixes it with some of the vestigial respect
Americans have for him from his Fox News. So, we're going to
go through after this and we're going to watch Ben not just make
this criticism. Okay.
I would say Ben has done similar things for the people on his
network, right? Like he had Candace Owens on his network. He
was totally fine with her being a conspiracy theorist on a bunch
of things, just not one thing, right? He brought Jordan Peterson
on. Jordan Peterson was saying insane. Have you ever heard Jordan
Peterson on climate change?
Is it fine for Jordan Peterson to conspiracize on on climate
change on your network? Like why is that fine? Why is that something
you can bring to your car wash? The Ben Shapiro car wash, the
Daily Wire car wash. You can you can wash up that opinion. You
can present it and it's totally cool. Why is that good?
Why Why do you only have one certain kind of bigotry that you
dislike? >> These days and still
suddenly become >> nowadays. I don't know. >> And
then, of course, Tucker denies he said anything controversial
at all. He was just asking questions. He was just interviewing
people. You don't want him to cancel people, do you? Of course,
there is no First Amendment right to a Tucker Carlson sensual
massage. But to listen to Tucker, you'd think there was. So long
as you despise America, oppose President Trump's foreign policy,
and bear a peculiar dislike of Tucker Carlson, you see, is a
coward. And here is where his relationship with Nick Fentes begins
with Nick Fentes correctly pointing out that Tucker Carlson is
a coward. You see, Tucker Carlson a few weeks back had on Candace
Owens to treat her to his usual ideological laundering services.
That's after years of Candace Owens saying things like this.
>> And it is the case that Dinosaur, >> okay, Candace
is insane. All right, Candace is out of her mind. >> For
whatever reason, are always just found by the paleontologist.
Like, it's not like you and me walking outside. I'm like, "Hey,
a dinosaur bone." And
>> this literally isn't true. This literally isn't true.
This literally isn't true. You can go to places. Geologists find
them all the time. That's where some of the most interesting
geological formations are in the world. Is it the Cambrian shelf?
Pre-Camrian shelf. It's the Cambrian shelf, right?
Oh, where's the There's like a shelf here. somewhere in Canada
like in like western Canada where where like you can see the
separation and there's tons it's not just no Alberta's drum heler
that's like different there's um there's a place where you can
see like
you know ammonite you know ammonite you can see like the fossil
version of ammonite okay whatever this is called like these helix
fossils you can like literally just walk through these mountain
passes and you see these fossils in the wall
now that's not dinosaur bones it's not quite the same thing.
But like
he took this off a terrible Egyptologist
that was on the Joe Rogan experience. Also, New Zealand is covered
in little fossils. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. There
are places where like you get the um where the tectonic plates
come together and it pushes like really old up into like mountain
formations and you can take walks through these mountain passes
and you see like the spiral. You see fossils in the sides of
the mountains. So this whole thing is like total bull. Also,
um I do believe that there are dinosaur fossils in that same
like area, but you obviously they're far less common. They probably
extract the dinosaur fossils. They don't just leave the little
spirals or sorry, they leave the little spirals there. >> Um
or by somebody who's related to a paleontologist. It's It's very
strange. >> And then, but it was just convenient for Israel
that uh JFK got shot. It was just convenient, you guys. Totally
convenient. It was convenient for Israel, by the way, when the
towers went down. I just want to be clear. Anything >> who
who gave this person a platform and made her like bigger than
ever.
Where did she like where did she launch her career as as a mainstream
like media commentator? Not an activist, not somebody who worked
for Turning Point USA, but as like a a media person. A media
personality. Where did she Where did she come out of? I forget.
Was it Oh, it was Ben's company again. >> Happens to me.
Blame the Zionist. Hey Ben, are you going to tell me that when
she told you, "Hey, you know what we discussed around the water
cooler there, right? You know, you're the one not there, Ben?
You know, we're the ones who all agree with each other, right,
Ben?" Did that not set off any alarm bells in Ben Shapiro's head
that he'd been making some mistakes? Maybe he had to look at
himself. Maybe he had to self-reflect, you know, introspect a
tiny amount and maybe I'm maybe I'm being harmful. Maybe I'm
hurting things a little bit. Nope, not even a tiny amount. >> Like
1,000% blame the Zionist. It's like let that be my my parting
word. >> I'm waking people up to the fact that are in power.
They are literally in power and that is intentional because then
they can be controlled while they are in power and they are also
exhibiting signs of a psychopath pathology that lets them know
that they will do harm to the masses and feel nothing because
they were themselves many of them when they were children. It
is not a coincidence that Justin Trudeau is gay. at Obama gay.
Zalinski gay, Emanuel Mcronone gay and married to a trans man
who him when he was a child. >> This person is like this
person is so extra with all of it's like so so so
Like why can't you just have one? You have like one or two. All
right.
You This is like the VC thing. You're literally hitting everything.
Like I could make up the most wild conspiracy in the world and
and tell Candace Owens about it and she would just be like, "Yeah,
that sounds reasonable. That sounds good." Oh, like like uh squirrels
control all of us. Squirrels control the entire planet. Yeah,
that seems reasonable. Squirrels there's there's like the the
acorn. Yeah, I believe that. I believe that. I Okay. Okay, Candace.
Well, Candace Owens had recently hosted Nick Fentes, and this
led Tucker Carlson in an attempt to dissociate from Fentes to
label him a weird little gay kid operating from a basement and
a fed as well.
>> That's obvious to me. I've been around a long time.
I know when I see it. >> Yeah. And I will say I I don't
understand it. We were very kind to him. Like I truly like we
almost said like we felt maybe he was a bit lonely. We should
invite him back for dinner. You I mean that's how good of an
experience I had. And >> clearly it's a 180. So, it's either
a it's being driven from like a little boy in security and he
just was so worried that he like just went on the attack because
he doesn't know how to have normal relations after being banned.
Salivation just linked this and said this was his favorite Jtock
conspiracy. Hold on. What is this?
What is this?
Oh, hold on. That didn't that didn't play sound. What the [__]
dude? What is this? You could be my little wuff. Okay. Only 800
bucks.
You could be my little wuff. Okay. I don't I don't know what
that means, but I think there's the one element the angry gay
kid thing going on. Yeah. >> Well, Nick Fuentes did not
take kindly to this. After all, here was Tucker Carlson, the
man Nick Fentes correctly sees as a fellow traveler, dismissing
him, all the while refusing to say the sorts of things for which
Fuentes takes slings and arrows. And so, uh, is the gay thing
with Nick Fuentes true? Asked
Lowi. Okay, I that is the one thing about Nick Fentes when people
bring that one up. That one I basically know for a fact is false.
Somebody got his stream key, right? Like his stream ends, it
gets cut over, it goes to a different thing and then like Gabe
starts playing via his stream. Someone just grabbed his stream
key or someone Yeah, someone did something to get his stream
key. They started streaming on his That one is just objectively
false. People got to run with it. I get it. Like there's a there's
another one.
There's another one where he's like scrolling. It's like a video
of him scrolling. There's some thing that's like a trans girl
getting
that one could be true. I don't know. Plent unleashed on him
as a fraud and also as an expert on gaslighting.
>> Tucker is like the goat of gaslighting.
But unironically, dude, this this is the this is the clip I don't
you think it's up for Ben Shapiro to say this himself as if it's
his opinion and then play the Fuentes clip he got it from? He
said earlier, Tucker Carlson's the king of gaslighting. He'll
tell you he didn't say that. And then he plays this clip. He
throws it in and he never sources his he never cites his source
for having this opinion. Tucker is like the >> This is
This is what I'm talking about. I This is why like two years
ago I was telling you all the Daily Wire rips their points from
Nick Fentes one to one and eventually people are going to realize
that you don't need the Daily Wire people. You can just go straight
to the source. If Nick Fentes breaks containment, it's going
to be a real problem for everyone because they're just going
to go to the source. They don't need these old like creepy boomers
telling them the things Nick Fuentes says. They'll just go to
the guy who's actually funny and says the same things. So, if
you normalize the beliefs, you're going to normalize this guy.
Okay. But then there's Ben Shapiro proving my point again. Thank
you, Ben. The goat of gaslighting.
But unironically, he goes up at the memorial and said, "Charlie
Kirk told the truth. You know who else told the truth? Jesus."
And you know what happened? He got by and people said, "So are
you saying that the Charlie Kirk in the way that they Jesus
for telling the truth cuz they hate the truth?" And Tucker said,
"I never said that. You're crazy.
I never said that. Everyone eats hummus. What do you mean everyone
runs
What did he say? Was it like sitting in Tel Aviv eating hummus
and then I don't know how he got out of that one. I don't know
how he got out of that one at all. That one was crazy.
That was so wild when he said that. But I wasn't born with a
silver spoon in my mouth. Tucker Carlson says, "I have so many
trust funds I never have to work."
Tucker went to a $45,000
per year private high school, then a $45,000 per year selective
Ivy League school in New England.
Tucker Carlson's daddy was a Reagan appointee.
And then after years of bragging about being an elite, bragging
about being so out of touch and so rich, now he's going to be
the spokesperson for all the white people. Now he's going to
roll up his sleeves. I just like to hunt fish in my log cabin.
I care about CLA and credit card debt.
Bro, this is this is my exact dude. This is exactly how I feel
about Tucker Carlson. It's like, dude, how are you trying to
We all saw you on CNN. We all saw you on Crossfire with that
bow tie. Tucker, who you trying to fool with the hunt with the
horns on the wall with your chandelier made of like deer horns.
Who the are you trying to fool here? And nobody believes you
bow tie. But then when it comes to me, I'm one of the real disaffected
white people. You want to talk about me and them? I am them.
Well, there was one big problem. >> Yeah. This is like
the rugged outdoorsman. Oh, this went to an article. This is
like the rugged outdoorsman right here. This is the guy who lives
out in the woods out in a log cabin.
Right off.
Jesus Christ.
This was like his look for so long. He was the bow tie guy. Like,
come on, man. for Tucker Carlson in all of this. Nick Fentes
is absolutely 100% correct. Tucker is a coward and Tucker's audience,
much of which he shares with Nick Fuentes, knows it. And so Tucker
hit upon a final strategim. He let Nick Fentes him. He brought
Nick Fuentes on to legitimate his ideology. >> Okay, Ben,
there's a little fight left in Ben. Okay, there's a little fight
left. There's something there. There's a bit of a soul. >> He
let Nick Fuentes him. He brought Nick Fuentes on to legitimate
his ideology. He signal boosted Fuentes. Glossed him, shined
him, presented him to the world. All in order to protect his
own reputation with his online. He just said glossed him again.
He just said glossed him again. Ben Shapiro is getting glaze
written in his transcript in his teleprompter and he keeps saying
gloss instead of glaze. He glazed him is what you're supposed
to say. Ben, just don't write. Yeah, I know. I know. It's like
he's making it so obvious he doesn't write his own scripts right
now. He glossed him and then he put it out and it's like I'm
sorry if I promise you Fuentes is going to point that out. They're
gonna he's going to show this clip or he's going to reference
this clip and he's going to go look how [__] fake
you are. You don't even write your own [__] I I bet
you I bet you Fuentes gets enough that he says, "You know what
you should have done? You should have called Milo. Why didn't
you call Milo? There are people who could actually talk about
me. You're not the one. You're writers, your interns who do this
for minimum wage or you maybe you outsource this to India. They
don't know how to talk. You don't know how to talk.
Who is Milo? Milo Yiannopoulos.
Enemy true enemy. Soul
sole adversary of Nicholas J. Fuentes. Milo Yiannopoulos.
Right. Like that. Again, he just had a funny moment and he totally
undercuts it by saying gloss
because that feeds right into the narrative that you are fake.
You are putting on a show. You're putting on an act. None of
this is real, right? You're just a made guy trying to sell people
talking points
and we don't buy it anymore. Like this should have been you rewrite,
you reshoot this. This does not come out today. This can't come
out. and base, a base he is competing over with Nick Fentes.
Now, of course, Tucker has a right to do all of this for the
100th time. He can do what he likes. This is America. But there's
no question that Tucker has become the most virulent super spreader
of vile ideas in America. And the rest of us who oppose those
vile ideas have every right to call him that. There is one other
element here that's even darker, if possible. Tucker Carlson
prays on the friendship he proclaims with others, and then he
knifs them directly between the shoulder blades when convenient
for him. Tucker Carlson is in short a terrible friend. Tucker
Carlson was supposedly Charlie Kirk's friend. Charlie believed
that Nick Fuentes was vermin. That's a direct quote. He believed
that because Nick Fentes dedicated his life to destroying Charlie
Kirk and TPUSA from the inside. In fact, here's Nick Fentes describing
Charlie Kirk the month before Charlie was murdered. >> Uh-oh.
Charlie Kirk cannot call himself a Christian anymore. Sorry,
you forfeited that. I do not want to hear and you cannot allow
Charlie Kirk to go to one more public event,
one more question and answer, one more ask me anything without
being protested, without being shouted down, without being interrogated
about this.
This guy goes around from campus to
in the most artificial and phony and fake way. And here is Nick
Fentes describing how he destroyed TPUSA from the inside. Whether
he chooses to confront me or not, whether he has dignity and
honor or not, it's just a matter of time. My ideas are already
there. I've already impregnated your
I took Turning Point USA and I it
took your organization.
I took your baby, Turning Point USA, and I it been it.
And that's why it's filled with gropers.
That's why your whole crew, that's why the people around you,
that's why your chapter presidents, that's why your attendees,
they're all gropers.
And here is Nick Fentes calling Charlie Kirk unpatriotic and
talking about how he's a idiot and saying all firepower should
be focused on Charlie Kirk.
>> I think a lot of people are starting to >> Oh,
hold on. Okay,
sure. This is We can keep going with this. We're going to finish
this video and then I got to go I got to do a quick a quick Hutch
switchover. Okay, we got to do uh Charlie is not the patriot
that he says he is. And so I look at what happened last night
and I think to myself, this is totally a doable operation. You
know, Charlie Kirk in the grand scheme of things is just some
idiot. The dog is terrified. I had to go upstairs and reassure
him cuz I'm scream. If this if this doesn't make you understand
that like anybody could be a streamer if you're willing to put
in the work and the effort. All right. Nick is Nick's a good
speaker back here. But he's not great. He's not as anywhere near
as good as he is now, right? When he's like this skinny nerdy
haircut guy. There's like a lot of there's a lot of polish that
isn't there that you know gets there eventually. Screaming at
my stream at my screen calling Charlie Kirk a and everything.
The contrast could not be more clear. Charlie Kirk is a totally
unexceptional human being. A moral struggle that's happening
on you the higher dimension, right? Which is Christ versus the
devil. Who does Charlie Kirk serve? You know, is is he really
a Christian? Is he really Christlike when he supports foreign
wars and Israel and all this? Look at the people he's taking
money from, you know. So, the guy's a fake Christian. The guy's
not a patriot. He hates our country. He's unamerican.
Let's let's focus all our firepower on Charlie Kirk. Why are
we doing this? It's because Charlie Kirk is a fake patriot, a
fake Christian, and he hates his people. He's anti-white. This
is our >> Nick Fentes despised Charlie Kirk. And for good
reason, because Charlie Kirk actually opposed Nick's evil program.
Here's what Charlie Kirk had to say about Nick Fentes's agenda.
They both lied about each other, right? They both lied about
why they didn't like the other person. Charlie knew that Nick
was a better speaker than him. He was more compelling, right?
And Charlie knew that Nick was trying to [__] with
him like a little bit explicitly. And Charlie tried to get him
kicked out of everything.
Nick hated Charlie because Charlie tried to kick him out of everything
because Nick was kind of an [__] and Nick was anti-Semitic,
right? It's not It's never been about the ideas between these
two people. It's been about they hate each other because they
keep trying to each other's careers over. That's why they don't
like each other. It's not It's not like, oh, you know, Nick Nick
hated Charlie because Charlie opposed his ideas. Nope. That is
not that is not what this was.
They hated each other personally. You >> go back to the
original founding fathers. They intended this to be a European
nation for white men of good stock in character. >> Show
can you show me let me let me answer the question. Can you show
me where in the United States Constitution it says that? >> It
wasn't in the Constitution. >> It wasn't in the Constitution
cuz they didn't believe it. >> I found it.
>> What does the phrase una mean? What does the phrase
e pluribus una mean? >> Why is that relevant? >> Because
it was on every founding document and presidential seal from
our founding which means out of many one you serve and your ideology
is not conservative. It is rightwing identitarian. It has no
place in the conservative movement. MY FRIEND. GET OUT OF
>> I don't platform trolls and I don't platform. And I
>> just just to be clear, what did what did Charlie do
when he uh started talking about like DEI? Seemed like identitarianism
had a little bit of a place when he started talking about DEI,
right? Just don't get identitarian
over. Okay? There's just like one thing. This is one one thing
that I'm going to get really fired up about. I don't discuss
people or I don't debate with people that
are not good faith actors and um >> you debate males then
people champion >> they can keep on yelling at how successful
we are and our big events and well over a thousand
employees
but there's a lot of jealousy out there we build they complain
we succeed we win they blame the
>> after Charlie's TP USA made Tucker Carlson one of its
chief faces. Tucker of course spoke at Charlie's memorial where
he implied that humus eating nefarious
Charlie with no mention of the ideology of the actual alleged
murderer who was of course a trans activist gay furry. Tucker
Carlson in fact has spent more time talking about
Wait, he wasn't a furry and I don't even know was he a trans
what what's your bar for trans activism?
I guess the the only act that could arguably be considered trans
activism that I'm aware of is him shooting Charlie Kirk. He was
not a trans activist before that and he wasn't a furry either
in Israel since Charlie's death than about the transify that
motivated Charlie Kirk's killer by a long shot. It's not close
which is not a surprise since he seems to spend very little time
these days attacking anyone.
>> Uh it's a big one. Yes.
But I'm telling you that calling him an activist means he had
this ideology for a long time that he wasn't just like reacting
to some stuff that was happening. Okay.
>> Well, now Tucker Carlson has seen fit to >> calling
him like transif. It's just it's like painting him as something
he's not. >> wander.
Trust me, if we had if this guy had, you know, a video of Tim
P, the Tim Pool podcast there that was talking about how Charlie
Kirk sucked on his phone,
Ben Shapiro would have all the understanding in the world, right,
for why that wasn't necessarily Tim P's fault. It's the person
who hated Charlie most and who wished him destruction. That's
not an act of friendship. It's an act of sick evil. And then,
of course, there's Tucker Carlson's relationship with the vice
president. Certainly, Vice President Vance has been quite generous
with Tucker Carlson. That loyalty was not reciprocated last week
to say the least. Here, for example, is what Nick Fentes has
said about JD Vance's wife,
>> Andrew Tate and Bronze Age pervert and all these people
for years all they talk about is going to the gym, being a vitalist,
fighting the Matrix, India smells bad, all this kind of.
And now they're all in favor of a fat race mixer who's married
to a Jeet who named his son VC who was mentored by a neocon
and a gay fed Peter Teal.
Now, now
that's an incredibly critical I think Ben Shapiroed up by not
making this entire thing about like that. Nick Fentes's attack
on other Republicans cuz what Ben needs is a coalition of people
who are going to oppose this guy, right? That's what Ben needs
to do. He needs to solidify the coalition that goes against these
people and he needs to continue using clips like that. Those
are the clips that actually hit if you want to get the rest of
the Republican movement to to shut this guy out again.
This guy has a non-white wife and a kid named Vivec.
This guy is going to be a defender of white identity. I don't
think so. This guy's going to defend American identity.
>> You slam JD Vance for having an Indian wife. Yet Trump's
wife is an immigrant who was working here legally for a time.
His son is half foreign, bilingual, and holds dual citizenship.
Yet, you give him a pass. You're either a hypocrite or just [__]
>> SHE'S WHITE, DUDE. SHE'S WHITE.
If we if we had uh millions of Slovenian supermodels imig
uh the destiny strategy on Hassan saying he condemns too much.
No, it's different than that. It's basically saying that like
this guy's really popular and he trashes you to his audience.
If he if he's allowed to just continue, he's going to keep making
you look bad. He's he's against everything you stand for. You
have to you have to make your stand now, right? That's what Ben
needs to convince people of. grading to America, I don't think
we'd have a big problem with it. >> Tucker Carlson had
on Nick Fuentes and did not ask him a single question about any
of this. He just brought him on to launder his ugly ideas and
make him more popular. That doesn't seem quite like the act of
a friend, which finally brings us to the Heritage Foundation.
Now, I have a long and admiring relationship with the Heritage
Foundation. One of the very first outlets to pick up my syndicated
column when I was 17 years old, 24 years ago, was townhall.com,
then a property of the Heritage Foundation. I know most of the
leadership very well, and I have for >> Is that where Ben
wrote about what he thinks should happen in the West Bank? >> I
know Kevin Roberts, and I like him, and I'm grateful for his
contributions to the conservative movement. If you're a regular
watcher of this show, you can check the interview I did with
Kevin on the release of his book just last >> Wait, doesn't
doesn't actually forgive himself for a lot of his comments on
Muslim people because of his age?
>> Which is why what Kevin Roberts did last week is tragic.
And >> that's another point, isn't it? Ben Shapiro, when
you ask him, hey, you made like these really bad Muslims only
know how to live in open sewage and bomb people. That's kind
of a thing to say, isn't it, Ben? Yeah, it is. And I I don't
agree with that anymore, but you know, I was young. Isn't that
his answer to that question? Hey, why what what the was going
on here? Awful. He put out a statement that Heritage Foundation
didn't just stand by Tucker Carlson. Kevin instead said openly
and repeatedly that Tucker Carlson can do nothing ever that will
sever his relationship with the conservative movement. He said
that after and in defense of Tucker's glossing of defender Nick
Fuentes and he added that only
third time third time third time like I'm sorry
you're being painted is inauthentic. You are trying to use like
what you see is young person slag. Uh slag. Slang. Oh my god.
You're trying to use young person slang to get people on your
side. You're misusing it. You look
bad doing this. Hey, I'm just mispeaking. Okay, I know the slang.
I'm just misspeaking. All right. It's different. It's different.
It's different.
He keeps he keeps trying to say glaze and he says glossing every
time. members of the globalist class direct quote a venomous
coalition direct quote subject to the dictates of someone else's
agenda direct quote oppose Heritage's ongoing relationship with
Tucker Carlson which means that according to Kevin Roberts apparently
anyone opposing the ongoing mainstreaming of Tucker Carlson is
acting on behalf of a foreign power.
Kevin's statement is a betrayal of the Heritage Foundation's
history and principles, which is presumably why both Tucker Carlson
and Nick Fuentes loved it. And that's a tragedy because America
needs a robust conservative organization based on principle and
ideas, not personal loyalty to bad actors like Tucker Carlson.
We need strong leaders in the conservative movement willing to
speak out against the moral rot that threatens our future. I
hope Kevin Roberts and Heritage show us that they >> Does
he mean glossing over? No, because Porter Beller repeatedly
he was talking I believe he said gloss like directly.
No, no, no. I We'll go back through it. We'll do a We'll do a
glossing review after this. Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no. We'll do a glossing review after this.
>> They can still be those leaders, but if not, we'll have
to look elsewhere.
So, why is all of this happening? Because like the Democratic
party, the Republican party is being eaten by its radicals. Many
in the political class are too cowardly to stand up. Apparently,
they're willing to play footsie with gropers and hug Tucker Carlson
out of fear of somehow losing support. They've been bamboozled
by the lies of the ex algorithm and the Tik Tok metrics.
The left.
Oh, I hope that works for you, Ben. I didn't work for anyone
else. It's never worked for anybody else. It's been years since
this argument worked. Listen, guys. Social media is not real
life. The internet's not real life. A dog can't play basketball.
Okay. Dog dog can't play basketball. >> Left followed its
radicals to electoral hell. Apparently, many on the right wish
to do the same. Forget the morality then for just a moment. Let's
be pragmatic. Here is the thing. Americans hate Nick Fuentes's
philosophy. They think it's trash. Republicans by the polling
think it's trash. Independents think it's trash. Democrats think
it's trash. And
>> Okay. When you hold on when you went and checked Trump's
ideology, what what people said, hey, Donald Trump says he wants
to like he says like all Mexicans are rapists and murderers.
How do you feel about that? Everybody says they hate it. And
then he's president of the United States. Here's the other thing.
Americans hate Tucker Carlson's laundered anti-Americanism.
Republicans think it's trash. Independents think it's trash.
Democrats think it's trash. Americans are not pro-segregation,
pro- rape, anti-woman, pro-ch child marriage, anti-lack, anti-Indian,
anti-Latino, anti-constitution,
nut jobs like Nick Fuentes. And Americans are not pro Putin,
pro- Iran, pro-China, pro Venezuela.
I mean, this is just going to the other thing is is so Ben's
lost so much of his audience. Uh, Fuentes is getting like so
many views now. Unfortunately for him, he's gonna have to contend
with the fact that a lot of people watch Fentes. So when you
misrepresent him completely, right? There are going to be people
who will actually know the majority of his content that is like
by and large while it is like blackpilled in a lot of cases,
it seems to be pro-American, right? It has a pro-America sheen.
You could dig deeper and you could explain how like the values
are anti-American uh anti-American like they're anti they're
yeah antithetical to American, you know, norms and and values.
But I don't think you can go and just say, well, he's clearly
like,
well, there's a lot of clips, but like pro Putin or like anti-America.
You can't like do a bunch of these things. Anti- anti-semite
and Okay, you can do those, but there's a couple other ones that
are like, man, that's going to be tough for you, right? Did the
They took Our Jerbs episode in 2004. It's pretty old. Yeah. This
is Ben Shapiro's views over the past year. Okay. Monthly gain
He was doing good during the election. After the election, it's
kind of been a tough slog for him in 2025. It's been a very tough
slog for him. Okay, that's a bit of a rough one there. Oh, we
don't have all the way to the end. Hold on.
Wait,
how do I do this? There we go. There we go. Been a bit of a rough
one through the end of 2020. Actually, all of 2025.
He's basically got like three months in 2025 where he's positive
on the old on the old subs. Okay,
it's rough. The views are down.
The subs are down. It's all down. >> Pro- Fuentes, pro
hate idiots like Tucker Carlson. They hate this vile garbage.
If Republicans decide to cower before the likes of and their
propagandizers, they deserve to lose. And they did Did Ben Maybe
Ben called out all the people who attacked Andrew or sorry, who
attached themselves to Andrew Tate or willing to talk to Andrew
Tate again. Maybe he did that.
I don't remember it. I don't remember him making as big a deal
out of it, but maybe he did. Maybe he's got, you know, a principled
leg to stand on here.
We'll see. Will lose.
And their propagandizers are not Republicans. They're not America
first. They're not MAGA. They sure as hell aren't conservative.
These people aren't to my right. They're not attached in any
way to the fundamental principles of conservatism.
Okay, this one, this one I do believe way more. I I actually
still believe that for the Tucker Carlson grocery store thing,
he must have he must have said some bad there, right? Like about
it.
All of MAGA loves Tate.
What's the biggest personality in Ben's media network? And how
are they doing in views? Uh it should be Ben at this point, right?
Nolles. You could maybe look at Matt Walsh. You maybe see if
Matt Walsh is doing good. And these people have already declared
themselves to be my enemies. I'd be a fool not to take them seriously.
Yeah,
it will hollow out the Republican party, lead it to electoral
catastrophe, and empty it and the country of any semblance of
decency in the process. >> So I Hold on.
Uh Ben Shapiro
2016 Donald Trump. I need to see Did Ben Did Ben Shapiro do an
article
in 2016? That's what I I did not No, no, no. Not this one. I
want to see Ben
talking about Trump in 2016. I need to find this article right
now. Okay. I need to see Ben Shapiro's article that he actually
wrote because is this it or is this just a thing with all of
them? It's just all of them. I need to see Ben Shapiro. Ben Shapiro
wrote an article on Trump, right? And I need to see and watch
how closely it matches up to what's being said here about Nick
Fuentes.
And these people have already declared themselves to be my enemies.
I'd be a fool not to take them seriously. If they get their way,
they will hollow out the Republican party, lead it to electoral
catastrophe, and empty it and the country of any semblance of
decency in the process. My answer is no. No to the Gropers. No
to their publicists like Tucker Carlson. No to those who champion
them. No to demoralization.
No to bigotry and
No to anti-Americanism.
No, this is our country. This is our party and this is our conservative
movement. And I will not stand by while it is handed over to
those who betray the most fundamental principles I have spent
my entire life defending and
That is a path to defeat and a path to moral oblivion. I reject
it because if we lose the right, we will lose to the left and
either way we'll lose the country. I'm Ben Shapiro. This is the
Ben Shapiro show. >> Okay, hold on. What is this?
I'm trying to find. Thank you, Ben. That was so cool from Ben.
That was so cool, Ben, to just give us content for the day. As
Jtock looked at the comments. Oh, I have not looked at the comments
yet. Right-wing pod wars are about to be wild this week. You
know, Ben is serious when he w There wasn't a single ad read
in the vid. Oh, boy.
Okay. Get back to work, Matt Walsh.
That's a reference, right? Get back to work, Matt Walsh.
Protect Israel, Matt Walsh. That's a That's a sneaky reference
right there. Okay, that's probably why that hasn't been deleted.
Protect Israel. Matt
Times like this make me wish I could see the amount of dislikes
like back in the day. Just debate him. He'd gladly do it. Nick
is going to go nuclear on Ben tonight. America first, not Ukraine
or Israel or Sudan. I much rather 10,000% that my tax money gets
spent on lazy Americans than in foreign countries. Uh, I love
how the comments are filled with wang halves
and the hat is getting bigger.
Oh, it's not great for him. I love this episode is just a montage
of Nick Fentes and Tucker Carlson clips. Ben, you have no choice
but to debate him. It'll be the biggest thing in politics. He's
only going to get bigger, especially with the anger from young
people about Charlie Kirk. Tim Pull is having Fentes on soon,
and I'm sure he will push back on him more than Tucker did, but
it really has to be you, Ben. You have to do it.
I'm Dan Krenshaw.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, we we will do the gloss investigation as well.
Why don't you debate Nick? Debate him. We are all We're all noticing
now. Debate him. Free speech for everyone or no one. Ben, show
him why he's wrong and debate
Christ is king. Nick Fuentes is hilarious. Americanism, not globalism.
This is of course the inauguration speech from Trump. Americanism,
not globalism, will be our credo, right? It's America first.
Only America first.
free speech before it's taken completely. America first.
Like, this is not good. Ben is not the master of his own channel.
Okay, this is
Nick Fuentes lost to Candace Owens. I doubt Nick Fuentes will
risk going against Ben. I think he will cuz again, I'm just telling
you it doesn't matter. Nick doesn't need to win. Nick's not arguing.
Nick is evangelizing.
He You can't beat him in a debate because you can't argue with
him. You cannot win the argument. There is no argument to be
had. He is just going to go on. He's going to explain his entire
the the story, right? All of these things. He's not going to
engage in the specifics.
It's never going to be and Ben
I this is just like karma, okay? It's karmic justice for Ben
Shapiro because Ben Shapiro consistently
refuses to call out Trump for doing the same thing. Right? When
Trump won't actually answer questions, when Trump will lie, when
he will not be held down to any fact of reality that's inconvenient
for him, right? He won't be held down by facts. Ben goes, "Oh,
don't." He's kind of just lighthearted. You know, he's our guy.
He's getting us judges and stuff. Ben totally sweeps for it.
And now Ben has that exact same thing. He's experiencing what
Democrats got to experience, but it's instead of watching America
get, it's way worse for Ben because this time he's going to watch
Israel get.
and that's what he's actually concerned about. Okay, we've got
the somebody gave me the article here.
Wait, somebody linked me the article. Why didn't I open it? Here
it is. This is the the Daily Wire right here.
Oh, I'm losing my
Hold on. Here we go. Oh, I opened this. That's why. Ah, whoops.
I just have this open twice. Okay. I will never vote for Donald
Trump. This is Ben Shapiro in 2016. This might be the one of
the first articles ever written on the Daily Wire. Although it
might also just be copied from somewhere else because I I don't
know. But it says dailywire.com. I will never vote for Donald
Trump ever. I will never vote for Donald Trump because I stand
with certain principles. I stand with small government and free
markets and religious freedom and personal responsibility. Donald
Trump stands against all these things. He stands for Planned
Parenthood and trade restrictions and targeting trade restrictions.
Yeah, he does. and targeting of political enemies and an anti-morality
foreign policy and government domination of religion and nastiness
towards women and tacit appeals to racism and unbounded personal
power. Oh, how what what has changed here? What? What changed
that? He put I guess he put judges in that gets rid of the Planned
Parenthood thing and then Okay, maybe not government
I Okay, I don't know what of these changed.
I stand with the Constitution of the United States and its embedded
protection of my God-given rights through governmental checks
and balances. Okay. Well, did you complain? Have you complained?
Have you been complaining, Ben? Ben, I thought you I thought
I thought checks and balances were important. Ben, where's Ben's
voice
Donald Trump does not. I stand with conservatism. Donald Trump
stands against it. I stand with # never Trump.
The counterargument to the hashtag neverTrump movement comes
down to two words. Hillary Clinton. Trump will supposedly close
the borders. A lie. Hillary will not. Trump will appoint conservative
Supreme Court justices. Unlikely. This one he was wrong on. Hillary
will not. No matter how bad Trump is. The argument goes against.
The argument goes conservatives will have a duty to back the
anti-Hillary. I think Trump will get blown out in the general
election. But let's assume that these critics of never Trump
are right. Let's assume that. But for
let's assume that but for we never Trump voters sitting out the
election, Trump would become president and Hillary would go down
in flames in a flaming defeat. And let's assume that Hillary
Clinton will appoint terrible justices, destroy the military,
and usher in the
Why in the world would conservatives live with President Hillary
Clinton on their consciences?
Because first, it's not on our consciences. It's on the consciences
of the people who went along with this nomination. We did not
select Trump. We will not vote for him. And if we are going to
save the country, it will not rest on one or two justices on
the Supreme Court. It will rest on the will of the people to
resist tyranny.
Bro, I like actually it's I knew this would be surreal because
I knew that Ben Shapiro had essentially what is the Democrat
position on Trump today in 2016. I remember it very specifically.
Okay, this is more about the cadence than the tone. I'm not I
can't capture Ben Shapiro's tone correctly. This is about his
cadence that will start at the state and local level. It will
start with the people. It will start with conservatives willing
to say no. Because if we never say no, we will never have the
opportunity to say yes. We must have a conservative party. The
Republican party is not the party and has not been for a very
long time or sorry is not that party and has not been for a very
long time. The Obama administration has brought about a unique
moment, a transformational choice for the party. Will they abandon
all conservative principle in pursuit of victory or will they
turn back to conservatism they supposedly espouse?
This entire election cycle, the answer has been the former. In
fact, for virtually my entire life, the answer has been the former.
Establishment Republicans abandoned Reganism for Bushism and
then abandoned Bushism for McCainism and then abandoned McCainism
for Romneyism. Until the last five minutes, they were ready to
embrace Trump himself rather than getting behind Senator Ted
Cruz.
Now they call for conservatives to swallow hard and unify behind
a man who opposes all conservative principles to save conservatism.
All throat, no gut. In every election cycle, the establishment
insists that we hide No, it's just going to it's going to start
going in a direction that I don't want to go in. The establishment
insists that we unify behind a candidate who does not reflect
conservatism because elections are always a choice between the
two worst options. They blackmail conservatives into supporting
candidates who undermine the message and morality of our mission.
Now Trump does the same. The establishment created the Donald
Trump phenomenon with their best of two bad options logic. And
now Trump is using the logic to destroy conservatism openly.
The establishment doesn't object to Trumpism. They only object
to Trump. Strip the drunken bore antics from Trump and you've
got John McCain who will lie transparently to pander to the populist
The populace. Oh, you got a problem with populism.
The Daily Wire is the populist news network.
The Daily Wire is the bullhorn for populism in America. It has
been for 4 years.
But apparently, you know, lying to pander transparently to the
populist wing is disgusting to Ben Shapiro in
Puggyups. What is a woman? Puggyups. What is a woman?
Get the [__] out of here if you think that's not
pandering to the populace wing. It absolutely is. Okay. Thank
you. Sorry.
I'm sorry to get I'm sorry to get harsh. My bad. Uh we don't
have to be complicit. As Ben Dominic is fond of citing, Alexander
Hamilton once wrote, "If we must have an enemy at the head of
government, let it be one whom we can oppose and for whom we
are not responsible. Let us be not be our own enemies. Now is
the time to say no. No is a useful tool." in conserv if conservatives
don't say no to Nelson Rockefeller in 1964, there is no Ronald
Reagan. If conservatives don't say no to Gerald Ford in 1976
and George HW Bush in 1980, there is no Ronald Reagan. If we
don't say and if we don't say no to Donald Trump now, we will
continue drifting even further left, diluting conservatism into
the vacasillating demagogic absurdity of Trumpism. Conservatism
will become the cryptoracist pseudor quasy tyrannical toxic brew
leftists have always accused it of being. Holy [__]
Ben Shapiro was a genius. Ben Shapiro pondered the orb and he
said exactly what would happen if you support Donald Trump. And
then he cut the [__] out and supported Donald Trump
openly.
It's so obvious what's going on here.
And we will have been complicit in that. I will not be complicit
in that. I stand against the establishment that sewed the seeds
of Trumpism. I stand against the Republican party that insists
that victory matters more than principle because victory without
principle isn't just meaningless, it's counterproductive to my
belief system. Hash never Trump. I can't think of a more scathing
and and
sort of
just totally on the money takedown of Ben Shapiro than the words
Ben Shapiro wrote for himself in 2016. And so in fact, I see
I just see Nick Fentes as like this karmic bomb that's come to
wipe out all of these never Trump people, right? that that are
now going, "Oh, well, never Fuentes." No, you already you opened
Pandora's box. You've already made it so the truth doesn't matter.
And now you will you've sewn the wind.
Prepare to reap the whirlwind.
Hold on a second. What is >> CNN, the president should
the president know who he's pardoning pardoning Mark Wayne Mullen.
Who the [__] is Mark Wayne Mullen? Who the [__]
is this incredibly like goofy conservative caricature
in a cowboy hat? >> Should the president who he's pardoning.
>> Well, I don't I don't know anything about this one.
That's the first time I've seen that. Uh but I would say the
>> senator. Oh, I didn't know he was I don't know the deep
red state senators. Okay. Senator
Oklahoma. I feel like I know most of the Republican senators.
I know most of the Senate roster. That's crazy. I just didn't
know who this guy >> Has the authority to pardon people
and uh and that's within his realm to do it. So, I'm not going
to question who he pardons, who he doesn't pardon. But the argument
from should the president know >> this is this is exactly
what it is right
man there's parallels here it's like you have to you have to
have some sort of internal understanding of what's true and false
because if you don't have that if you let somebody else especially
somebody who's transparently grifting transparently lying just
using like some cultlike following to convince you that they're
correct if you follow that person and you let them be be your
like sense of right and wrong you will always you will always
find yourself running a foul of that, right? If you don't have
your own strong developed sense of what right and wrong is, you
will consistently be defending the the most wrong things, things
that are totally antithetical to your own principles, like this
guy is now. Oh. Oh, uh, Trump's just pardoning somebody he's
never heard of. Oh, well, you know, I've never heard about that.
I don't know what that is, man. I don't perpage, but that's just
weird. I don't I don't know. These people just need to not be
so survile, okay? They needed to find spines a long time ago.
Ben Shapiro needed to find a spine. I kind of wanted to read
this article. What else do I got here? I wanted to go from this
into just another thing that Ben I noticed after October 7th
we covered this on stream. Okay, it was Ben when he was quite
upset about the way the Republican party was embracing conspiracy
theory and again I do believe right here right
cryptoracist pseudo strong quasi toxic
uh demagogic absurdity of Trumpism. He he basically says this
here, right? That you're basically going to have somebody who
is it's not going to matter what the truth is. Our principles
won't matter. We'll get like swept up and and
we'll get swept out to sea. Okay.
From here, I wanted to go to him commenting on
conspiracy theories he was seeing in the media and why it was
upsetting to him. Oh, he's muted. Ben, don't be muted. >> And
once Americans believe that they
>> because he is the person who convinced Americans they
could believe this. Okay, he is the one. It's all Ben. It's all
Ben doing this. He is one of the biggest propagators of Sorry,
not him. Actually, I shouldn't say him specifically. His network,
the Daily Wire, is one of the biggest propagators of like conspiratorial
thinking. They totally support because it gets tons of views.
They're all all of the people, Candace Owens at the time, uh
so Candace,
Jordan Peterson, Matt Walsh, Michael Nolles, they were all people
who would propagate conspiracy theories in one way or another.
Okay? or conspiratorial thinking at the very least. There was
a lot of us versus them. Oh, the elites are us over all the time
rhetoric. Guess what? If you're going to do that programming,
elites are us over. Elites are [__] us over. It's
all them. It's all them. It's all them. It's all them. It's only
a matter of time until the them is not the elite. It's not the
rich people in America.
Who else is them? Who's they? Who else? Ben might be a group
you support. Might be a group you're a part of. Right? you're
going to support that kind of thinking constantly. It's going
to come back to bite you. And we're going to watch Ben describe
what he he's going to describe something he pretends not to >> All
groups of people in shady rooms making decisions for all of society.
And so now we are in >> here. Hold on. We're going to go
all the way back to >> So writes even further. He says,
"What was one of the chief factors?" >> Oh, he's reading
he's reading Ilan Paping to the exacerbation of conspiracy theory
of society. Why has this become so prevalent? He's writing this
in the 40s.
He says the big problem is what he called discretionary powers
designed to empower organs of the state to act within certain
limits as they consider necessary for achieving the ends laid
down by the and this is precisely what we talked about on this
stream for months and months and months. Dustin Suggs is a ton
of people. You heard them talk about it, right? Candace Owens
talked about it. How the Daily Wire, a bunch of the writers there
would tell them, "Oh, like I'm like, oh, I I watch this kid.
I'm a fan of this kid." Right? Like 40-year-old men, 50-year-old
men watch Fuentes, they write or or just thought leaders in the
conservative movement and then they write for these shows and
stuff, right? Their ideas are the ones that are circulating.
It's all the same populist messaging. It's all the same like
anti-intellectual messaging.
And yes, it is only a matter of time until the person who is
coming up with that messaging, who is the main propagator of
that messaging, who best understands that messaging, it's only
a matter of time until they come in and they reprogram just a
little bit and suddenly, you know, you've been h it's like uh
hold on, we're going to find
JD Vance's close friend warns that 40% of GOP staffers under
the age of 30 are gropers. political gatekeeping. The conservative
writer Rod Dreer, a close friend of Vance, warned, "I am told
by someone in a position to know that something like 30 to 40%
of DC GOP staffers under the age of 30 are gropers." Usha Vance,
by the way, if you watch Fuentes talk, his talking points on
Usha Vance, he doesn't even believe them.
Fuentes was incredibly until Fuentes realized that this was an
angle to attack JD Vance on, he was incredibly complimentary
of Usha Vance consistently. the first couple times he saw Usha
Vance totally complimentary, but it's like uh I I think it's
funny that this I hope JD doesn't get like scoped by it. Okay,
we'll see.
Um yeah, this is interesting. I've seen some similar stuff to
this though, that a lot of these people are are gropers.
I've seen I've seen this a lot. No, he's I He's not. It's Trust
me, he's not. If JD Vance was going to go and run in this field
or whatever and
I'm I'm not going to bother talking about it. I can't I can't
convince people. Okay. I can't convince people.
Anyway, I'm going to go back to watching. We're watching Ben
Shapiro describe what he hates about conspiratorial thinking,
conspiratorial movements. Yeah, conspiratorial movements. All
right. You go listen to him talk about this >> rulers for
the time. >> This is in where was this? March 20 March
29th, 2024. This is shortly after the Candace stuff, right? I
think it's shortly after Candace exits Daily Wire and he's talking
about how much he hates conspiratorial thinking. >> So
centralization of power turns into we need to act against the
conspiracy and we can't go through any sort of predictable process.
We can't go through any legalistic process because it might get
thwarted. We need to solve the problem fast and the best way
to do that more centralized power in the hands of an unanswerable
few. He writes, "The use of discretionary powers is liable to
grow quickly once it has become an accepted method since adjustments
to discretionary short-term decisions can hardly be carried out
by institutional means. You're going to have to move too fast.
You can't go through like a legislature. You can't go through
a budgetary process. You need to have an administrative state
that can move quickly and it needs to be able to do things at
a moment's notice and it doesn't have to make its excuses to
you because after all, there's a conspiracy of foot and that
conspiracy can only be thwarted by centralized collective power
through discretionary means."
Uh, so
do I have to go back? Ben's Ben's explaining how populists Okay,
is he memeing? He is not memeing. He's explaining how populists
will use conspiracies to explain why they need executive power.
Where are his criticisms of Trump? Where are they? That's exactly
he's describing Trump's playbook one to one. This is I believe
it's I believe it's Poppe. Not Elon Poe. I said Elon Poppe. It's
uh Carl Popper. I believe it's Carl Pa he's reading right. the
a philosopher. >> He says this tendency must greatly increase
the irrationality of the system, creating in many the impression
that there are actually hidden powers behind the scenes, making
them susceptible to the conspiracy theory of society with all
of its consequences, heresy hunts, national, social, and class
hostility.
So, you give the government a lot of power, you centralize power,
and then you use that centralized power in order to push discretionary
power and then discretionary power because it doesn't look predictable,
because it doesn't look rational. That breeds more conspiracy
theories because now you actually do have small groups of people
in shady rooms making decisions for all of society. And so now
we are in a death spiral, a conspiracy theory death spiral that
ends with the belief by the vast majority of Americans that they
are now victims in the society. And once Americans believe that
they are victims of societal institutions around them,
like all of the Democrats using the deep state and every institution
of the federal government to ruin lives because they want to
bring in brown people and make an Democrat like infinite majority.
Kind of like that. Kind of like the thing every single Daily
Wire commentator talks about, Ben. Kind of like that.
And that freedom is not the answer. Individual freedom is not
the answer. Collective power is the answer. That's the end of
the American dream. It's totally dead.
You can draw this out on a flowchart. I want to do this just
for for one second because it's actually a pretty simple way
to see exactly where the country is going if this doesn't stop
right now. Okay, so everything starts with a problem. Dude, we
I lost my I think I only had like 50 viewers when I originally
watched this or something. I I don't think I had that many viewers
when I did this episode. I remember cuz I wrote out all the stuff.
I lost my mind watching this cuz he is quite literally writing
out the the like game plan for the Daily Wire while complaining
that it's being used against people. Hey, so the problem is real.
Okay, the question is, is it an individual problem or a collective
problem? Is this a problem that you could solve on an individual
level or is this a problem that has to be solved by the mass
power of the collective? The vast majority of problems in your
life are solvable on an individual or local community level.
That has been true for a very long time in the United States.
Doesn't mean there aren't big collective problems that we need
to solve together. It means that those are pretty few in number
in a free country like the United States. We are not living in
Sarist Russia.
Okay. So the next move that people make a problem really is a
claim of victimhood. You're being victimized by something. Sometime
that's true, sometimes that's not.
The next thing that happens is that you blame that on society.
Right? So instead of you internalizing the problem, trying to
fix the problem, instead you blame the society. And once you
blame the society, you very quickly end up if you >> He's
talking about blaming like the
He's talking about blaming like the institutions of society.
>> You do not have evidence at a conspiracy theory. Okay,
now you have a conspiracy theory. There's a group of people who
are stopping you from solving your problem. You blame society.
You don't have an answer. So it must be a conspiracy. There must
be some sort. And you're just asking questions. You don't know.
Right? This is the game that is played by so many corrupt commentators.
Just asking questions. I don't have to show you evidence that
something terrible is happening. I don't have to actually demonstrate
how the thing is happening. I don't have to tell you who the
problem is. Wink wink. But I can just tell you right now that
there is a but and and if I'm asked about it, hey, I'm just asking
questions. Now, let me tell you something about just asking questions
for a second. Just asking questions is a game for children. My
son is seven. He can just ask questions. My daughter is 10. She
can just ask questions. If you are 50 and you are just asking
questions, I don't think you're just asking questions. I think
that your level of curiosity is actually quite low. I think that
you don't care enough to know or know enough to care. I think
that the vast majority of people who are in the just asking questions
business have an answer that they want to suggest, but they know
there's no evidence for it. So instead, they hide behind just
asking questions. In other words, they're completely full of
So
no way. That's Dude, it's
I I just grabbed this time stamp today. This is from again March
29th, 2024.
It's so wild that he did this. It's so wild that he couldn't
see any of the stuff any of his fellow commentators, his employees
were doing. Couldn't see that as bad. And then October 7th happened
and he's like, "Oh my god, this like conspiratorial thinking
model, this is evil."
You get, but then you go back to 2016 and you realize he totally
understands what demagogues do. He totally understands how bad
voting for Trump will be. He totally understands the path America's
going on and he's just there for the ride cuz he's collecting
the baddest paycheck on planet Earth to the conspiracy theory.
Now, in order to solve the conspiracy theory, you need to mobilize
collective power, right? Because you have a conspiracy. The conspiracy
can only be fought. It can't be fought by an individual. It has
to be fought by centralization of collective power. It's the
only way to do it.
Okay? And and then there you have a problem. As Popper says,
collective power tends to be pretty slowm moving and large and
unwieldy. So then what you have to do is you have to delegate
that. You have to delegate that collective power to some sort
of discretionary
power. You have to delegate it to the discretionary power, right?
Because once you delegate it to the discretionary power, then
they can handle the problem. The problem is that the discretionary
power actually >> guys, you have to let Trump be like a
dictator. You have to like actually allow the executive to do
everything because there's a deep state. How is he going to deal
with the deep state if he doesn't have all of this power, all
of this discretionary power? If we don't get the Supreme Court
to like declare all of his acts like immune, I'm not going to
go out
because now you actually have a small group of people who have
been allocated outsized power without answerability or accountability
and that group of people can now be blamed for other failings
because they in fact will be involved in those failings. And
so what you end up with is, wait for it,
you've shortcuted the first couple of steps. You end up back
at the conspiracy theory and now you're in a spiral. Now you're
in a never- ending spiral. More conspiracy theories requires
more collective power requires more discretionary power, which
leads to more conspiracy theories. More collective power, more
discretionary power.
Wow. He really just mapped it out like that. Oh my goodness.
Oh, sure. Sure. Evil Johnny Bravo, is this like a human thing
to do that you can't see why this is bad? why you can't see it
when it's happening to somebody else. Yeah, that's absolutely
a human thing to do. I'm still going to call him a total piece
of because he talked about this precise thing in 2016 and he's
been supporting Trump the whole time. And with Trump, I think
he knows because he didn't start he didn't start at the place
with Trump where he liked Trump and he was just blinded. He started
with the place at the place with Trump where he hated Trump.
He knew exactly what he was. He called it out. Called out all
the populist that his he quit his job as the head article or
sorry the head editor of Breitbart. I believe he quit to go start
his own news network because he hated Trump so much and within
like 6 months to a year they were fully dethrowing Donald Trump
anyway and so on and that's how freedom dies through the power
of collective conspiracy theories and that is where we are there's
only one way to break that chain the one way to break that chain
is to say to yourself and say to the society stop being whiny
stop pretending that every problem is a collective problem if
you have a problem show the evidence of the so we can all solve
it together. Ghost hunting is not meant to actually find the
ghost. It is meant to mobilize the collective in pursuit of power.
That's what's going on politically on pretty much all sides of
the aisle right now. We have to break that chain. We have to
go back to the individual American dream. Again, doesn't mean
there aren't conspiracies. Doesn't mean there aren't bad people
trying to do bad things, but we have to be very specific about
what we are targeting and very
meticulous in our use of power in order to target it or we end
up in a very, very bad position.
Now, so
speaking of bad position, I believe the time is nigh. Oh, let
me see. Do we have this? Is this up? Where's the uh is this up?
>> American sovereignty. Do we run the world or does
>> We will probably be watching this once uh once Fuentes
is going to go live with his response. Okay.
>> Fenta is going to have his response coming up shortly.
We'll probably watch this, I would think, live.
Uh, with that, I do believe we will get off of
Twitch, though. Okay guys, we're probably going to go to kick
only for the rest of the stream. If you guys want to head to
kickon, it's kick.com/jstk.
All right, kick.com/jstk.
Oh, also guys, if you like the content, go ahead, follow on every
platform. Join the Discord. discord.gg/jstk.
If you really, really like the content, go ahead, throw a couple
subs my way. Throw buy a TTS message. All right, exclamation
point donate in the kick chat.
We'll give you the links. All right, that'll give you the links.
We are, let me see where we're at. We are
11 subs from two more hours on the stream. All right, 11 subs
from two more hours on the stream. So, get your subs in now.
Let's make this work. All right, let's make this work. Okay.
All right. Ending the Twitch stream, guys. We'll see you on kick.
All right. Bye-bye. Where am I?
All right. Multireaming off. We're good to go.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool,
Let me see here. Uh, he's supposed to start at 9, so I don't
know when this is going to happen. I'll I'll keep it up on my
other monitor and we'll we'll just see when we can get over to
that. All right, in the meantime,
we do have there's a fl there's a Fantas Flandis. Flandis Flandis
Owens. I was I was talking about Candace and I started saying
Fuentes. So, there's a Candace Owens response as well. Candace
Owens started talking about this because she gets sideswiped
by Ben Shapiro. She goes ahead and talks about it. We'll look
at the Fentes tweet in response here real quick.
Oh, he's about to go live as well. No to Ben Shapiro. No to the
neocons. No to dual citizens. No to Benjamin Netanyahu. No to
cancel culture. No to genocide and ethnic cleansing. No to the
Christ-hating Talmud. No to greater Israel. No to our oligarchy.
America first. America forever is what he says.
That was his response. And then I believe he said, "We're going
live at 9 central,"
which is 2 minutes ago. Probably going to be late, I would imagine.
All right, we got those. Let's check out the Candace response
real quick and then we'll we'll flip over once Fentes goes live.
We'll check that >> All right, you guys. Happy Monday.
MAGA civil war. People that listen to this podcast have already
accepted that the >> Zionist attack on Tucker about Charlie's
Erica Kirk speaks. Cash Patel. Oh, dude. >> question really
is just >> We'll do the Cash Patel stuff after. Okay. The
Cash Patel stuff. Very, very, very funny. >> Now, how fake
are we talking? What shade of gayness are we talking? And I think
we should start with the Lindsey Graham shade which he threw
at American voters. So, what happened was he was on stage at
the Republican
coalition. Okay. He and many others, by the way, many other congressmen
basically directed their >> Am I crazy? I could have sworn
that Candace Owens specifically responded to Ben Shapiro here.
Here we go.
>> She does respond to Ben >> attack on Tuck. Quite
stunned. Keep me in context. There's a lot people can vote for
me. All that aside, I have to say that I was quite stunned that
he found within himself, Ben, the audacity to present this attack
on Tucker as a noble defense of Charlie. Here is what Ben said
in his own words.
>> There's no question that Tucker has become the most
virulent super spreader of vile ideas in America. And the rest
of us who oppose those vile ideas have every right to call him
that. There is one other element here that's even darker if possible.
Tucker Carlson prays on the friendship he proclaims with others
and then he knifs them directly between the shoulder blades when
convenient for him. Tucker Carlson is in short a terrible friend.
Tucker Carlson was supposedly Charlie Kirk's friend. Charlie
believed that Nick Fuentes was vermin. That's a direct quote.
He believed that because Nick Fuentes dedicated his life to destroying
Charlie Kirk and TPUSA from the inside.
So, first and foremost, the idea that in order for you to show
that you are a good friend of somebody, you have to agree not
to host people on your platform from conversations is is just
so anti-Ch. It's unbelievable. which it's just it is disrespectful
really to his lo legacy. Um and it is simply a fact which I feel
comfortable sharing now that Charlie and Ben Shapiro did not
get along. uh because Charlie found out that Ben was operating
behind the scenes to uh stop him and sort of hinder the growth
of Turning Point USA in our early days, right, when things when
we were kind of coming up together, me and Charlie as partners
getting out there. And I have >> The funny thing here is
I literally don't even believe this. Like Candace lies about
so much on a personal level, especially Charlie. I don't even
necessarily believe that this is happening or this would have
happened. >> Only about 80 to 150 text messages from Charlie
to that effect. This is not a debate, by the way. This is a fact.
So, challenge me to share the messages. I I will gladly. Now,
when Charlie tried to figure out where the sudden hostility was
coming from, because he at first admired Ben, like I admired
Ben. Uh, actually, Charlie was the one that told me, "You should
watch Ben debate videos so you can strengthen your debate skills."
The next thing we knew, we were hearing that he was trying to
block us. And they had a a conversation. Ben told Charlie, again,
this is according to my messages with Charlie, that Ben was in
part upset because I made a joke about him, a literal light-hearted
joke when I appeared on Joe Rogan back in 2018.
Um, do we have that clip, Skyler? We can roll that.
Like, I can't take anything seriously anymore.
>> well, there's things to be taken seriously, but celebrities
probably aren't on that list. >> So, Ben Shapiro's right.
>> Yeah. No. Well, he's right about this, you know, but
he was like trying to correlate like what Kim did like with Alice
Marie Johnson with like that. And I'm like, come on, man. That's
like totally different. And just in general, like sometimes he
just gets a little like Hall monitor for me. Like, you know,
like it's just like, you know, >> he can't help himself.
>> I know. He's a funny guy. He's He's very snarky. I like
him. >> Ben couldn't have been that mad about this, right?
Like, objectively,
Ben hired Candace after this. I don't know why she's running
this as if this is like, oh, proof Ben Shapiro hated us cuz I
made a joke about him. She literally he he literally hired you
after this, Gandice. What are you talking about? >> I like
him, too. That's the thing. It's like we actually really get
along, but like the hall monitor, like I know these types in
school. Like I was in their classes, you know, like they're just
>> you're like late to school or like the last person you
want to see is like the hall monitor. Like you know, like the
idea like that she would be late, right? Like he's writing you
a pink slip. It's like Ben, just give me the pink slip, dude.
Like that. Just give it to me, Ben. All right. like right like
you know this is a gateway to Saturday school like it's just
like >> that's a good impression of him
>> light-hearted joke but specifically Ben's head to Charlie
>> dude somehow Joe Rogan gets it in there that he has
no idea what is funny what comedy is a great impression no it
wasn't that was a horrible impression >> he was upset about
that and that he I Candace was going to Milo my career if Charlie
didn't get away from me now obviously the story goes Charlie
stuck with me despite Ben's urging. We kept climbing. We reached
a point where as a team, Charlie and I were suddenly undeniable.
Some producer in June of 2018 then reached out to us to book
us on Ben's show. And honestly, I'm so glad they did this because
in retrospect, it's actually one of my favorite Charlie memories
because it just makes me smile to reflect on because Charlie,
he was never meanspirited.
He always was just funny. He always chose humor, light-hearted
humor to get over any situation. He was never a person that wheeled
and dealed behind the scenes to prevent other people from becoming
successful. It just >> We've literally seen like two different
DM leaks in the past like since he passed away saying don't debate
this. Don't don't platform this person. What are you talking
about? Gettis >> wasn't in him, right? He wasn't
>> She's just lying. She's just like openly lying. I guess
>> vengeance is actually kind of the vice that I have had
to work on a lot. But Charlie's perspective was just laugh and
move on. Anyway, the story goes, we get the invite to be on Ben
Shapiro's show. And I'm like, "No, f that. He was so awful to
us. He said this about me mileing my career. We should not do
his show. Why would we do his show?" And Charlie's like, "No,
it's great. Let's do it because we won." >> Uh, not no
shot astronaut. She's saying that Charlie Kirk was never somebody
who would reach out and say, "Don't platform this person. Don't
give them an opportunity." And it's like, no, he's done that
plenty with Nick Fentes. We've seen conservative influencers
leak those DMs that show exactly that. And again, I don't even
think I don't have like a lot of judgment for him saying that
he thinks Nick Fentes is bad or or going to be harmful to to
the conservative movement. I think that's probably correct, right?
But her saying that he's never done this to anyone when it's
like, oh, we've seen multiple leaks in the past month, month
and a half showing that he has done it to people is weird to
cope and not deal in reality at all. >> Okay, we won, Candace.
And I'm like, okay, fine. We get to the location. I think it
was in Sherman Oaks, California, uh, at that time. And Charlie
says to me, we're in the green green green room. Hey, when we
take a photo with him, I'm going to puff my chest out and stand
extra tall so we never forget this moment of us having triumphed
over Ben Shapiro.
And he actually does it and it was completely hilarious. And
this is actually the photo from that. Charlie did that totally
on purpose. It was such a Charlie Kirk thing to do. And it became
like our perfect inside joke every time we felt like he was kind
of saying little things about us. And that was Charlie. That
was just the spirit of Charlie. And >> Oh, so he was like
a mean girl. He was like somebody and now you're going to tell
everybody that he's a mean Why does she make Charlie Kirk seem
like the most duplicitousest [__] on planet Earth
every time she speaks?
It's actually crazy. I don't even believe that. I actually don't
believe that at all. I just She's just making Charlie Kirk seem
bad for no reason. She thinks it's funny. just to get one over
on Ben Shapiro. She's like, "Actually, Charlie didn't like you."
That's her response to everybody talking about her recently.
Actually, I knew Charlie and Charlie hated you. Actually, Charlie
hated you. >> He was always cordial uh beyond that. He
never felt any nastiness.
The point of me sharing this though is to make it very clear
uh that Charlie loved Tucker. I can go through all the messages
with
>> Charlie and he loved Tucker. Not for a single second
did he not admire and respect and greatly appreciate Tucker.
And he fought for Tucker to be on the turning point stage until
his dying day. Literally, Charlie was not in love with Ben Shapiro.
He didn't hate Ben Shapiro. He just, I would say, experienced
Ben Shapiro. We all get the Ben Shapiro experience at some point.
Despite this, he always, as I said, kept it cordial because that's
who he was as a person. I really thought Candace did more on
the specific talk. Sorry, the specific Ben Shapiro's statement,
but it looks like she just grabbed the one thing. Interesting.
I would have thought she'd do more
cuz she did get hit as well. She said her response was coming
and then it was mostly just other Zionists talking about um Dr.
Carlson. But what I will not allow is this absolute inversion
of reality where Ben Shapiro becomes any sort of voice on who
is and who is not betraying their friendship with Charlie. I
will not allow it. Like I said, everybody has a vice. And when
I reflect on Charlie's, it is probably that he associated
success and growth with money. And I believe that that is probably
the conduit uh for the snakes that I that got into his company,
got the donor. Honestly, in the middle of this, I'm just thinking
I want to go read this Vice article and see if sorry, Vox article
and see if there's anything else here. Former Breitbart editor
on what Trump's victory means for the alt-right. They truly believe
that multi-thnic democracies cannot succeed. former Breitbart
editor Ben Shapiro.
A f a few days after winning the presidency, Donald Trump announced
he his first two hires. Ryan Priebus, the current RNC chair,
will serve as White House chief of staff and Steve Bannon, executive
chair of the alt-right website, breitbart.com, will serve as
chief strategist and senior counselor to the president. If the
alt-right isn't Oh, come on. Shut up. Come on, box.
Hold on. I got to go to an archive of this. God darn it. I just
spelled archive incorrectly. Oh,
hold on. Archive. Can you give me an archive of this?
Wait, they really don't have this
Oh, what the hell?
Like this? Anything? Nothing. Oh, well that's weird. Oh, well,
we're not doing that either. We're >> a second. >> Me.
I don't suffer. >> I might I might have to start moving
on to the cash patell segment if we don't have this. >> I
don't care about money. I would gladly, as you have seen me do,
burn it all to the ground to get out one modicum of truth.
And if you'd like to hear something else that happens to be true,
in the immediate aftermath of Charlie's death, uh, people that
were extremely close to Charlie, including donors, were very
touched by a monologue that Matt Walsh did over on the Daily
Wire. I didn't see it. I was too agreved to watch anything, but
apparently Matt Walsh did an amazing monologue. So, uh, the team
reached out to host Matt Walsh, to ask Matt Walsh, rather, uh,
to host Charlie Kirk show because they wanted to keep it going.
And they were told that that was not allowed to happen unless
Ben Shapiro was also invited.
And in the true spirit of Charlie Kirk, Turning Point, cordially
accepted those posthumis terms. Anyways, those are the
>> Posthumis. Okay. >> Turning my attention. I probably
shouldn't be too harsh on misspeaks, but god damn. >> To
another matter, uh, Israel
is rather obsessed with this already failed operation to stage
a hostile takeover of the legacy of Charlie Kirk. So obsessed
that the Jerusalem Post completely fictionalized,
or rather published a
Candace pretending to be so close to Charlie for clout is disgusting.
It's so disgusting. Uh, she's not pretending. They were really
close friends. I think it's gross that she's like weaponizing
that and then she's telling stories and all these stories paint
Charlie as like somebody who didn't like all these people and
apparently kept it to himself which just makes him look worse.
So if they're true I think she should keep them to herself in
a lot of cases. And if they're false then that's even more gross,
right? But I they were actually friends. They were very very
close friends. Like they went on vacations together and all the
time.
It's not like fake to say that they're friends. That's not That's
not a lie. Definitely not.
She makes him look and sound gay. All right. Well, listen. He
just really likes Cardi B. Okay. What What are we supposed to
do? Charlie loved Cardi B. I've got some more adjacent content.
I saw I saw Richard Hanady was tweeting while I was live. So,
give me a second. I think all he does is he tweets and then he
puts articles under all of his tweets. He like does funny tweets
and then he links his substack.
NT using the best photo of Nick Fuentes I've ever seen to crown
him Charlie Kirk's successor. Did they really use an AI
optimized photo of Nick Fuentes? That's not a real photo of Nick
Fuentes. That is a totally AIed photo of Nick Fuentes. They found
like a photoshopped photo of him to use in this article. That's
a bit weird. No. Nick Fentes was Charlie Kirk's bitter enemy.
Now he's becoming his successor.
Interesting. Backwatch 2021.
You don't know. Wait, what? That's not That's not him. I'm telling
you that's not him. Wow. We really don't hate the media enough.
Yes, they're the ones who did this to you.
Uh Hania is like pretty based, okay, in a lot of ways.
Oh, this was the one. Heritage staffer in private group chats
as more and more of interns agree with Fentes. This was the one
from the New York Post. I was going to read
Heritage Foundation in revolt over Tucker Carlson defense after
controversial Nick Fentes interview. Footsie with literal
Okay.
God. Oh, whoops. Just meant to delete message. Apparently Sneo
and Aerite are talking right now.
It's probably going to be like, "Sneo, you did so good against
Myron. You're so awesome." Oh, what? Oh, they were talking. Now
they're not talking.
>> What happened to Sneo's stream? You can watch this for
a second while we were uh waiting. when the tape brothers were
seen at the rest of the year.
>> Oh, because I grumpy with you if you come with a whole
lot of robots. >> Oh, he died. >> No, he didn't die.
What the [__]
>> Hold on. He just went offline.
>> Say nothing. >> Especially a few months ago.
>> Is this
>> So, he wants to talk. Yeah. Know, it's good to talk
to people from different sides. You know what I'm saying?
Whatever. Whatever. >> Is he on YouTube? He might be >> going
to get in there and go, "You need
>> Dude, this guy's [__] crazy. This guy's
out of his [__] mind. There's no way. Okay, he's
not he's not live right now. I for a second I was like going
to see like, is there any way that he'd be live right now? Could
you imagine if he was live and he did that [__] That
would be insane,
dude. That was
that was a wild moment right there. He's on party at the moment.
Hold on. Maybe he's Maybe he's live on Is he still talking to
Ardite? Because I was just going to watch this conversation with
Ardite before the Oh, >> I was saying ironically that that's
what I would do. Why are you watching the rest of this videos
instead of talking to me?
>> Because I
>> I think this is the >> great show for you tonight.
Very excited to be back after Monday. We have a lot to talk about
tonight. Lots to get into.
big show.
There has been so much happening over the past week. I'm sure
you've seen it >> Yeah, that's okay. We can go back to
that later. It's not related to the big story that I >> interview
with Tucker Carlson last Monday is when it came out exactly a
week ago.
>> And I believe a few days after that, I tried to get
back into the regular news. We were going to talk all about the
conflict in the Middle East, the conflict in Venezuela.
It seems like the whole world is devolving into a world
And hopefully at some point we can return to that and engage
in some highlevel analysis about all that. But for now we are
still talking about this GOP civil war.
And I'm sure you know what I'm talking
Last week on Thursday,
the president of the Heritage Foundation, a major conservative
think tank, put out a video defending Tucker
for interviewing me. I don't like the word platforming. Everybody
says platform. I have a platform. I have the biggest platform.
I have one of the biggest platforms.
My clips go viral. My show is huge.
So they use this term. They say he gave him a platform. We need
to no platform him. This is the I'm on a platform right
They're trying to cancel him literally for talking to me. He
didn't agree with everything I said. He didn't agree with everything
I've ever said.
We had a conversation and now Tucker Carlson is being cancelled
by a small but very vocal group of pro-Israel
and in the conservative movement. And so last Thursday, the president
of the Heritage Foundation put out a video statement which I
thought was very >> Wait, why would you why would you put
that's
He could have just said people the conservative. He just said
exgroup and not exgroup. Okay, that's like me saying, um, yeah,
listen, I'm loved by black people and not black people. So, okay.
I don't know why you actually s
Huh? Why did you do Why did you do that? very strong. >> That's
weird. >> I don't think there was anything objectionable
in it. Obviously, I'm biased, but I think that objectively
there was nothing objectionable in it. And I think any normal
person, especially any conservative, would agree, and I covered
it extensively on my show last Thursday. He said, among other
things, that conservatives don't engage in cancel culture. Heritage
will not abandon Tucker Carlson.
He said that he disagrees with my views, but I have a right to
express them. He said that the core of American conservatism
is
Christ is our king. America is our country, and we're in favor
of free speech.
What's wrong with that?
Well, now they're trying to get this guy fired. And so the backlash
to this was
because this is institutional
and that's what they're afraid of. They're afraid that the podcasts
and the influencers and the things that we say on our show or
suggest on our platforms,
they're starting to show up inside the Republican party and in
college and in government. And soon that means policy. They're
deeply afraid of this. And by they, I mean the pro-Israel lobby.
And so this is what they could not accept. And what we have seen
since then over the past weekend is the most
coordinated, organized, unbelievable smear campaign
that I've seen in a very long time. And to be honest with you,
you know what it reminds me of?
It reminds me of the campaign to discredit and destroy Donald
Trump in 2015 and 2016. >> Going to draw parallels. And
the reason I say that is because last year during the election,
it seemed as though the media and the institutions
had almost given up >> on cancel culture, wokeness, censorship.
Did you get this impression also?
You could be forgiven for thinking around the time of the election
last year that all that stuff was over. It was all ancient history.
And it seemed that anti-woke comedy and free speech and all these
things that we remember before the woke progressive era were
back and were here to stay.
Shane Gillis is on SNL
making edgy jokes on his appearance on his Netflix show. Donald
Trump became the president and was inaugurated without a hitch.
It seemed that Silicon Valley had acquiesced to his return to
the White House and it seemed like everything was back to normal.
We're all good
and all that crazy woke lunatic stuff was a thing of the past.
And this past weekend, uh, the last three or four days, maybe
the entire last week, >> all right, we're back. It felt
like all of that 2015 2016 era cancel culture
>> came crashing back down all of a sudden. >> This
was like the basket of deplorables moment
for the pro-Israel lobby. >> Hold on one second. >> And
remember what Hillary Clinton said in that remark?
She said racist.
I just all he has to do to convince me it's cancel culture is
say which of the clips that got played that he disagrees with
that he thinks aren't valid like oh I I totally disavow that
I don't believe that anymoreist homophobic xenophobic this basket
of deplorables it is his
it's like that level of rhetoric all over again we're seeing
the clip compilations remember when Nick Fuentes said this remember
when he said that they're doing it to Tucker doing it to It feels
exactly the same
and it ends just as it began with the exact same playbook, the
same tactics. And so tonight, I want to talk all about it. I
want to get into all of the backlash.
And the reason I put that in scare quotes is because of course
it's all fake. It's all artificial.
Specifically, I want to talk about the Heritage Foundation. and
we'll do a followup
because the last time I did a show Thursday night, I was praising
the president of Heritage, Kevin Roberts, for defending free
speech and Tucker Carlson and America First.
But since then, he came out with a muing and pathetic apology
that wasn't even written by him. I'm told it was written by somebody
else. And now he's begging for his job back, crawling on his
hands and knees like a b.
He's on Dana Lash's show. I don't know why. She looks ridiculous.
I don't think anybody under the age of 65 even knows who she
is. That isn't like a polit Okay. I I get that he's going to
go after these people. Dude, your audience doesn't barely knows
who the Heritage Founder or Heritage Foundation
president or whatever is. Dude, get get to Ben Shapiro. Get to
the actual civil war, bro. What the [__] are you
doing? >> Nerd. He goes on her show begging for
He's at Hillsdale College begging for forgiveness, talking about
anti-semitism.
So, we have to do a followup on him.
I want to talk about this Republican coalition summit which was
held in Las Vegas this weekend. What the hell is even that?
And go ahead and watch some of the clips.
It's all It's all the most popular conservatives in America.
All the most beloved popular conservatives
like Randy Stein, Lindsey Graham, Mark
>> it's all like the most reviled conservatives in America.
>> And I don't think there's any way to describe it other
than a declaration of
This was a psycho unhinged
lunatic, like truly delusional
declaration of war
by the Israel lobby >> against not just America first,
but America. And I promise you, go watch Mark Levin's speech
and tell me that that's not what it is.
This is interesting to me that he's taking this tack here because
uh you might be witnessing there's a certain way you you run
your stream whatever you want to do your movement when you're
small and you're like trying to make a name for yourselves. You're
trying to claw your way into relevancy
and he we might find Nicholas okay Nicholas Fentes he might not
be that guy who takes the movement from this tiny movement to
its like large scale version. He's like the CEO who's grown this
company massively and now he's attacking people
who are like not irrelevant. They're not irrelevant. As Levvin
said, he's going to describe what Mark Levvin said about him.
No, he's going to describe what Mark Leavin said about him. But
um he's going after people who like these these speeches, the
Republican conference speeches from Ted Cruz, from Mark Leavvin,
from Randy Fine, they're like nothing. They're like getting no
views, getting no press, and now he's driving way more attention
to them. Watch what Mark Leavvin specifically said
in his speech at the RJC, but also in his follow-up interview.
I think it's with the JNS or one of these media outlets. He did
a follow-up interview which was published, I think either last
night or today.
It was literally a declaration of war. And this is the group.
The group is the
Coalition. That's what they're called. I'm not making that up.
That's not an anti-semitic trope. That's their name. And they
held the summit and it was all about anti-semitism and Israel
and people being under attack by the right and the left on all
sides. And it was a declaration of war against America first.
Seething, raging, unhinged, emotional.
Well, >> I don't know about that. It definitely was a declaration
of war against America first. talk all about that
and then we'll talk about Ben Shapiro's video about me this afternoon.
And if you know anything about my feud with Ben Shapiro, it's
really
the way they operate.
The way that Ben Shapiro operates. If you know anything about
this feud, you know what I'm talking about.
For the last 10 years,
Ben Shapiro has pretended like I don't exist. Nick Fuentes who
even if you ask him directly about me he won't utter my name.
It's like my name itself is a curse. It's like the words Nick
Fuentes are
not able to be spoken aloud.
That's that's how he is. He he literally will that's that's by
design, right? When he was deplatformed for everything, if you
don't say the name, nobody's ever going to stumble across Nick
Fuentes, right? So some of the only ways he could like grow or
have any oxygen brought to his stream, his movement, everything
is for people to say his name. So they would just avoid it, >> not
say my name. But today it was a clip show. Today it was like
a full-fledged Fentis updates clip show. It was like America's
Funniest Videos,
one clip after the 40 minutes, no ads. That's how you know they
mean business.
When Ben Shapiro turns down the money from the advertisers, when
Ben Shapiro doesn't do, let's say, 50 ad reads in a 50minute
video. >> This is again kind of unfortunate
because he just stole this as the top YouTube comment. Okay,
this was the top YouTube comment. Nick, come on, man. At least
source damn lurker on this one eight hours ago. You know Ben
is serious when there isn't a single ad read in the video. Come
on, bro. That's how you know they mean business.
>> He will literally do an ad at a prolife march in person.
He will give a speech in real life at a prolife march about abortion
and he will stop and do an ad read for Zip Recruiter.
But when you're talking about
there's simply no. But that's funny. >> There's no time.
We mean business. Cuz this is something we really care about.
No ads, 40inute video,
and about 50% of it was just my clips. Fuentes, Fuentes, that
he's a
Holocaust
Whoa, you're sounding like you're giving me like Bill Mayor,
Rachel Matto. What is this?
I thought Shapiro was against SJWs.
Now he sounds like one of them.
I thought he was against liberal tears and cancel culture and
safe spaces. Now you sound like one of them.
So first Nick went to set a thing. Then he said a racist thing.
Then he said a thing and and an anti-semitic thing.
He's a white sup. It's Hillary
Racist
homophob.
It's literally the basket of deplorables clip.
And so we'll go through we'll talk about his little response.
And I say little because he doesn't get views anymore. It's >> Oh
boy. >> Can Owens is doing 10 times. What does she get?
Two, three million views on a video. He's lucky to crack a half
And he's on YouTube. He's got millions of subscribers.
>> Uh so we'll talk about his little his littlest show,
the clip show about me. and th that'll be our show. We'll talk
about each of these things as they're developing
and we'll get into what it's really about. Of course,
at the end of the day,
it's like anything else. They can say whatever they want and
it's all a conceit.
It's a shell game. They want you to look over here, look over
there.
It's about a [__] from 2020.
Guys, I understand that Trump said some bad things. I understand
that Trump's done some bad things, but like Democrats are protecting
a global cabal of
don't pay any attention to that. Okay? Don't pay any attention.
Listen, I don't pay any attention to the bad things Trump does.
There's there's a global cabal cabal of that you have to focus
on. All right?
Don't
He's He's describing the shell game to you while setting up the
shell game where Nick Fuentes was an edge lord. Does anybody
think that's what this is really about?
Kevin Roberts, Mark Leavvin, Ben
they say in 2019, Nick Fuentes made a joke comparing the Holocaust
to Sesame Street.
Does anybody really believe, honest to God, if we're being honest,
does anybody really believe all of this acrimony,
all the con >> He just He just explained the Cookie Monster
clip, by the way.
Mark Levin is losing his mind. Ted Cruz is fighting with me on
Twitter.
You really think this is about a joke
from my show? An edgeord joke in January 2019,
7 years ago? Does anybody really believe that's what this is
all about? Because Tucker didn't say, "Why did you make a joke
seven years ago?"
We all know what this is about.
Israel is at war. They have been at war for two years. The war
far exceeds the scope of what is considered proportionate
and appropriate
and a response to what did on October 7th.
And by that I mean, let me be precise and specific.
Israel has used October 7th as a pretext to launch a far-reaching
and ambitious
regional war against no fewer than seven different polies.
Gaza, the West Bank, Lebanon, Syria, Iraq, Yemen, and Iran.
They are doing this in pursuit of a longstanding regional goal,
which is to expand their borders, something they call greater
Israel.
one problem they can't do it on their
I So it's very interesting because I think even 6 months to a
year ago if you talked about greater Israel or the idea that
Israel is seeking greater Israel that they want Judea and Samaria
to be a part of their borders that they're going to absorb the
West Bank in these ways people would call you a conspiracy theorist.
And I don't think it's a conspiracy theory. It seems to be much
like if you believe that hatred is at charter. I believe in the
in either the the mission statement or the charter of lood is
a goal to strive towards greater Israel. No,
they need us. They need the United States. They need our money.
They need our guns.
To secure that, they need the support of our government. to secure
they need the support or at least the indifference or the acquiescence
of the American people and the American people are fed up with
it. The American people are done. We don't want to fight.
But here's the thing.
I don't have I don't have like proof that Greater Israel is like
a thing. You could call it a conspiracy theory, but I'm just
going to say that like if I'm flipping a coin with you, if I
have you in a coin flipping contest, okay, we're we're betting
on what side this is going to go. I have I have heads, you have
and somehow it's come up tails 99 out of a 100 times. I'm going
to assume you rigged the game. And I'm sorry, but this is the
way that like basically conflict and geopolitics have gone in
the Middle East for long enough that I'm like, okay, the game's
rigged. like it's it's pretty clearly rigged and you're clearly
moving towards either expansion or ethnic cleansing.
I I don't know. Like I I'll just deal with the reality on the
ground. The fact that somehow magically your borders are expanding.
Somehow magically you are going to push people out of these areas
or I guess maybe do a real estate thing with America and Gaza.
I don't I still don't know exactly what the Trump plan will entail
eventually. But it's it's obviously like going in your direction
the whole time, right? In the Middle East. We don't want to fund
the wars in the Middle East. We don't want to send our missiles
to kill innocent people. We don't want to be on the hook. We
don't want to be blamed for it. We don't want to be a party to
it, complicit in it. We don't want to be dragged one step further.
On the contrary, we want out.
We want out of the whole arrangement. We don't want to give you
more money. We don't want our troops to even be there. We don't
want our aircraft carriers there defending you. We don't want
to be supporting this in the UN. We don't want to pay for it.
We're done.
That's what this is about. Everyone knows that is always what
this has been
And that's the only reason that any of these people even know
who I am or care. That's why they have a problem with me. That's
why people have been watch uh the unfortunate, not unfortunate,
the thing that I'm not sure Fuentes will catch here. And the
way to like actually point this out, guys, you can see the timer.
If you want the content to continue, go ahead and donate. I love
you. Thank you.
the only
Sorry, I'm not sure if Fentes will catch this or if Gropers would
have c caught this because they don't really care about Tucker,
but the criticisms of Tucker are showing why was Tucker their
best friend. Why was he friends with everybody in these movements
for so long
until he had some contrary opinions on
Why? Why is that the case?
Why is it only when he had when he starts being contrarian on
Israel, why is that the only time Tucker is suddenly a bad guy?
Right? And I'm not saying just with the Fentes thing, the Fentes
thing is bad, but Tucker was before this. Ted Cruz came in and
called him an anti-semite for saying we shouldn't bomb Iran on
behalf of Israel, right? They're going after Tucker the second
he was he he suddenly had a contrarian position on Israel that
he started talking about MSAD. You saw Charlie Kirk was getting
texts not to have Tucker speak at TPUSA
Yes, Russian propaganda. When he goes and does all the Russian
propaganda, that's totally cool, guys. Oh, he's doing he's he's
doing anti-Israel commentary now. Oh, cancel him. Get him out.
He's an anti-semite. Get him out of here. Watching my show for
like Nick is an anti-semite. So, when they call him an anti-semite,
there's not really much to push back against, right? But Tucker
was like not an anti-semite and he was clearly like an overt
Russian shill. If he wasn't being paid, he was being brainwashed.
I don't know how to explain it, right? I don't know about the
Ukraine evil for Johnny Bravo, but that's that's where the real
criticism is. Is why did you all flip on Tucker? Why why did
you flip on Tucker? Not even after the interview, but before
that. For 10 years looking for things to make me look bad.
Ammunition to my character. Look at what he said here. Oh, I
bet you don't like that. Look at what he said there. Oh, I bet
that offends you. Oh, >> you went >> look anywhere
else. Everywhere and anywhere else other than
>> the thing that we all know they really care about, which
is that the money and the guns and the
uh Did he Oh, thank hooligans. Thank you for the gifted sub,
bro. Bro, did he do an episode on the grocery store? We looked
for that. I just couldn't find it. I took two seconds to search
for it. I could not find the Tucker grocery store episode. or
keeps going in the same direction with no limits and no conditions
and no
Oh, sorry. Um, I'm gonna stop interrupting him in just a second.
But I would say as well that I wouldn't even look at Ben stuff
cuz Ben tends to stay pretty squeaky clean. Ben tends to like
commentate in a way that's pretty consistent with his principles
most of the time. >> The issue I have is that Ben supports
a whole network of people. He employs a whole network of people
who don't have his principles, who constantly engage in conspiratorial
thinking, who constantly engage in proper uh populist rhetoric
and and demagoguery, right? They they do it constantly. He supports
all of this. He makes money from all of this. That's my criticism
of Shapiro more than anything. I do think he also uh equivocates
for Trump constantly, which is embarrassing as well given his
past statements, but that's again a slightly different issue.
They want you.
>> Thank you, Spruce Willis. Thank you, Hooligans. And
thank you
to
woke up today for the three gifted subs, guys. To run our country.
They got a good deal.
They recognize that good deal is collapsing. It's falling apart
for the simple fact that we now have free speech now that Elon
Musk acquired Twitter and they're not banning everybody for everything
and anything. Now that on Instagram and Tik Tok, some of the
moderation has been relaxed. Now people are simply catching up.
They're waking up to what has always been going on, which is
that we've been fighting these people's wars for generations.
And people are hip. People are not hateful. People are not crazy.
>> Chatty nickel, thank you for the gifted sub. People
are decent and normal and we want our
country back. Forgive my language, but that's how everybody feels.
We want our country back. We want our sovereignty. We want our
independence.
And you know how we know we don't have it? Because we have to
literally go and kiss their wall.
That's how everyone knows. It's not complicated.
If they are getting money and support, but somehow we have to
go and kiss their
We have to attend their conference and salute their flag. Honestly,
the the wall kissing thing once it became a meme, it's like,
why don't you just give that up? Why do you guys keep doing that?
Why you guys got to do that? That's like a total
>> outside our congressional offices, our governor's offices,
our state legislatores. They're flying a foreign flag. That's
how you know something's wrong. And it's obvious. It couldn't
be more obvious.
That's why they slavishly
defend this country more than they defend us.
They They won't talk about white people. They won't defend Christians.
They won't By the way, I think I should also make it clear. I
have like very little problem with Israeli citizens,
right? If you're an Israeli citizen and you defend Israel, you
go online and you talk about how awesome Israel is, good for
you. Just if you were born in the United States and you do it
anyway, that's what's weird to me is if you are like explicitly
Israel first over your home country. That's what's gross. That's
the annoying thing. Even worse than that is if you're like Ted
Cruz. If you're somebody who doesn't have an ethnic or you you
have neither an ethnic nor a religious tie to Israel and you
do it anyway, even worse.
Even worse. So Dan, no, I don't think Dan likes Israel more than
America. As much I don't I have no reason to say that for Dan
either. I don't have the same suspicion for him. I don't think
Dan voted for Trump. Right. Again, to really clear this up, it's
like if you voted for Trump over
Kamla, you're willing to sacrifice norms and values in your country
o over Israel is a single issue. That's who I got an issue with.
That's who I got a problem with. Right. Those are the people
I have a problem with.
Anyway, um Hooligan saying thank for the five gifted. Let's go.
We actually a little bit close here. We're what, two gifted?
No, we're one gifted. One gift away from two more hours on the
stream. Easy. Thank you guys so much. border.
But if this country is insulted, attacked, threatened,
they're the first ones to leap in front of it
with a letter, with billions in aid, with a with a carrier strike
group.
We're threatening to bomb everybody. We are bombing everybody.
Everybody knows it. Everyone's sick of it. You're wrong. We're
right.
You are abusive. You are taking
>> You are out of place here.
>> You are improper. We are correct. That's what's going
on. And they hate that. They hate that because they couldn't
censor and cancel me and I'm super popular. I said thank you
for the gifted subs to Hooligans and Bub. That's two more hours
in the stream, guys. Thank you so much. Let's continue. >> And
everyone is with me. Everyone supports. And look, you know, not
everybody likes everything I say. Not everybody likes my weird
sense of humor or my jokes. I'm a weird guy. Whatever.
>> And not everybody has to like it. Not everybody has
to agree. You don't like it? Turn it off.
I hear people say, "You need to apologize to who?
What are you talking about? We're all
More than anything, they want people to stop listening to what
I have to say about this topic. That's all they care about.
They don't want the information getting out there. They don't
want people to feel confident saying it with their chest. They
don't like the
They don't like that I'm telling people, "You're American. Stick
up for yourself." That's the message they hate more than anything.
They hate that someone is telling people, "We're American. This
is ours. We have citizenship. It's our government. It's our country.
It's our birthright. It's our heritage. It's not yours.
And if we want to opt out, we can. And there's not a damn thing
you can do about it. You can't bully Americans. You >> It's
uh here's the thing, Screw. It's like Trump. It's like all of
the instincts of Trump with somebody who is an eloquent eloquent
speaker. Trump has no eloquence. Fuentes does. Fuentes is extremely
good at just speaking essentially off the cuff, right? I do think
he scripts out a lot of stuff as well, but he's like Trump with
eloquence. He's got all the instincts. He's got all the populist
understanding of how people will like see and and he's got all
of the manipulation tactics,
but he's got actual eloquence as well and intimidate Americans.
And as long as I'm around, you're not going to gaslight Americans.
I'm smarter than you are.
I do this for a living. I've done it for years. I fought these
people.
As long as I have a platform, they will not trick you. They will
not gaslight you.
I told people don't vote for Trump because you know what you're
going to get? War with Iran. And I was right
and everybody sees that now. That's a part of it. They hate that.
So, we'll break it down. We'll talk. He's not going to go in
to tell you that he said vote for Trump and then he said don't
vote for Trump and then he said vote for Trump again. Then he
said don't vote for Trump and then afterwards he celebrated Trump
winning. Talk about all of it. That's all. It's going to be a
good show. Before we get into it, I want to remind you to smash
the follow button here on Rumble. Smash the like button. Leave
a comment. Let me know what you think about the show. Show the
support.
Show support. Like the video. Leave a comment. It's not for my
edification. I don't even look at the
Like the video to show them this is a mass movement.
This is not the This is not the loudest minority. No, this is
the silent majority. This is the silenced majority.
These are all the people that have been feeling like this for
a long time, but can't say it. And we know why nobody can say
it. Nobody can say it because they don't want to be expelled
from school. They don't want to be fired from their jobs. They're
not afraid,
but they understand the consequences. They understand that we
live we live under the thumb of this cancel culture. Yay. Had
it right. I'll be honest with you. I love the man. I know the
man. He's not a hateful person. And he said, "Who do you think
invented cancel culture? Is there any doubt in anybody's mind?"
He said, >> "I can't believe I can't believe in this huge
moment he drops a Yay reference. That's pretty crazy." >> Who
invented cancel culture? I'm going to guess it's the ADL
which got him kicked out of his billion dollar Adidas deal, his
billion dollar gap deal
that got his bank accounts frozen at JP Morgan. I'm going to
guess that
everybody feels this way. People are afraid to speak out because
they know they will be called names and they're not bad people,
but they know they'll be called names. They know that there will
be societal repercussions. And people, this is a difficult economy.
People want to feed their families.
You know, people are looking
>> looking out for themselves, but they're also looking
out for their loved ones.
So, I'll say the things you can't. I'll take the slings and arrows.
Not cuz I'm a hero, but because I don't I don't have a family
like that, you know? And maybe I'm a maybe I'm meant to do this.
Maybe I was made to do this, right? Cuz I'm a bit of a loner.
So, show the support. Like the video. Leave some comments. Let
me know what you think. Get your shirts.
Weighing. It's We're all weighing halfs. Guess what, Mark Levin?
You cannot control a white ass going hard as there's one thing
you didn't count on. Thank God. Thank God. These plans that were
laid long ago,
these plans they've made, they're you think this is this is actually
you're missing out on a second dimension or like a second order
plan here. This is a psychic attack on Ben Shapiro. Okay, it's
an actual psychic attack on Ben Shapiro right now. He's going,
"Hey, Ben, you know how you thought I was so important that you
like couldn't shill? Uh, I'm going to shill all of my stuff for
like 10 minutes, okay? I think you're going to watch it. You're
going to watch me shill for my t-shirts. >> We're going
to destroy Iraq and then Syria and then Iran and we're all going
to go along with it. THERE'S JUST ONE THING you didn't account
for.
One white ass going hard as
a human wrench into the system
who inspires
millions. There's just one thing you didn't count on.
One white ass going hard as bringing all your plans to a screeching
halt
cannot be intimidated,
cannot be cancelled, cannot be censored, cannot be gaslit, honeypotted.
One white ass, one Roman,
one American, one Christian, one
going hard as that's what you didn't count on.
Who would win?
All your money and all the banks
and Israel and Apac and the rest of it,
your lies, your slander, your cynicism,
your cruelty, or one Wang half.
Can the real Wang half please stand up? Can all the Wang Halfs
get up, rise up
and tell them it's America first.
It's America first. Fentustore.
Get the hat. Get the shirt. We support the show.
Get the hats. Get them in time for
>> Black camo blue. Check it out. That's the store. Subscribe
to the website america plus. Get access to all my shows for 15
bucks a month. Hundred bucks a month. You get to hang out with
me in a group chat. I'm leaving voice messages every day. It's
like I do a mini show every other day. I do a voice and I tell
you what I'm thinking. I >> I just realized I just realized
I could do that. Let's go. I should do a group chat with the
people in the Patreon. Me >> tell you, let's go. >> Excuse
me. Some of the inside scoop.
That's America First Plus. Okay, but let's get into it. Now,
the first thing I want to say because I think this is really
important to get out there.
We're going to talk about the backlash. The backlash. Everyone's
mad.
Before we even get into that, I would like to say first and foremost,
these people are
world champions at gaslighting.
Do you want to know the numbers on the Tucker Carlson interview?
My interview with Tucker Carlson is the number four most viewed
video of all time on his
He's got 5 million subscribers,
massive YouTube channel.
Number one, his interview with the Russian president Vladimir
Putin. Number two, his interview with Boule, president of El
Salvador. Number three, his expose on
Number four, his interview with me.
It just crossed the threshold. 5 million views. It's a little
bit higher than that.
Over 200,000
likes, close to
likes. All the comments,
every single one of them positive.
And scroll through. >> That's me. That's me. >> Look
at all the top comments. Sorry, I thought I just thought it'd
be funny to roll in the background while he was doing his show.
>> One, they're all a lot of them are jokey and funny,
but they're all saying, "We literally could not wait for this
>> On Tucker Carlson's Twitter,
100,000
likes, close to 20 million views.
>> On Instagram, this picture with me, close to 200,000
likes. It was one of the most liked, most talked about, most
anticipated,
most viewed interviews he has ever done.
And the reaction almost universally
positive. Tucker is one of the number one shows in America right
now, if not the number one news show. And my interview was the
number one interview this year on that platform. So don't be
gaslit.
Let's just stop for a moment and say this is a triumph.
This is a
This is a massive victory for America First. For 10 years,
I was cancelled. For 10 years, I was blacklisted under a false
pretense.
A story which I told in the interview, and now it's finally getting
out. It's a story that people didn't know. It's a story my own
family didn't know. Of course, except my parents obviously they
knew. But I can't tell you how many people, and I've seen this
from influencers. I've also heard it from people in my life.
They tell me, "I did not even know
that you were a normal conservative mainstream generic normie."
And Ben Shapiro tried to cancel you when you were a freshman
in college, when you were 18 years old. They didn't even
And this is like a it's like the the Revenant.
It's like gladiator. >> I just want to point out that like
while I do think Ben Shapiro didn't like him, I don't know if
it was Ben Shapiro that canceled him. I've not really seen any
evidence of that. Even the Cassie Dylan stuff there's just scant
evidence of I do think it's just mythology writing to a large
extent. But
>> it's like one of these classic movies
where the hero is totally knifed in the back and left to die.
And it's this remarkable journey where you have to repair your
reputation or come back from the dead or or the brink of death
in a certain sense. From the time I was 18 years old,
I had Shapiro, Cabbat Phillips, Cassie Dylan,
Right-Wing Watch, Media Matters, the ADL, the SPLC
lying about me, trying to make it out like I'm a bad person,
like I'm evil, like I'm this psycho skin head or something, like
I hate everybody, and I'm like this wannabe mass murderer.
They made my high school friends hate me. My high school friends
wouldn't talk to me because of this reputational destruction.
They made me unemployable.
They banned me from CPAC. I mean, it was ridiculous.
And so, it's a triumph that after 10 years of this totally malicious,
defamatory
character assassination campaign, I was finally able to speak
for myself in my own
invited me on the platform to just hear me out.
People have said so much about me and I was not able to reply
because I was censored
for 10 years. I was banned from every platform while they lied
about me.
They banned me. They silenced my voice and then they took clips
out of context and said he's evil
and wow. I can't imagine being banned from like the biggest platform
for content creators, have people lie about you just and then
they refuse to engage with you in any way when you try to correct
those lies. I can't imagine that. That sounds like a really horrible
experience. Finally, someone said, "I'll talk to you. I want
to know what you're about. Tell me what you think." And I was
able to just say, "These are my views."
And I think it's remarkable that we have reached a point in our
country when that is even possible
because for so long like I
uh he's never going to address the clips. He addressed the Cookie
Monster clip already. He called it the clip where I compare something
where I where they like I make a comparison to Sesame Street.
He that's how he referred to it. Okay. He's never he's never
actually addressing these clips again. I don't think >> I
said for 10 years you literally did not have the freedom of conscience.
You couldn't think these things. You could not speak these things
aloud. It wasn't possible. You would get banned from everything.
And if that didn't work, you got fired from your job. And if
that didn't work, they banned you from banks.
That's what happened to me.
And so finally, we are in a time where I'm on a platform. I can
make a living and people are willing to hear me out. And maybe
they like it and maybe they don't, but that's a huge victory
in itself. And by the way, people are loving it.
The reason this is happening, by the way, is because I'm popular
now.
And every time I leave the house now, I get recognized.
And I don't know how I feel about that. I'm a pretty private
person. I'm a pretty isolated person.
But let me just tell you all of this, all the freak out, the
so-called backlash, that is on Twitter. That is not real life.
If you go outside and touch grass, you will find men, you will
find women, you will find young people, you will find
what I
I don't know about this. >> People, they watch my stuff
on Instagram and they like it. They think it's funny.
They agree with it. Everywhere I go, it used to be the case I
would get recognized maybe one out of a hundred times. Now it's
like every other time I leave the house and it's all positive.
I get people high-fiving me, taking pictures of me, keep doing
what you're doing. I love what you're saying. America's not free.
And by the way, it's not what they say it is.
Uh, Cy, just so you know, this guy gets massive play on like
every platform. Yes, this is not this is not false. Where does
he live?
oh, it's uh
Uh, Berwin, Berwin, Chicago. Or there's another place. There's
like another It's like Burwin is is
maybe the next kind of like township over. Yeah. Berwin. Berwin,
Chicago, Illinois.
Berwin's like the sub. >> They all And by they, I mean
the Israel lobby. They say, "Oh, it's loser, disgruntled white
men who we need to save from themselves." You're wrong.
When I was in DC, it was a Liberian immigrant. It was it was
some Filipino looking guy who was at a restaurant. It is also
a lot of young white men, but a lot of them, they're normal.
They're good-looking. They're tall. That's all of them.
And whenever I go out, I love what you're doing. It's America
first. Keep spreading the word about Israel. All of them in all
colors, mostly men, less so women, young and old. They love what
I'm saying. And I The reason I say that, I don't want to uh >> Yeah.
No [__] >> Ramble on too much here, but the
reason I say that is because they're trying to demoralize you.
And this is the name of the game. It's all >> uh he probably
by tall, he probably means like 5'7 king of town. Okay, this
guy's not a tall human being. >> All about the frame. It's
all about how the table is set. And right now there is a concerted
effort to distort your perception. And I don't know what's going
on with the algorithm on X, but my entire timeline for the past
week, it's all people I don't follow. It's all people that have
like 10,000 followers and they all have the yellow ribbon in
their bio. They all have the Israeli flag in their bio and they're
all hand ringing and crying and freaking out about the interview.
And that is simply not how it is being perceived. You've got
probably combined 50 million views on the interview.
Universal acclaim. And and the people that don't love it, they're
saying, "I don't get what the big deal is. It seemed fine to
me.
It seemed moderate and tame and mild and and honestly, I agree
with 90% of it." But there's a deliberate effort right now to
distort that perception and say, "No, everyone's scared. Everyone's
freaking out. Everyone hates this." That's not reality.
That is a concerted smear campaign, an a media campaign.
Yeah, ex
right Hassan in my timeline. Uh, that's probably just your regular
timeline. I think I see a lot of this, but I think it's just
like around the stuff you're looking at, right? Like the axalgo
is showing me stuff that's relevant to I'm looking at all the
time.
It's always showing me that's relevant, but I I don't think it's
like up. Seems like every JTO stream is a Nick Fente stream.
Bro, if I do two streams in a row on the same topic, people say
this. It's very silly. I'm scared. But I like realistically,
BTO, this is just the thing literally everybody's talking about
in politics.
Like is there interesting? I guess there's this and then I was
going to do like a mayoral race update. Oh wait, I did the mayoral
race update for New York City. Yeah, literally everybody's talking
about this. Like every tweet about this has millions and millions
and millions of views. Ben Shapiro's tweet about this. How Nick's
tweet about this 2.5 million views. Where's Ben's tweet? Ben's
tweet has like 12 almost 15 million views. 16 million views,
right? Like these are massive. This is massive [__]
that's going on right now. Like this isn't some little there's
50,000 people watching this live right now. 55,000.
Everyone's freaking out. Everyone hates this. That's not reality.
That is a concerted smear campaign and a media campaign because
they know they're on the back foot right now. And I want to get
into a little bit of this smear campaign and I want to break
it down. And for starters, I want to talk about the Heritage
Foundation because it seems like this is where it all started.
So, I did my interview with Tucker Carlson last week and like
I said, the interview blew up. It's one of the biggest interviews
he's ever done and he loved it. He texted me. He said, "I I thought
it was excellent." I said, "Thank you so much for being fair.
I thought it was great, too." And we loved it and everyone I
knew loved it. And then it seemed that everything really changed.
when the president of the Heritage Foundation released his statement
on
as soon as the interview came out. Hold on, I'm going to back
this up because I just want to deal with um I hate how we can't
trust the view count on any platform. Never know the true number.
I listen, this is probably juiced a decent amount. If there were
less than 20,000 people watching this live right now, I'd be
very, very shocked
if there were less than 20, 25, 30 thou. Like if this was more
than doubled, I would be very
Like objectively when he goes and talks to people on YouTube,
those episodes blow up massively, right? You could say that you
don't know what the real thing is anywhere.
But I I just don't think that's useful. Then you just say then
you just say you don't know anything about anything. And it's
like, okay, that's like
I don't know. It all correlates, right? It's got to correlate.
It's got to go in a direction. Then it seemed that everything
really changed
>> when the president of the Heritage Foundation released
his statement on
As soon as the interview came out, all of the usual suspects
came out to condemn Tucker Carlson.
And by the usual suspects, I mean the Republican coalition and
Mark Levan and Josh Hammer, Israel's number one propagandist,
and Ben Shapiro and Laura Loomer. All the people from the Israel
lobby came out to condemn the interview, which is not surprising.
And then on Thursday, the president of the Heritage Foundation,
Kevin Roberts, released a video about this. There were some rumors
that Heritage was distancing themselves from Tucker Carlson,
and their president, Kevin Roberts, came out to set the record
straight, and he released a video statement. And I thought the
video statement was totally on point. I thought was very courageous
and I didn't disagree with anything in it. Nor do I think that
any reasonable person would disagree with anything in it.
In the video, he said very simply, he said, "Contrary to popular
belief," he said, "We are not distancing ourselves from Tucker
Carlson." He said, "And the reason being is we don't agree with
cancel culture."
He said, "Our job is not to police the conscience of other Christians."
He said, "And I also don't believe that we must reflexively and
automatically support a foreign country like Israel." He said,
"We have a right to criticize Israel." Actually,
in addition, he said, "Our principles, the pillars of our movement
are Christ is king, America first, and free speech." He said,
"And while I don't agree with everything Nick Fuentes says and
I find his views abhorrent,"
he said, "Nick Fuentes should not be cancelled and we should
debate him rather than censoring him." That was the video.
Okay. Yes.
I don't think his follow-up really said anything else. It just
went into more details on why he abhors Nick Fentes's values,
right? I don't think his like actual
statement that he released later went deeper down that same track
like sorry I don't it did go deeper down that same track I don't
think it like broke broke new ground though right it didn't break
new ground at all it was like the same statement now this was
really important because Heritage Foundation is maybe the most
important think tank in the conservative movement they've been
around forever and they're considered the standard bearer
of the Reagan
So for the president of Heritage representing this allimp important
institution to say these things was a really big deal because
the message was Tucker Carlson is not going to be kicked out
of the big tent. Tucker Carlson will not be cancelled. He's not
going anywhere. The cancel culture mob will not lynch him.
And that was a major vote of confidence in favor of Tucker.
But the reaction to this
somehow was worse than the reaction to Tucker.
All of a sudden, the donors that put up the money, the and pro-Israel
Christian donors freaked out. The board members freaked out.
The
anti-semitism brigade,
the coalition for and whatever against
they resigned from Heritage.
And it looked like Heritage Foundation might literally fall apart
because of this
And I said on my show last week, you can go and watch it for
my full breakdown, but what exactly was objectionable about what
Kevin Roberts said?
He said, "Christ is king. America first. Free speech." He said,
"We have a right to criticize Israel. We're not going to cancel
Tucker." You might not like Nick Fuentes, but let's debate him.
What is wrong with any of that?
Are those not the fundamental principles of the conservative
movement? Isn't that This is the unfortunate thing is he's just
got you by the balls here, right? You you literally can't do
anything to push back against this. He says, "Okay, like what's
what's going on?" That's all of your values, all of your state
of values. That's why you guys get so mad that when you say the
hard R at your job, you get fired. That's Isn't that cancel culture?
Isn't that really bad? Isn't that like unamerican? Shouldn't
you have free speech? Why won't you debate me and say why I'm
wrong? Yeah. All of that is stuff they've espoused. It's all
stuff they've esposed. They've gone hell and back defending those
values.
And this is the one place where they're compromising and he's
just got it right. It doesn't make him right on anything else
he says.
But this one contradiction, the entire conservative, the entire
GOP movement in the United States, the entirety of the Republican
party is sitting on this on the eye of a needle, this one contradiction,
right? Oh, actually, free speech everywhere except this one place.
And and he just keeps hammering that and they won't say why else
he has to be
And they get really mad at other people who go, "Oh, you know
what? You kind of changed my mind on that issue." Yeah, I think
that one issue where they think you should be able to, you know,
we shouldn't have free speech necessarily. I think that's actually
that's actually like I you might have changed my mind on
That what it means to be a conservative. I mean, seriously, which
part of that does anyone not like?
If the conservative movement is not Christian, what is it? If
it's not patriotic and America first, what is it? If we're not
in favor of free speech contraanc culture, what is it?
And does it not follow from those principles that we're allowed
to criticize a foreign country, we're not going to cancel and
censor? So, what's the problem? So, what did Ben Shapiro say?
That Ben Shapiro's criticism, he says, and him playing those
clips, that's not cancel culture, right? Cancel culture is when
you get somebody banned from a platform. As long as Ben Shapiro
is not trying to get Nick banned, then everything's fine. Okay.
Well, as long as you're not showing those clips, as long as those
clips don't lead to him getting banned, then sure, that's Ben
can say that, right? But I don't think those clips I don't think
there's almost anybody who's unaware of those clips.
Who's those clips have been blasted full volume all over the
internet for years now.
Where are the new clips? Like, you have to have something new,
right? Like, this guy was banned four years from everything.
Where's the new reason to keep him banned? Where's the Where's
the new reason to stop listening to him or or to to turn on him
now? Right? He's gained massive popularity. Those clips have
been known for a long time. Where's the new reason to like turn
on him, to get him off of platforms, to not listen to him at
all?
Well, the problem is very
It's very simple. And as we talked about last week, the problem
is that if people are able to criticize Israel,
then they will. And if people are criticizing Israel, then people
will agree
because there is a fundamental contradiction here between America
first and the amount of influence that the Israel lobby has.
So if you're following, if people are able to speak freely, then
they can criticize Israel. If they criticize Israel, they're
going to make a very compelling and persuasive
And the reason being is because they're right. You can't be America
first and support all the wars and the diplomatic and economic
support and all of it. Apac and the ADL, the influence. You totally
could, but somebody would have to justify that. >> They
exercise over our society.
And if that's a strong and compelling case, people are going
to come to believe those things. They will express that in how
they vote. and eventually the support for Israel will come to
an end.
And that's the part they don't like. That's the part that's
Free speech as long as you talk about the right ideas because
if you talk about the wrong ideas, then we'll get the wrong policies.
So they tried to destroy Heritage Foundation. And the backlash
against them was so immense that on Friday, the day after the
video came out, Kevin Roberts Oh, you got to go back and watch
the actual Ben Shapiro segment from the start of this stream.
Okay. Honestly, can you stop this level of populism? We went
through all of Ben Shapiro's takes where Ben Shapiro said he
will never vote Trump because of the demagoguery, because of
how what it would mean for the Republican party going forward,
and we cover all of his. No, you can't. Once you once you make
it where you're willing to excuse your party leader not engaging
with reality, right? Not engaging with any facts, any actual
criticisms, it's just all a cult of personality. No, you can't
come back from it once he's established control of that cult
of personality. Once he gets in, you have to have a better personality.
And none of these people have had a personality for years that
it's all been free. It's all been paint by numbers analysis,
right? This is the only guy who's been outside of that who's
had a separate opinion who is a heterodox opinion who's a heterodox
like character in this whole sphere
and he's he's just been working on this for years and he's been
getting more and more like charismatic better at running the
show. It's it's like the worst of all possible worlds all came
together to to
I don't know destroy the Republican I I hope this would destroy
the Republican party. Some people seem to think that this will
lead to an out like a mass exodus of donors and that they won't
be able to run any of their campaigns and they'll get massively
destroyed in elections and people will get turned off of it.
I don't I don't know. I don't know cuz this is so much in earned
media, right? If you're good at if you're good at being an influencer,
turns out you don't have to pay for the
Put out a statement which he didn't even
The guy that wrote the video on Thursday was fired.
They blamed it on the chief of staff. Some guy,
I guess his name is Ryan New House. Some guy that works at Heritage
under the president who wrote the statement, he got fired.
Someone else wrote a statement for Kevin Roberts, which he published
on Friday, and said, I said Nick Fuentes has abhorentt views.
This is what I meant in particular. Nick Fentis is a he's a racist.
He's an anti-semite. He said this, he said that. And now Kevin
Roberts still might be fired. Anyway, and this is a story from
The Hill. It says, quote, Ryan New House, who until Friday was
chief of staff to the Heritage Foundation President Kevin Roberts,
left the conservative think tank in the wake of an uproar over
a statement from Roberts last week defending Tucker Carlson after
he interviewed anti-semitic white nationalist Nick Fuentes.
Always the preamble by the way, right?
Anti-semitic, xenophobic, islamophobic,
Just call me a deplorable, right?
It's dude, dude. Uh,
he says it all like he's just Yeah, he said, do you feel how
easily that's like water off a duck's back there, right? He just
he doesn't even see it. as a heritage spokesman confirmed New
House's departure. He had angered Heritage staff and other conservative
movement allies after he had reposted a number of messages of
support for Roberts and his defense of Carlson on social media,
including one particularly controversial statement that Heritage
employees who were virtue signaling in wake of the remarks should
resign if they are outraged and that it would be addition by
subtraction for the
The spokesperson said New House would be reassigned to be a senior
adviser in the B. Kenneth Simon Center for American Studies to
work on other critical issues including housing.
>> Following the significant backlash, Roberts elaborated
on Friday on what he abhores about Fuentes' views. In another
statement, he said, quote, "He is fmenting hatred and his incitements
are not only immoral and uncchristian, they risk violence." Oh,
really? We're going to play that card now? So I get called a
they tell me they're going to neutralize me. They say that I'm
vermin and that's fine because there's no accountability for
people at all. As long as you're as long as you support Israel,
everyone knows
there's no accountability. You can say whatever you want. You
can I certainly feel like Josh Hammer is a total loser who shouldn't
really have any platforms. Like it seems seems to suck a massive
amount, but >> do whatever you want.
You can say about the Palestinians, kill them all, and that's
fine.
You can say, kill two million people and you're fine. You're
not genocidal.
You're not a racial supremacist. You're not violent
because you're and you're pro-Israel. And God knows you can't
criticize God's chosen people.
Josh Hammer can say Tucker Carlson should be neutralized like
an animal. And that's fine. No one's going to criticize that.
That's not violent. That doesn't tend towards anything bad because
he's a pro-Israel Jew. So there's no accountability.
You can like Mark Levvin say these people are vermin. They're
our enemy. They're anti-American.
Once again, you're fine. You could be Lindsey Graham and say,
"We're everyone." We Is Mark Levin from New York? And is he like
Orthodox?
because that's the only way that voice would be would be okay
there. Okay, that was that was
uh hold on. Somebody asked a sec somebody asked a question here.
Where was it? Oh, how much would you bet that this all prepares
Nick for a presidential run in 2036? I don't think he's thinking
about politics. Stuff stuff got to change majorly for
Um
I do think you still have this other part of the coalition, right?
You've got this other part of the coalition that's still the
Neocon people. They are still there. They don't make up a ton
of the party and they signal towards this this part of the party
a lot. But you you would have those people break away for Fontes
right now. A lot of stuff would have to change. And I see this
as like one end of the the pendulum, right? Like we got to be
close to the end of this side of the pendulum swing. We have
to be there. It's going to start swinging back soon, right? There's
like a a pendulum that's swinging and it's going back in this
Fentes type direction, this populist direction. It's we can't
be that we can't go that much further. I think we're nearly done
with this. It's going to swing back. Not saying that he will
he'll be like banned or anything. I just think like the the overwhelming
popular support will go away.
We won. We ran out of bombs.
But if you say America shouldn't support Israel, now you're the
irredeemable, reprehensible,
anti-semitic Holocaust denier and it's violent. Stop. Just stop.
Just stop. Just stop. stop the cap. No one's buying that anymore
anyway. But that's a statement. Now, understand,
think about how crazy this is. Okay,
let's break down in a very mechanical way the anatomy of what
has just
So, Tucker
interviewed me.
Kevin Roberts defended Tucker.
The chief of staff for Kevin Roberts defended his boss, Kevin
Roberts. That guy has been fired from his job.
What is that? Like three degrees of separation.
So wait, did that guy get fired because of that statement? I
didn't get that impression. I thought that guy got fired for
disscent, but maybe that guy got fired because he
maybe he is like a H. >> Oh, think of think of this. Think
of
No, I don't think something Fuentes says are done. Not by itself
will cause an inversion. I I It's just a natural thing. Like
eventually you reach you've got like the Fuentes clones like
that Fuentes multiverse thing going on and realistically there's
almost no further saturation he can gain in the Republican space
and he's not the kind of person who can transition over and be
like a universally beloved figure. So realistically there's like
he's nearly at the zenith of what he can accomplish by himself,
right? like there there really isn't a lot more room to grow
from here. Like he's going to meet he's going to start to see
like market saturation. There'll be diminishing returns on any
growth he has from here. Like it'll it just won't be the same.
Yeah. Unless there's a >> years ago >> again. Unless
there's a major political paradigm shift that we're not anticipating.
Can't say for sure. >> Like three degrees of separation.
>> So think of think of this. Think of this.
7 years ago. 7 years ago, I made a joke about the Cookie Monster.
Tucker interviewed me and didn't ask about it. Kevin Roberts
defended Tucker
and Ryan New House, some guy defended Kevin
Unacceptable.
He's fired. He's been reassigned. You're gone. What?
And they say that's not cancel culture.
Shapiro is making the case that that's not cancel culture. That's
drawing a moral line somewhere. And the moral line is that if
you >> point out point out that Crushaw did the same thing.
Point out that Crunchaw did the same thing. You >> defend
somebody who defended somebody who talked to a person who made
a joke 10 years ago.
Your morals are you're a morally horrible person. You're a moral
idiot. You're a thirdderee Holocaust denier. A third generation
Holocaust denier. What?
That's how insane this is.
And what is really happening at Heritage
The president got the call. Kevin Roberts, the president of the
Heritage Foundation, literally got the call from who? The donors,
the board members, and all of the bureaucrat. Uh people have
said as much, by the way. Like I I saw people on Twitter just
saying, "Oh, Laura Lumemer is out here on Twitter just saying,
"Oh, if you follow this this whole trend, you're going to lose
all of your donors."
Like it's super out in the open. It's not, by the way, it's not
like Israel donating to them or something. It's just like there'll
be a lot of people who are sympathetic to the Israeli cause who
put a lot of money into Republican politics, right? And so
this has just been advertised openly like, "Hey, the sponsors
are going to pull out. You won't have money to be doing the things
you were doing before." rats and think tank nerds that have ever
worked with Heritage Foundation in the past. The rabbis, the
literal rabbis that wrote some of the project and white papers
at Heritage Foundation. That's who we got the call from.
This guy basically said the conservative manifesto and took it
to its logical
What's the logical conclusion of the Trump ideology? America
first, Christ is king, free speech, no political correctness.
He took it to its logical
We're not going to cancel Tucker. We can criticize Israel. We
can put America first.
But then he got the call from his pro-Israel donors, from his
pro-Israel board members, from his pro-Israel and
staff members. And you know, he could have just not included,
again, he could have just not said the part, right?
pro Israel and
that's everybody. That's so everybody is or not, right? Sorry.
Everybody's either or not.
Everybody is either or not. Come on, man. And that is why he's
firing and blaming his
That's why he went on Dana Lash and begged for forgiveness.
That's why he was at Hillsdale today. And do you know what he
said at Hillsdale University?
He said, "I forgot the most important part of my mission, which
is fighting
at the Heritage Foundation."
>> there's no shot he said that. There's no shot he said
that. That's crazy. >> You're not going to say anything
about white genocide. You're not going to say any Wait, hold
on. Where did Where did he say this? >> And begged for
forgiveness. That's why he was at Hillsdale today. And do you
know what he said at Hillsdale University?
He said, 'I forgot the most important part of my mission, which
is fighting anti-semitism
at the Heritage Foundation.
So, you're not going to say anything about white genocide. You're
not going to say anything about mass migration, free speech,
the Constitution. That's not important. The most important thing
now is fighting anti-semitism.
Does anybody believe? A few days ago,
I posted a video
truly. >> Oh, also, did he say white genocide
>> With the best ofions, >> a little goofy.
>> I and heritage don't engage in cancelling people because
when you cancel people, >> especially in the age of social
media,
>> let's see. >> If in fact you want you do that
because you want their audiences to get smaller,
you make their audiences
bigger.
And then there's the whole thing of the loyalty
toward friends.
that's not why cancel culture is bad. Cancel culture is bad because
it works. It's not because it makes you bigger. >> And
speaking as a pretty
>> You can tell he just totally flipped on that principle.
Oh, we don't cancel people because it actually helps them. No,
you don't cancel people because it's wrong to take away their
income for speech. That's what you believe. Why do I have to
tell you what you believe? >> Proud generation Xer.
My motivation having seen over the last 25 years basically the
entirety of my professional career
that men and women of all ages but especially in my generation
have been cancelled from every industry. My motivation was to
draw a line in the sand and say let's stop that. You have problem
with the content, you have problem with the issues, you have
problem with the ideas, by all means go debate them. But I have
to tell you to the students that this old history professor made
a mistake.
And I'm not saying that your professors at Hillsdale make mistakes,
but sometimes you can make a mistake and with the best of intentions.
And my mistake was not saying we aren't going to participate
in cancel culture. We're not. My mistake was letting that, which
we will never backtrack from, override the central motivation
that I had in doing that. Because I can tell you as an old professor,
but also as a dad of four, there's one of those ideas that really
worries me. It's an idea that has become cache not just on the
left but on the far fringes. >> Come on man. Come on. of
the right. And that's anti-semitism. These people are literally
like it sucks when I watch this
and it's like these people are
if you were to tell me that they're they're putting on some sort
of like pantomime
to try to like get Israel out of American politics and make it
like obvious that they're controlled, I would believe you. I
would actually believe you because they it comes off as so transparent.
Yeah, it here's the thing. It comes off as so transparent every
time when they do this. This is what I'm talking about. These
boomers aren't equipped to fight Nick in any way. He's out here.
He's been railing over and over again. They think it's Israel
first. They're going to tell you anti-semitism is the biggest
issue in America. You can't feed your family. And they're going
to sit there and tell you that actually anti-semitism is the
mission of of the Heritage Foundation, the biggest Republican
think tank. Yeah. Stopping anti-semitism, that's their number
one priority. Are you [__] kidding me? Are you serious?
Yeah, nobody nobody wants to see this. Nobody thinks this is
smart. Nobody thinks this is good political strategy. And they're
they're just walking into it. They're sideshow Bob walking into
rakes over and over and over again. Why?
Okay. I did not I did not think that it was going to be that
obvious again. And it's it's funny cuz I do think like the populist
thing populism is not good. The the way America's engaging in
populism, some populist stuff is is okay, right? There should
be there should be a tension between populism and you know I
guess you call it like establishmentism
institutionalism institutionalism versus populism right there
should be some tension there just like versus you know any dichotomy
in politics there should be tension right but getting way too
into the oh all institutions are bad we need to be populist on
everything that's how you get rid of all of your hierarchies
you hire total to do jobs you get Cash Mattel spending $80,000
to go fly to his girlfriend's country music concert and he's
going to convince her that she's going to be a star, right? He's
going to fly an FBI private jet there, spend $80,000 so he can
try to get his dick wet.
That's how you get that is is this level of like totally disproportionate
populism, leaning totally out of your
And I'm just watching Fuentes, who's a guy who's going to go
max populism, right? Totally own every institutional person in
the right wing. And they just seem to want more. They just show
up for more. They just like get punched in the mouth and show
up and go put their hands at their sides. Can you punch me in
the mouth again? Can you please punch me in the mouth? Please
hit me as hard as you can again.
I'm sorry. We're We can be done with this. We can go back to
Fentes. >> That's an organic reaction.
And although it goes without saying,
>> populism isn't saying anything. Lol. Nick is not populist.
You are permanently banned from this chat. Never come back. Loki
Coco.
This is the arrangement that people
This is exactly what we're talking about. This is what I'm talking
about. This is what Tucker is talking about. This is wrong. This
is weird. They said they're on nitrous. Okay. If they're on
I that I can't engage. I got to I got to I got to knock that
out. I got to
>> I'm going to pretend that didn't happen. you about.
This is what I'm talking about. This is what Tucker is talking
about. This is wrong. This is weird. This is conspicuous.
>> You have what purports to be a conservative Christian
pro-American think tank and its president defends Christian patriotic
American free speech values.
And the donors are yanking his chain because he's not disavowing
anti-semitism enough
because that is who really pulls the strings. That's the cancel
culture. Like I hate to say it, dude. I so badly hate to [__]
but it it looks like that, right?
It like that's transparently what it looks like and it sucks.
I want to tell you that Fantas is wrong on everything he's saying.
I want to be able to show up, watch this guy's stream, and be
able to go, "Oh, he's totally here's all the here's like why
he doesn't understand the situation that's going on, right? I
can do that with a lot of different streamers. It's very easy."
The issue I have with Fentes is I I show up and I'm like, "Oh,
he's lying here, here, and here." And it won't matter. And he
knows it won't matter. He knows that he's set up the board in
such a way that he can lie with impunity.
And you need somebody who's going to be like more entertaining,
more interesting, who can actually play the populism game against
him because he's already got a party set up to be totally
like basically somebody cut a key perfectly for this entire base
of viewers and he's got the key now. And like he he is literally
the key master. Okay. And we're all that's how I see this. That's
the influence operation.
And it's on behalf of a foreign state. That's the problem.
People are tired of this. They're tired of all of it. They're
tired of this Dr. Jackekal and Mr. Hyde. One day we see Kevin
Roberts and look at the difference in demeanor. On Thursday,
he comes out and does a video statement confidently. He says,
"Here at Heritage, we don't do cancel culture.
We don't police the conscience of Christians. We're not cancelling
Tucker. We're Christ first and America always. And he go, "Yeah,
I like this guy. Finally, someone with balls. Finally, someone
taking a stand against these bullies. We like Tucker. We don't
want to see him cancelled."
And then the next day, it's like a different person. He's there
with Dana Lash. I just I don't know what I did. I don't know
what I said. I'm sorry. I I got it wrong, you guys. I got it
wrong. I forgot my most important mission was fighting anti-semitism
and these view Nick Fuentes is a and he's a and disgusting and
vile and
we're we're done with that. We hate this
We hate this hostage situation. That's how everything feels.
Honestly,
such a massive mistake to even make this about anti-semitism.
Run all the clips of him saying the hard R over and over again.
run all the things he said about black people. Run all of the
uh run all of the al Alexander stuff. If you want to if you want
to try to cancel this guy, run all of that. Cuz I swear to God,
the anti-semitism thing, Republicans aren't equipped to deal
with the fact that like
people sympathetic to Israel are way too aggressive in threatening
their money and they don't know how to act other than to make
it transparent and clear to everyone that they are going to that
Israel is their number one priority. They That's how they will
make it look every single time. I stop making this about anti-semitism.
Never bring up anti-semitism with regards to Nick Flintes again
if you want any shot at making this go away. That is a microcosm.
That is a live demo.
That's a live demonstration. That's your beta launch of everything
that we hate about American politics,
which is that our politicians
are in a procession going to Israel to bow down to their prime
minister and kiss the wall. That our Congress 533
to three votes for endless foreign aid. That their leader comes
to our Congress and gets 50 standing ovations.
that our president stands at the Republican coalition and says,
"I'm working for you. There used to be a time when you couldn't
oppose Israel in politics, and that was a good thing.
It's humiliating. It's insulting. And it's wrong.
This is the United States of
We're the wealthiest, most powerful, best country in the world,
but it doesn't feel like it." Why do you seem more concerned
with Nick Fentes being canceled than the US government being
entirely captured by a foreign country? Weird.
Uh because realistically the foreign country thing only actually
comes into effect like once in a while.
And your government is literally letting the president scam the
American people out of money. He is selling pardons directly
to people, right? And Fuentes is going to step right into that
vehicle. Now, maybe he won't be as corrupt as Trump. I have no
idea what his like true intentions would be if he went in there,
right? He's he's going to be behind the scenes. Obviously, it's
just the hearts and minds, right? But I'm very concerned that
this populist thing is going to destroy the planet.
This populist surge in America is going to destroy the planet.
And Nick is far better at running this game than Trump or anybody
involved in Republican politics is. I've been saying this for
like two years now, two and a half years. All right. I don't
I don't want him. It's totally against my principles to cancel
them. But holy [__] there's got to be some people
who can actually like argue the points, who can actually stand
toe-to-toe with this guy because Jesus Christ,
our boy, our boy Ben totally failed today. Oh, hold on. I have
alerts off. I've had alerts off for a little bit. You went fating
fool. Glossing for an anti-semite like Fuentes. Repent bigot
or I will have Steven Miller ban you from the United States forever.
Okay. Well, thank you, Kate Miller. Thank you. Thank you.
Sorry, unmuted the alerts here. We're back. All right. Thank
you for the five. Appreciate it. And it's not destiny. I Listen,
I don't know who it is. I It's not politics. You cannot logically
debate this person, right? It's like emotion. It has to be a
And yeah, it probably can't be Destiny. I'm not sure it was ever
Destiny, to be honest with you. Destiny was effective in keeping
when Nick was like deplatformed. Destiny was effective in like
bringing up the clips and only letting the conversation be about
like the old clips of Fuentes. I just don't think he's got the
clout to make it work like that anymore. Would I debate Nick?
No. I've already made it clear. I don't think you can debate
Nick. Nick is not making political points. Nick is not making
policy points.
We pay into the system. We fight for the system.
It's ours. It's our country. But it feels like it has been hijacked.
It feels like it is being exploited.
It's being exploited for the benefit of another country. And
the reason that is allowed to happen is because of the foreign
influence which pervades our system. In a word, it's corruption.
And they use blackmail, intimidation, bribery to achieve these
ends. They do it in DC. They do it in New York. They do it in
the smoky corridors of power.
They do it to people like Kevin Roberts. They do it to people
like Trump. They do it to all of them. And that's why we get
these weird hostage videos and we as a country
feel like we are hostages. We are in a hostage situation. Gun
to your head. Do you support Israel? Do you condemn this? Do
you con do you renounce and all of his works? It's like what?
It's a 21st century. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have to go back on that. Give me a
Hold on. And Shapiro just took $5. You felting fool glossing
an anti-semite like Fuentes. Repent, bigot, or I will have Steven
Miller ban you from the States forever. >> Oh, thank you.
I don't know if that doubled up, but thank you. That might have
doubled up. Give me a second.
I got to back that up. I got to back that up slightly.
>> It's our country, but it feels like it has been hijacked.
It feels like it is being exploited.
It's being exploited for the benefit of another country. And
the reason that is allowed to happen is because of the foreign
influence which pervades our system. In a word, it's
And they use blackmail, intimidation, bribery to achieve these
ends. They do it in DC. They do it in New York. They do it in
the smoky corridors of power.
They do it to people like Kevin Roberts. They do it to people
like sitting around a table eating hummus. >> They do it
to all of them. And that's why we get these weird hostage videos.
And we as a country
feel like we are hostages. We are in a hostage situation. Gun
to your head. Do you support Israel? Do you condemn this? Do
you do you renounce and all of his works? It's like what? It's
a 21st century. What are you talking about?
That's what I was looking for was basically like is is he going
to call out is he going to say a bunch of things and then do
the hit line right at the end. Okay, JB, this is Air Force One.
>> our country is being genocided. Israel is carrying out
a genocide in Israel. >> And it's like gun to your head.
Do you affirm all of the tenets of the Holocaust religion? What
are you talking
Do you love Israel? I love America.
And so I saw this on Friday and I'm disappointed in Kevin Roberts,
but I'm not surprised. And you know what? How long before this
guy loses his job
He apologized. He graveled on his hands and knees in multiple
venues on Dana Lash's show at Hillsdale College.
These are other institutions. Crying on a Zoom call to the board
members, reassuring them. and it won't even be enough because
he won't condemn Tucker. He thought he could condemn me but like
Tucker, but it doesn't work that way. It's never enough for them.
So, that was the little circus on Thursday and Friday. Thursday,
he comes out, you know, hands on his hips. I We don't do cancel
culture. Friday, you get the the ISIS hostage video.
I don't know what I was thinking, you guys. Anti-semitism is
the real problem in America.
the apology, the condemnation, the basket of deplorable speech
that we've all heard a million times.
That was episode one. But there was something. This is the last
thing I want to say about Kevin Roberts because it was he's pushing
this line
and people are missing this.
It's a line I hear all the time.
He said to justify himself
the reason
>> I even said that >> real white negroes going hard
as please stand up. >> Thank you for the five Nick Fuentes.
>> condemn Nick Fuentes is thus he said the reason I said
we should engage Nick Fuentes is because Nick has an audience.
He says Nick has an audience of disaffected young white men.
He said, "And we want to reach those people because they're looking
for the answers in the wrong places." And I hear this line a
lot.
And there's an idea concealed inside of that statement, which
is they believe that the only reason I'm popular, which they
tacitly acknowledge. Dude, it's just it's the exact same thing.
Okay.
So many people expected like Republican voters in a lot of ways
when they felt like they had been totally [__] over
by the system that their jobs were all getting taken by illegal
immigrants and Trump came along and was like actually that's
really bad and these people are like rapists and criminals right
he didn't actually say that but beyond the point okay and and
Democrats in a lot of ways had this very soy reaction 2016 right
of like oh like racism is totally
and the Republicans were like wait we're not being racist we're
like we just want our jobs. We just want safety. And there's
a lot of people in the Republican party who had no problem with
that, who totally lined up behind Trump, were totally fine with
it. And now the same thing's happening, but with Israel, right?
It's like people are in a dire economic situation overall.
And people are going to them. The Republicans are going to them
now and going, "Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Have you I understand that like you're not eating, but
have you thought about how anti-semitism is like the biggest
political challenge in America right
And of course that's not hitting. Of course that doesn't work.
Of course that's a total failure as a concept, right? How the
could it possibly work? People don't care. The economy is bad.
You can't feed your family. You feel like you're in in constant
exist existential terror from the economy and and the fact that
you might lose your job or something. Yeah. You don't care about
racism. Racism suddenly disappears as an issue for you.
And somehow we're in 2025
and people still haven't figured this out. In that statement,
they say Nick is really popular. He's got an audience, but the
reason he's got it is because the men are so lost and confused
and weak. They say, "And Nick is cynically exploiting those men
and taking advantage.
His rise was enabled, they say, by our negligence to the young
men. So, we need to take an interest in them."
And this is such a messed up idea. Would you like to know why
they don't care about the young white men at all?
Oh, hold on though, Kico. This is now the Republicans, even though
they watched it happen, right? They they called Democrats soy.
I'm saying the Republicans now are like, "Wait, or sorry, at
least the you call it like the Zionist coalition within the Republic
Republican movement, they're all like, "Wait, aren't aren't you
guys this is racist? This is anti-Semitic." And a bunch of other
people are like, "Dude, America first. Like, I don't care. It's
just happening to a different ethnic group this time.
and they don't care about them because I'm one of them. And this
is what I said in my response to Tucker.
All this talk about the disaffected young white men.
I am one of them. I was that guy when I was in college. I'm that
guy now. And they hate me.
They hate me. They condemn me. They're they're not saying anything
they're saying about me with any charity towards me. They don't
want to understand me as a person. They don't think of me as
a person.
They don't look at me as a Christian should with charity and
with goodwill towards my soul. They look at me as an obstacle.
They look at me as someone who is a political inconvenience,
a political problem. And so, how do they regard me? They want
to discard me.
Oh, him. He's horrible. He's abhorent. He said this, this, this.
Do you watch my
Kevin Roberts, when you say my views are abhorentt and you rattle
off a bunch of 10-second clips which were put together over 10
years by Media Matters, do you think that's an honest representation
of my views? Do you even care?
Do you care if they're true? Do you care for my sake if they're
true or for anybody's sake? Or are you just saying that out of
political expediency because it's easy?
>> Hold on. What did Gringle say here? I didn't I saw this
coming so hard. Like Democrats need the mail vote, but they are
just going to make it look so patronizing and like they want
their vote, not that they care about them. Oh, sure.
Um like you're saying that it's just it's like really transparent.
It's just transparent manipulation.
Yeah, it's it's kind of similar. It's like discouraging an opinion
instead of encouraging.
Discouraging an action instead of encouraging. It's a little
inverted for me, but not to discard me because it's easy to throw
me under the bus because I h I'm a bad look. I have baggage.
I'm flawed. I'm imperfect. I've said provocative things.
So, we can throw him under the bus and we could pretend to care
about all the other ones. Well, guess what?
All these other young white men, they say things like I say all
the time
because we're not politically correct. We grew up in this generation.
That's how our generation talks. A lot of us are edge lords.
We're on the internet. We have uh postironic sense of humor.
So, we all talk like this on some level. We all were raised in
the Call of Duty lobbies or on 4chan or on Twitter or
So, we all talk like this. And a lot of the things >> Do
we all Do we all talk like this?
Hold on. I was sent a clip of Dickers and I clicked on it instead
of actually downloading it first. One second. Quick quick Dickers
review. What was Dicker >> I might actually have like child.
>> That's that. I'm sure that's clip chimp. It's probably
fine. Things that I believe many people believe. Many people
are being very skeptical of feminism and very skeptical of diversity.
You call it racist, but you know, our generation is growing up
in a majority minority country. That's uncomfortable for us.
We don't have the luxury of growing up in an all-white country
like the boomers did or generation X did. It's different now.
It's different for us. It's worse. We're feeling those externalities
all the time. We're seeing them.
And so, it's like that classic thing that Trump says, "They're
not after me. They're after you. I'm just in their way.
And by the way,
all those other distor I didn't think I I've heard him saying
it and I was going to point out that Trump has done this and
it was a Trump meme, but then he just he does it explicitly.
That's crazy. >> Young white men that they want to pander
to that they think they're going to coddle and give them a pamphlet
about, I don't know, from the Holocaust Remembrance Society or
something.
Make no mistake about it, they would cancel those young white
men too if they caught him with the bad screenshot in the group
chat. if they overheard him saying something controversial in
a private conversation, they do the same thing. They don't care
about us.
They don't care about young men. They only they only purport
to care about us
because now we are an inconvenience to the people they really
care about, which is the donors and the board members.
If they cared about the young white men, they'd listen to them.
And the young white men, they love Tucker, they love me.
A lot of them like Candace, they like Daryl Cooper. They don't
like any of those other people. No young white person gives a
about Tucker. Nobody Nobody who's under the age of 45 gives a
about Tucker. Nick is just glazing them. Not glossing them, but
glazing them so he can make them look better. So they he's just
handing out. Listen, he understands. Hey, I I'll give out to
these people exactly what I gave out to like Beardson and the
other people around me before, right? These people have now they've
kind of endorsed me and I will show mercy. I will give them like
a handout here. That's all this is. Just like Pat Buchanan, that's
where the young men are at. That's what they believe. Isn't it
your job to represent their views?
Isn't it your job to hear them, represent them, support them?
How about our problems?
How about white genocide? Is that not a problem in Europe and
America? Open borders. Ever heard of it?
But he turns around and says, "The real issue is anti-semitism."
And you know, we want to reach the young men and tell them about
that. Well, who is that really on behalf of? That sounds like
that's on behalf of the money that supports heritage and it comes
from
oligarchs that care about Israel and they don't care about the
people here and their their small parochial problems in their
neighborhoods, in their towns, in their cities. Ah, got to get
rid of the $5 words like that, Nick. I know you like being smarter
than other people. That's that's got to you you got to get rid
of that if you're going to try this. Okay. Prochial. That ain't
no pleb knows what the parochial means. Okay, chill the out.
That's what that sounds like to me. So Kevin Roberts, don't actual
[__]
>> Well, we need to engage with Nick so we can reach.
You will never reach my audience because you're not honest.
you will never reach my audience because you are fake
>> with all my faults, all the mistakes I've made, all
the all the ways that I'm not a conventional conservative or
I'm authentic. You're fake. I'm honest. You're a liar. I am a
disaffected young white man. I represent their interests because
they're my interest. You represent your donors because you live
in DC. Antonio's >> that's who you are.
>> sorry. I'm I'm getting like trigger. I get so triggered
by people saying like, "Oh, you're defending this guy. >> You
tell me I'm doing something that I'm doing the opposite of, I
actually just lose it. It's so annoying to me." >> Until
you're willing to give up all of that, which is not anytime soon,
you will never reach those people.
You will reach the careerists who want an internship at Heritage.
you will reach the the ambitious student council presidents and
theater kids and stvers that it's their dream to like be the
president or you know work for Mike Lee in Utah. You will never
reach my
So I just want to put a book end on Heritage Foundation and say
that cuz
I hear that all the time. Spare the fake concern. Oh, now you
care about the young white men when you're not browbeating the
young white men and belittling them and bullying them. And by
the way, I know this is sacrilege. I'm going to say it.
Charlie Kirk was the king of that.
He was the king of that,
which is going to young white men and telling them,
"You need to be more differential to your wife. You need to be
more differential to women. You need to be more differential
to the >> Oh, I didn't see the incel time in or sorry,
I didn't see the insult tie in
Actually,
the the subservience to Israel they want that's just like the
subservience to your wife. Okay, listen. If you if you think
when you think about it, people wanting you to be nice to women
is just like people wanting you to be nice to
>> the oligarchy. Didn't see that one. You need to shut
up and pay your taxes.
>> And you come last. You don't matter. Put down the video
games and put this down and shut up and you got to grow up and
being mature means being a s and all the rest of it.
They don't care about us at all. And they don't care about our
well-being. They don't care about any of it. And the proof is
in the pudding. I'm one of those young white men. And they threw
me away when I was 18. and they throw me away now. They don't
care about me then. They don't care about me now. And if you
were saying the same things that I did, if you had the wrong
opinions or said the wrong things, they would not be looking
to help you or understand you. They would be crushing you like
they tried to crush me. It's that simple. And everyone knows
that. Uh but I want to move on. I want to talk a little bit now
about the
Republican coalition summit this weekend because this was really
interesting timing. >> Oh, interesting. So, he's going
to go over to the Randy Fine talk, the Mark Levin talk, Ted Cruz
was there,
Floyd Mayweather was there apparently. I'm not sure why. I have
no idea why. I swear to God that whatever the Republican coalition
is, it's the most like transparent, manipulative show. I feel
like almost certainly they were like, "Hey, Floyd, we'll give
you some money and then you can get us like some some black voters
who will be around us as well.
So,
I did the Tucker interview on Monday, and it just so happened
that this past weekend, it was a coincidence,
just a couple of days ago.
This is real. This is a real thing that
This is an actual thing that happened that occurred in our lifetime.
Unironically, flag up right now.
My heart.
Like, I'm sorry.
Anybody under the age of 50 that sees this is like, "Oh, I actually
I'm I'm voting. I'm single issue anti-Zionist now. Every single
person who saw this who's under the age of 50 is just like, "Yeah,
I'm done. I'm done. I'm out. I'm out. I'm out. I'm out. I can't
anymore."
The Republican Coalition held their annual leadership summit
in Las Vegas,
And this was, like I said at the top of my show, I don't think
this is an
It was literally and it felt like a declaration of war by the
Israel lobby against the United States of America. It felt like
they were on a war footing.
This group, the Republican
I don't think it's anti-semitic to say that they represent
Not just the interests of Israel, but the interests of people.
It's not called the Republican Israel Coalition. And it's called
the Republican
coalition.
And so the types of questions they ask,
this is not me saying this, this is their own Wait, I thought
I'm almost positive that wasn't it males 18 to 25 actually broke
for Trump this time. I thought it was like that that group barely
swung to Trump like like 51%.
Which is crazy cuz normally it's like 70 30 80 20 Democrat words.
The types of questions they ask are what is best for
Again, they hate when I say those things, but they say it all
the time. You know, it's sort of like the white genocide narrative.
If I say America's becoming minority white, they say that's a
racist conspiracy theory. If Michelle Goldberg at the New York
Times says we are replacing white people and it's a good thing,
well then I guess it's different.
You know, when the liberal media says whites are becoming a minority
and here's why that's a good thing. Here's why that's good for
the Democrats. Here's why America's better off because of this.
I get Yeah. I don't know. Just But uh
yeah, young men swung here.
like people in this age bracket vote Trump. So, I don't know.
It's like almost equal. I I think it's This person only says
This person shows up and only says wrong things. Why do you do
this? You only say wrong things. The only things you come to
chat to say are wrong things. It's crazy. I got to
>> I guess it's now
different somehow.
It's the same with this.
If I talk about
and by that I mean they have many
that flames run the game. [__] him. Feel my pain.
Slim spits venom. Groper horde. Bagels are fake.
>> It cut off. Cookies get baked. Groper horde bagels are
fake. Okay. Thank you for the five. Appreciate it. Appreciate
>> Want to hear about some of them? the World Congress,
which is headed up by I think Larry Frink is gonna take the role
or maybe he's up at World Economic Forum. I believe the World
Congress is led by Ronald Lauder who's the heir to the Estee
Lauder perfume fortune. That's one of them. The World Zionist
Organization is another.
You have the Zionist uh guys, we're we're seven subs away from
the two hours on stream. I'm probably not going to shill too
much after this. We're going to go back and do that glossy review.
Okay, we're going to look for all the glossy terms and make sure
we know whether or not Ben Shapiro was truly like that up. Okay,
whether he was mispronouncing glazing or
glossing. Yeah, glazing each time. Okay, we'll go back and do
that analysis. I've also got all the Cash Patel stuff. And then
we've got Aerodite and Schneo. And then which by the way, that's
what they got in the title of Schneo for a streaming channel.
And then there's live and learn as well. Live and learn with
Hutch and Prime Kai.
Okay, I've heard there's just lots of content. I don't know if
we're going to get to it tonight, but we will get to it tomorrow
if we don't. So, if you're interested in seeing more of that
content tonight, I'm not sure which direction we'll go. We'll
do Cash and then we'll do one of the other pieces. Okay.
Aerodite and Sinko did end up talking about Stalin. Cool.
Organization of America led by Mort Klein. You've got the Anti-Defamation
League. You've got the
Benet Brit Society. You've got many fraternities. You've got
APAC, American Israel Public Affairs Committee. You've got the
organization of major
uh organized
on YouTube and everybody's like, "Hey,
aren't you going to like aren't you going to totally fed post
right now and get banned again? Don't you want to like kind of
deny the Holocaust right now? Aren't you feeling like you could
maybe just deny a little just a little Holocaust denial for like
old times sake? What do you think? What do you think, Ste? Can
we a clip of you denying the Holocaust right now?
I I forget the acronym exactly. So when I say organized,
this is a community. They organize on the basis of their ethnicity,
their heritage, their religion. They have many different federations,
organizations,
congresses, groups, whatever. And when they convene together
like they did this weekend at the RJC, they ask questions like,
"What is best for us as a group?"
What is a word for this? This is identity politics.
It's a word that Tucker Carlson used. True. Sorry. This is uh
we'll we'll go back into this. He's talking about like group
solidarity and how white people aren't allowed and people are
and they're encouraged to and it everything up. Okay, we can
get to that. It's a it's an old it's an old talking point. It's
kind of tired in my opinion, but we'll we'll get there. I just
bantab orno balls. Yeah, deny the holocaust. Or no balls. Are
you chicken?
Deny the
>> in our interview. It's a word I haven't heard in a long
time, but I think it's useful here. >> They're engaging
in identity politics. They're not saying what is best
objectively. They're not saying what is best for America. They're
not saying what is best for conservatives.
When they convene at the Republican coalition, they're there
to answer the question, what is best for us, the what is best
for us as the community?
And the implication, the subtext of this is that this is distinct
from what is best for everybody, including the Jews or everybody
other than the Jews or all Americans. Like to say what is best
for the is exclusionary.
It's to say that are a group organized on the basis of that shared
identity and they recognize that that group has explicit interests
as a group
which you know when they call me anti-semitic for saying organized
I don't know what they're talking about because that's what this
is
and I don't think there's anything immoral about acknowledging
that anyway. So they convene this weekend at the Republican coalition
and there is an air of alarm.
That is the culture at the RJC this weekend. They are hysterical
and panicked.
And they had speeches there by the senator Ted Cruz, the senator
Lindsey Graham, the representative Randy Fine, I believe Dan
Krenshaw, he either spoke there on television shortly thereafter.
Mark Levin spoke there
and the air of the conference like I said was hysteria, uncontrolled.
>> Did he not did he not mention Floyd
screaming very aggressive hostile paranoid rhetoric?
This is an excerpt from a news article about it. It says, quote,
"Until last week, the Republican coalition's annual leadership
summit was expected to be a triumphant gathering to celebrate
President Trump's accomplishments in the Middle East.
Chief among them, the recently brokered ceasefire between Israel
and
so they were getting ready to celebrate and say, "Well, Trump
ended the war and this is great for Israel and so on."
that says that all changed after Tucker Carlson hosted the
influencer Nick Fuentes on his podcast for a sympathetic interview
provoking fierce backlash.
By the time that Kevin Roberts came to Carlson's defense on Thursday,
the RJC recognized its conference would require a thematic update
to forcefully
the urgency of confronting rising anti-semitism
and its enablers within the GOP.
Norm Coleman, the national chairman of the RJC,
said in his opening remarks, "If there was ever a time for the
Republican coalition, "This is our time. We have been called
to this moment to fight the scourge of anti-semitism."
Even as multiple speakers at the 3-day summit held at the Venetian
Resort, including congressional leaders, activists, and media
per Okay, hold on. Hold on. Do you guys think How well do you
think Floyd did? cuz realistically I'm not sure he could pronounce
anti-semitism
and he certainly can't read any speech that's given to him about
anti-semitism. So I do wonder what would have happened with Floyd
there. Like what would he have even talked about? He would have
just said like I love man. I I love
>> that's like all he could say
>> alluded to anti-semitism in their ranks. Many talked
in broad strokes, didn't mention Carlson by name, or downplayed
the issue as confined to the fringes, despite Carlson and Fuentes
each commanding a significant number of followers on the right.
Representative Byron Donald's running for governor of Florida
relied on euphemism.
The only thing that could probably save us from populism is unironically
their inner debate about Israel. True. Thank God the Democrats
aren't having any kind of schism about Israel at all. to refer
to right-wing anti-semitism, declaring that the GOP would not
stand idally by as some in other parts of politics demonize Americans
and try to weaken or destroy the relationship between the US
and Israel.
Some, including Ted Cruz, Dave McCormack, and Lindsey Graham
more forcefully addressed the growing anti-semitism on their
side of the aisle.
Taking the floor on Saturday, however, Randy Fine, a freshman
congressman from Florida, one of four Republicans in the House,
criticized those who focus only on left-wing
or just broadly talk about prejudice on the right. He said, "It's
easy to talk about anti-semitism on the left. I want to talk
about the dark force rising on our side." Multiple speakers have
talked about the rise of anti-semitism on the right, but it's
not enough to speak in platitudes or generalities. We must call
evil by its name. He called Carlson the most dangerous anti-semite
in America and said he did not belong.
I do want to see is he going to have like a reaction there. The
the funny reaction that I think he's going to stay away from
is it would be for him to go what the
what excuse me I'm right here. That would be a funny reaction
but he's not going to do that. >> Trump's movement. >> He
also said he was cancing a scheduled event with the Heritage
Foundation adding that the group had future in his office. He
said, "I will be calling on all of my colleagues on the Republican
side to do the same."
Lindsey Graham said, "The administration is doing what we voted
for it to do, the right people and lower their taxes." He said, "We
ran out of bombs
because we dropped so many and killed so many people." Ted Cruz
said the single most important national security decision Trump
made was to bomb Iran.
And Cruz said that he called Trump every week for months begging
him to bomb
But I want to talk about Mark Leavvin's comments.
Do you think there's no way Ted Cruz? Hold on. Sorry. We just
looked at Floyd. Where's my Where's my Floyd one here? Where's
Floyd at? Hold on.
Ted Cruz. Republican.
There's no way he said called him every
>> There's no That's not possible that he said every week.
Hold on.
I don't see it here. I don't see it in the transcript. I'm looking.
I don't see it. Okay. I don't see it.
We support Israel because it is unequivocally in the national
security interest of the United States to support Israel. Because
the enemies of Israel hate America
because
why
those who hate Jews hate Christians?
I mean that. Wait, why? Why do you think that is? What do you
think they think the reason is? Right. What do you think they
think the reason is, Ted? What do you think they think the reason
is? >> There is a reason the Ayatollah calls Israel the
little Satan and America the great Satan
and the national security benefit. You Ted. Ted. Ted. Question
for Mr. Cruz. Question for Mr. Cruz. Hey. Hey Ted. Who do you
think the Ayatollah thinks runs America?
Hey Ted, quick question. Just point of order. Who do you think
the Ayatollah thinks runs America? Ted, look at the MSAD.
We provide roughly $3 billion a year of military assistance.
If we tried to recreate that intelligence network to keep Americans
safe, it would cost 10x or 100x.
And every single terrorist, every single Hezbollah terrorist,
every single IRGC
radical that Israel takes out, the American people should say
thank you.
>> This is insane. This is completely insane. This person's
totally lost.
Kind of crazy. Kind of crazy. Mr. Cruz is a little little out
there sometimes because his were the most interesting.
A lot of these other remarks we can get into some of the things.
>> This is uh Mark Levin he's talking about right now >> that
were said because I think they bely some of the double standards
and maybe elucidate the real reason they're so angry. But I want
to talk specifically about what Mark Levvin said. Because Mark
Leavvin seems to be the most honest out of all of them. He's
certainly the most emotional. He's sort of like a woman. Mark
Leavvin is kind of like transgender. I think he might have a
vagina because he's the most emotional and it's weird about
they all have like a weird thing with their mothers
and it has to do with the religion. We could get into that in
the super chats but they all have this weird dynamic with their
moms. All the
not all but a lot of them they have the overbearing mother complex
>> and so many of the men are very emotional
and they're very histrionic
like women and Mark Levin I wouldn't be surprised if he had a
vagina actually if he's a girl
uh because he's such an emotional woman you watch his speech
he's literally shaking with anger literally cannot control himself
he talks about his he said my grandpa fought at Guadal Canal.
Was your grandpa a girl, too?
He said, "Where was where was Nick Fes's grandparents?" My grandfather
fought in World War II.
And Mark Leavvin seems like a histrionic woman. I don't know
what's going I would say I would fight him, but one, he's an
old man. He's going to be dead in 20 years. He's on his way out.
Two, I think he might be a woman. So, I don't even want to fight
him cuz I don't want to hit a girl. I know people say I'm a,
but I don't do that. So Mark Leavvin, I mean, this guy's like
by definition a
which a lot of them are. Anyway, but Mark Leavvin, he had the
most interesting statement because he's so emotional. I think
he told on himself a little bit. And I want to read through his
statement. This was not at the Republican coalition. This was
in an interview a couple of days later. I think it was on the
sidelines of the conference. He said this, and this is
that's prolific. That's a prolific forehead. Okay, that's an
incredible forehead right there. That's Mark Levin. A longer
excerpt, but I want to work through all of this. This is a verbatim
So, this is no editorializing.
There's no editing here.
This is not exaggeration, not hyperbole. This is verbatim what
Mark Levvin said in a video published today. He said, quote,
I decided six or seven months ago that this Tucker Carlson was
not being challenged.
I had people calling me, some very famous, some of the community
very powerful.
What are we going to do about it? they said to me.
Okay, these people just keep shooting themselves in the foot
over and over and over again
why why do they keep doing it?
Hey, um yeah, basically this interview happened and then a whole
bunch of like really powerful people called me and were like,
"What are we going to do about this?" I literally got the call
multiple times.
Are you serious? Are you
He said, "Very famous, very powerful
are calling me Mark Levin and they're saying, "What are we going
to do about Tucker Carlson?"
So, this is not out of the anti-semitic ramblings of the
clan meeting. This is from the mouth of Mark Levin.
Okay, this is at the Republican coalition for the news syndicate.
That is who hosted the interview. This is Mark Levin. He said
six or seven months ago 67 made an appearance. I am sorry to
say.
He said six months ago I had very famous powerful calling me
up saying what are we going to do about Tucker
Okay, that's how this is what happens. He got the call. He goes
on. He says, "The fact is they, and by they, he means people
like myself,
have access to our colleges and universities. This fusion of
Marxists, Islamists on the left, and the and clansmen on the
right, they hate us. They hate America and now they hate
Dude is honestly
I feel like mentioning Islam, Islamism,
that's just like a total that's like a total red flag to me now.
Like these issues are so non-existent in North America. If you
mention these words at all, if you go Marxist, Islamist, you
say any of these words, I'm immediately like, "Oh, huge red flag."
Yeah, I don't I Yeah, that's not been a problem here for a long
time. What the [__] are you talking about? What are
you trying to signal out right now? What are you doing? What
are you doing over there?
They hate us.
Who's us?
Oh, it's people. When he says us, he's not talking about Americans.
He's talking about people. Does Mark Levin believe if we're clansmen?
And does he think we hate white people?
We don't hate white people. Does he think we hate America? We're
called America first. We don't hate America.
So what do Marxists Islamists and clansmen in his parliament
what do they all have in common? They don't have anything in
common other than call all of them anti-semitic.
He says they think we're going to build a Republican majority
with 1930s
and 1950s racists. That's not going to fly, says Mark Leavvin.
The obligation we have here is to use whatever resources we have,
whatever roles we have in the community. It's time to get
He says that's not good. You think we're going to build a coalition
with Tucker and Nick Fuentes? That ain't going to
We have an obligation to use our resources, our roles in the
community and we have to get tough.
>> What does that mean? >> So Mark Levin is saying
powerful and famous Jews
have to use their money and the positions they have
across domains and they have to work together.
Okay. Um other than the speaking it out loud, at least Mark Levin
has an idea of what the strategy has to be, right? At least he's
identified that he cannot like fight the ideas here, right? Like
a bunch of whole bunch of like a whole ton of Republican people
have said, "Oh, no. We'll just fight his ideas." No, you lost
on that front already. At least at least Mark Levin knows what
he has to do if he wants to get rid of this guy, right? If he
wants to not have his whole party like submarined.
Saying it out loud is stupid though. I have no idea why you do
that. Now, now he can point at you saying it out loud and go,
"Look, they they were planning this. They did this. It was coordinated
>> to prevent
people like me and Tucker from having any influence
in politics,
anti-semitic conspiracy or Mark Leavvin speech. Which which is
it today? I I guess it depends on who's saying it. Because if
I said that, if I went on my
and said power like thi think about it this [__]
Uh,
you should have said now is that the speech that I finally got
banned from YouTube for or was it Mark Leavvin's speech at the
Republican
Republican convention? Okay, which one was it? Was it the speech
that got me banned or was it Mark Leavvin speech at the Republican
convention? way. If I got on my show and said, "Famous, powerful
are calling each other saying we have to stop Tucker and they
are going to use their money and their influence to shut us down."
They would quote that. They would clip that and they would say,
"This is another anti-semitic rambling from Jr."
But that's not a speech that I gave on my show. This is a speech
from Mark Leavvin for the new syndicate at the Republican coalition
to a room receiving a standing ovation.
He goes on, he says, "It's funny how this isolationist, bigoted,
anti-semitic kookery on the right rejects everything, the Declaration,
the Constitution."
He says,
"They tear down our symbols as much as the left in defending
ourselves.
We're defending this country."
What are you talking about? We tear down American symbols.
In what way? We're America first. We want to keep the monuments
of Roberty Lee, of George Washington, of Lincoln, of Thomas.
We want to keep the Constitution, the Declaration.
What are you talking about?
>> there literally the clip of him talking to Destiny in
a Twitter space saying, "No, of course we don't like that. Of
course we don't like free speech. Of course we're going to get
rid of freedom of speech." I thought there's like literally a
Twitter clip of him saying all these things. Yeah, we don't care
about it. We want to make the country better. Yeah, we'll tear
it all up. We We just want to make the country better.
He says they want to tear down America symbols.
We're standing in the way. What are you talking about?
He goes on. He says, "This is not a free speech debate. This
is not a policy debate. It's not even purely an Israel debate."
So, it is very much an Israel debate. He says it's a debate over
and
This is the Republican
coalition. 2026 is important. 2028 is crucial. We are going to
take names. We are going to see who is associated with who, who
platforms whom, who supports whom, and we are going to make our
decisions.
Who's we?
He says, I've heard this phrase, we don't deplatform people.
We sure as hell do. We don't have a discussion. You're the enemy.
That's Mark Levvin. That's an exact
2028 is crucial.
We're taking names. We'll see who's associated with who, who
platforms who, who supports who. We'll make our decisions.
I've heard people say, "We don't deplatform people." We sure
as hell do. We don't have discussions. You're the
You could say, "What is he talking about?" He tells us. He says,
"How many more times do we have to hear about pressuring Israel
to get a ceasefire?" How many times do we have to hear that Judea
and Samaria, that's the West Bank and Gaza, are off the table.
It's not off the table unless we say it's off the table.
How many more times do we have to?
listen to members of Congress talk about genocide in Gaza? How
many more times do we have to hear about members of Congress
go on and on about the Israel
This is Mark Leavvin.
He then he says nobody would talk about >> there's no I'm
I'm sorry.
This wasn't here, right? This was a different
There's This had to be a different
There's a full
This can't be. There's no way. This couldn't have been.
Did he He switched on to something else, right? He switched onto
something else.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. He said it was an Yeah, he said it was a separate
interview. I I figured that was what it was. Black people this
way, and they shouldn't. Nobody would talk about Hispanic people
this way, and they shouldn't. Nobody would talk about Asian people
this way, and they shouldn't. What makes them think they can
talk about us this way?
Who's they?
Well, I'm going to imagine that because he didn't say white people,
he means white people.
What's a 1930s in a 1950s racist?
Who's they can't talk about blacks, Hispanics, and Asians this
way? Is that whites?
Mark Leavvin is quoted as saying on Twitter that Europeans have
anti-semitism in their DNA. Josh Hammer said the same thing.
Mark Leavvin said that too.
This is this is a segment from Mark Levvin's interview with the
new syndicate at the Republican Coalition. What else would you
call this? And by the way, he gave away the game.
Kevin Roberts in his statement and Ben Shapiro in his statement,
which we'll talk about in a moment. They read me the riot act
by going through all these different things I've said on my show
over the past 10 years.
Jokes, things taken out of context, different clips. They say
it's about that. It's not about that. Mark Levvin gave away the
whole game. This is about Israel.
This is about the West Bank and Gaza. This is about the war in
the Middle East. This is about decapitation in Iran, in Syria.
This is about the US defending and supporting this, providing
them with foreign aid and missiles and giving them cover at the
UN and bribing their enemies and people criticizing them. That's
what this is about. That's what Mark Levin said. I'll read it
again because maybe it's not maybe it's not clocking to you.
And he said this in his furious voice.
He said, "We're going to take names. We're going to see who's
associated with who, who platforms who, who's Oh, hold on. Never
mind. I I was like, there's no way he's talking about this openly.
>> Oh, and I just opened up uh his YouTube channel, Levant
T Levant TV. Why Judea and Samaria belong to Israel. Okay. >> Mark
Leavvin delivers a powerful history lesson on Israel, Bethlehem,
Judea, and Samaria, exposing the truth about the Palestinians,
Christianity in the Middle East, and the West. Silence.
Cool. Supports who? We're going to make our decisions. >> Cool.
Cool. I've heard this phrase, we don't deplatform people. We
sure as hell do. We don't have a discussion. You're the enemy.
He says, "You're the enemy.
How many more times do we have to hear about pressuring Israel
to get a
>> and think about how this question >> so like this
this Mark Levvin guy is just like Fentes fought or this guy needs
to erase his international >> the homeland of the Judea
and Samaria. There's a place there called Shilo. Sheilo is where
the various tribes came together and essentially formally formed
Judaism. These are the firsts. Without all this there'd be no
Christianity. None. And so the Palestinians say, you know what
they say, that's ours. What's yours, Sheila? That's ours. It's
not theirs. The home.
>> This guy, this guy needs to stop talking. Just get rid
of the internet.
>> How many times do we have to hear about this? He says
like it's an inconvenience. How dare you? How dare you talk about
it? How dare you ask a
He says, "How many times do we have to hear that Judea and Samaria
are off the table?" He says, "It's not off the table unless we
say it's off the table."
Excuse me? You forget whating country you think you represent?
Did you forget that for one second? In between these totally
transparently fake appeals to American history, did you forget
for one second who you're pretending to
It's not off the table unless we say it's off the table. Who's
we? The Republican coalition. And who the are you to say that?
And we're the bad, right? We're in the wrong here. He goes on,
how uh just so we're clear. Okay, let's see how long we got.
How long we got left in the stream? 15 minutes. We're We got
what? 15
still. I think seven subs for another two hours on the stream.
If we hit those seven subs,
I we've got like a whole bunch more content. I think I'm like
close to done with this. We'll watch until the end of the 15.
We'll see if we hit them the number. Okay, we hit the number,
we'll probably switch over to something else if otherwise we
just roll this out. How many more times do we have to listen
to members of Congress talk about genocide in Gaza? How many
times do we have to hear about members of Congress going on and
on about the Israel lobby?
You have to hear. We have to hear about this. Who's we? The Republican
You think you're entitled?
You're You think you're beyond reproach, beyond
criticism? Is that it?
It's not off the table unless we say it's off the table. We don't
have discussions. You're the enemy. We cancel
They're calling me. What are we going to do about so and so?
We're taking names.
>> Hello, Maywan. Thank you for the gifted sub. Also, guys,
if we don't hit the goal here, if we don't hit the goal, we will
six subs remaining. we don't hit the goal, we'll probably do
like a sporter call for a little bit here cuz I I wouldn't mind
watching some other stuff. I don't want to get like so behind
that I'm like unaware of stuff going on. So, we'll see. We'll
probably do a sporter call. >> We'll make our decisions.
>> Anonymous. Thank
>> Sorry. Anonymous. Thank for the five gifted. Appreciate
it. Okay, one sub, one sub and then we got two more hours. So,
it it seems like we're going to get there. I trust you guys.
You can make it. you.
They're calling me. What are we going to do about so and so?
We're taking names. We'll make our decisions. They gave the whole
game away. THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE HATE. THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE HATE
ABOUT THIS COUNTRY.
>> And by the way,
>> uh Alpha Kilo, thank you for the two gifted. Let's go.
Sorry, one gifted. Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate it, >> We
don't hate all people. We don't hate
We hate that our country is being held hostage
by this
transnational gang.
What is What the is this? What is this speech? Who do you think
you are? >> What is this? >> How do you think this
is being received? What audience are you talking to
when you say these things? when you say it's >> this is
like actually my reaction when he explains like the things that
are I'm just like dude you you understand you're making yourself
like look awful right I just don't get why these people come
out and say this publicly and then Ben Shapiro references Mark
Levin multiple times and how he's like a like leading the way
on this issue it's just bad man >> it's not off the table
unless we say it's off the table we don't want to hear about
the Israel lobby
who do you think is saying these things
these are Americans that have these concerns and these are valid
concerns. This is our money. We're paying for this.
Think about it. What's happening? The genocide in Gaza is real.
We're paying for it. It's our money. The reason we're doing it
is because of Apac. Congress will not go against it because they're
being lobbyed to. They're being bribed.
And you say, "We don't want to hear about it. We'll make our
own decisions."
your decisions with our money, your decisions with our military,
your decisions with our politicians,
your decisions with our soldiers.
Where do you get off? Who do you think you
And this is this is why, by the way,
Mark Levin is sort of right in a sense. When he says this is
not about
free speech, he's right. When he says this is not about whatever
else, he says it's not even purely about Israel. He's right.
It is about and it is about Judaism. This is about supremacy.
This is about that whole attitude.
This is what we're talking about that Shapiro and Levvin and
Josh Hammer that they all have, which is that their [__]
doesn't stink.
It's the arrogance. It's a smuggness. It's the entitlement.
This is what we hate. It's that attitude.
This this complex.
We are God's chosen. When one in Israel dies, it's like a thousand
Americans dying. A Israel. I So,
this is a part of the populist game, right? He's just going to
take the things. He takes the threats and then he makes it worse.
Right now, he's going to say how they think. He's weaving a narrative.
I feel like I should point that out instead of just listening
the whole >> We're going to kill every Palestinian
and you better give us money or else.
And you think what the West Bank is off the table? We'll tell
you when it's off the table and we don't want to hear about it
anymore. We're sick of hearing about it from the people that
are voting for it, paying for it, fighting for it, dying for
it. Where do you get off? Who do you think you are exactly?
Oh, well, they say it in their religion. It is in their religion.
They think that God gave them the land.
They think that they have >> again Spruce Willis. I think
Nick is describing like a coalition of people. Not describing
all not describing all Jews in America. If you're like I do I
have to spend more time explaining this. I feel like you could
sub to him if you want to like say he's entertaining, but it's
just it's like basically lies. Very entertaining lies, right?
Entertaining distortions of reality.
It's It's like okay to be entertained by it, but you should you
should honestly if you don't understand, I should maybe be able
to explain. Okay. You think he's just funny? All right. So, I
just feel bad cuz I I feel like I'm explaining things and I'm
trying to listen to make sure I understand what he's saying right
as he's going through this.
But that's fine. We keep going. Souls and that we don't.
They matter and we don't. Israel matters and our country doesn't.
Israel is a blood and soil nation.
Don't you understand that?
All when they call us, they tell on themselves.
What is what is that? Blood and soil
It's our genetics, our you know Aryan DNA, our land, whatever.
That's what they have going on in Israel.
The were promised this land. And what is a someone with a mother,
not someone that believes in Judaism, someone that was born
by blood.
So they believe that
God chose their uh Nick largely spitting facts. I mean, he's
spitting a lot of facts, right? Obviously, everything he's saying,
just go away. Uh everything he's saying about Mark Levin, Ben
Shapiro, these people, obviously they suck at this, right? Obviously
they're making asses of themselves or shooting themselves in
the foot. They're like kind of ruining their movement. Yeah,
obviously.
Um
yeah, anything he says about them. Yeah, it's basically all facts.
The stuff he's saying about Israel, about
Their tribe, their bloodline,
and gave them that land. They're blood and soil nationalists
and they believe that everything is justified
to defend and secure
this promise, genocide, war, everything that they put the United
States through. And we are all just here to pay for it. All the
rest of us
all the rest of us that weren't chosen as our bloodline, weren't
given land by God, we're all just here, I guess, to pay for it,
to fight for it.
If we have a complaint about that, they're sick of hearing about
it. Hey, um, American here, American citizen, American veteran,
American taxpayer, I don't want my money. I don't want my sons
and brothers and uncles and cousins dying for a war that doesn't
concern me. And Mark Levin says it's off the table when we say
it's off the table. And we're sick of hearing about that.
It betrays an attitude. And I saw Tucker Carlson went on Dave
Smith and he said,
he said, "Where do these people come from?" He said, "Let's talk
about how they were raised. I'll tell you how they were raised.
They were raised in this
They went to schools. They went to community centers. Why do
you think they all talk the same? Why do you think Shapiro has
a Brooklyn accent? He's from LA. Does Ben Shapiro have an LA
accent?
Does he? Or does he have like some weird Brooklyn, New
[__] >> New York accent. Why do you think that
is? It's because of who his parents were and how they >> Mill.
You think yeah that's not going to hit with the uh the target
demo here millu they talk it's because of he went to a school
and this is the attitude that they're inculcated with
which is that they are better than us
that their country matters their struggle in Israel matters this
is a this is a cosmic struggle in which they are the main characters
and we are tools and instruments to be used in pursuit of this
and that's the attitude that they're giving in the speech.
That's the sense of entitlement, the arrogance, the hubris to
Okay, unfortunately, the seething about Mark Leavvin is just
not something I super care about that much about. I do want to
watch more. I kind of want to watch this myself,
but realistically, like I feel like we could go in a different
direction. We could go take a bit of a break because holy, this
is going long.
I think it was going to be like three and a half hours. Although,
I guess we had the intro for quite a while as well.
just repeats himself a little too much. Very important to repeat
yourself quite a bit actually. Marmma dude,
Templar stuff. I don't know if we're going to do Templar stuff.
He starts talking about Ben Shapiro in a in a moment. Okay. >> To
say we're sick of hearing about it. >> I'm probably going
to start Yeah. skipping past Mark Le >> talk about identity
politics. They are consumed by that. That is reality.
And you can like it, you can dislike.
What else would you call that other than a declaration of war?
Mark Levin said, "We don't discuss with you, you're the
If that is indisputably the America first position and the Republican
coalition, the Israel First Caucus is saying, "We're sick of
hearing all of that. We're not discussing that.
That's only off the table if we say so. You're our enemy. We
do cancel people. We've done it before. We'll do it to you. We're
writing your name down. We'll do it again. We'll use our money
and power to do it.
>> Yeah. Hold on. Sorry. The reason I pointed out my one
is evil Johnny Bravo was in here earlier saying that Nick might
actually, you know, his eloquence might hurt him a little bit
cuz he doesn't repeat in the same way. I understand it's NLP.
I understand repeating things. I repeat things a lot.
I do. So, I I get it. I get it.
But Nick does it as well. And I was just pointing out basically
for the people who are thinking maybe he's a little too eloquent
for the low IQ people in the America first movement or in the
Republican manga movement. Nope. He repeats stuff a lot. Just
got to get rid of the $5. >> How do you bring these two
sides together? You can't.
Spoiler alert. You cannot bridge the gap there because there's
a fundamental disagreement here about American
These people, and by these people I don't mean all Jews. I saw
I think it's Richard Baris today who does a podcast with Robert
Barnes. He's and he hit the nail on the head today. He said they're
calling Steve Bannon an anti-semite.
He said that's ridiculous. Steve Bannon supports Israel. He says
and watch the video. It was very good. It was very explicit.
It sounded like my show.
But there's a very clear line now between America first and Israel
first. And this fault line runs through the current regional
conflict
which is ongoing which is about to restart in Lebanon which is
about to restart in Iran which is apparently inofficially unofficially
restarted in
for all these people that say we just need to defer the Israel
America first.
>> I've been through a little bit more. Uh, you can't defend
them, you can't approve of them, you have to cut all ties with
them, and you can't be friends with them ever. Oh, okay. Yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
But I want to talk specifically about Shapiro's tactics because
I found this very interesting. Okay, here we go. He puts together
this compilation of clips from my show over the years where I've
said provocative things and in many of the clips,
most of them are not longer than 10 seconds. They take a 5 to
10 second clip and say, "Here's Nick Finch as being a Here's
Nick Finch is being a racist. Here's Nick." Okay, surely this
is where we get Nick is going to explain it, right? Nick is going
to explain it to us how those things are taken out of context.
We really meant in those clips, >> Point is being
and he does it in the most smug way possible. Here's him saying
this. Well, here's him saying that.
And you know what I want to say about all that?
I don't apologize for one single thing I've ever said. And would
you like to know why?
Because we all see right through
the tactics.
>> This has always been the tactic from day one,
which is this. This is the uh the Trump playbook, right? You
never actually defend yourself ever. Defending yourself is always
a mistake. Attack. Don't talk about what happened with you. Attack.
Don't explain your behavior. Don't defend your behavior. Don't
say anything. Just attack whoever is attacking you. Attack their
friends. Attack them. Attack their family. Attack anyone. Just
don't talk about your
Whenever somebody criticizes Israel, whenever
somebody is identified as a powerful, influential opponent of
their real agenda, which is what is happening in the Middle East,
they go back to the playbook and the playbook is character assassination.
Do you think that Ben Shapiro
really cares about even one of those clips? Do you think he cares
about anything that I have ever said on the show?
Does he watch my show? Does he understand the context of any
of those things? Does he care? Does he think those are an honest
people? People just can't help themselves. They got to say the
context thing every single time, right? They just got they got
to say the context thing.
Like he implies they're out of context. They're not out of cont.
At least At least most of them aren't out of context. >> Representation
of my deepest held views. Does he care if it's honest?
The answer is no. Would you like to know why? I'll give you a
perfect counter example.
Ben Shapiro is friends with Dave Rubin.
For those that don't know anything about Dave Rubin, Dave Rubin
is a
he's in a gay marriage and Dave Rubin has adopted children through
surrogacy.
That means that him or his partner
artificially inseminated some woman with the intention and the
purpose of eventually that woman has the child and the child
is adopted by Dave and his
this is the question they consistently press on every time with
TP USA until they sort of moved away from supporting gay marriage
and supporting gay couples. Um, this is like a this is a classic
groper war question, right?
Hey, uh, why are you saying you're conservative when you support
people like basically sinning? They'll they'll hit everybody
on the conser on the right wing with this. Um, it works because
that is unironically what a lot of, you know, conservative
more uh, what would you what would the word be
like evangelical Christians like a lot of Charlie Kirk's base
would be the kinds that wouldn't um
that that would buy into this, right? Oh yeah, wait, hold on.
We we don't like gay marriage,
right? And they try to they try to hit on the church angle regardless
of how how evident it is in scripture. And it's just like
it just hits with all of them every time. And then he goes even
one step further and it's like, oh, Dave Rubin, he's actually
going to tear a child away from its mother in order to raise
it in a in a marriage of sin. Can you imagine, guys? And Ben
Shapiro supports this. Ben Shapiro is friends with him. So really,
what is what is the problem Ben Shapiro has with me morally?
Is it could it possibly be worse than tearing a child away from
its mother? Could it possibly be worse than that? What is worse
than that? Almost nothing is worse than that. Can you believe
that Ben Shapiro has the audacity to come at me over my morals?
This is evil.
This is among the most evil things
short of, let's say, murder.
that a person can imagine. Why is that?
And it's not because of a disgust reflex. It's not because we're
It's because you are creating a child. You are bringing a life
into the world with the intention of depriving that child of
their mother.
Think about that.
Imagine. Think about like it's honestly not even hard. I swear
to God it's not hard. what your mother means to you. >> And
I have to sit here and watch all of these Republicans just consistently
fumble every move they make against this guy. It's hard to know
where he's going to go, what he's going to do, what he's going
to say. Your mother is the person that loves you more than anyone
else in the world.
Your mother would die for you. Literally take a bullet for you.
There is nobody on earth, and obviously there's exceptions to
this. There's people that are mentally ill. There's women that
have, you know, weird things with their
But the default
women,
mothers in particular,
they come the closest to unconditional love that you will ever
experience from anyone on earth.
And Dave Rubin and his partner are involved in the
the playbook. I already told you the playbook. The playbook is
cancel him. The playbook is Mark Levin was right. Shut the up
and get him banned from every platform. You can spend the money
you need to call in the favors you need to.
That's that's the only way you deal with it. That is the only
path they have.
That's the only path. If they want to win, I'm telling you how
they win.
Evil of surrogacy, which is to >> uh I don't advocate for
that, by the way. I'm telling you that's the only way they win.
Otherwise, the game ended when they the game ended like years
ago, right? Like it's over. It's a foregone conclusion at this
point. >> Bring a life into the world. An innocent child
that had no business in any of this, never consented to this.
To take that child from their mother, rip them from the womb,
rip them from their mother, and say, "You're with two guys now.
You're with two big, hairy, sweaty
not your mother."
What does that do to a child?
What does that do to a human being?
Where would we be without our mothers? You want to talk about
I said and I in one of my clips I jokingly said women like rough
sex. That's the gist of it.
I said we women like when you beat the out of them. I'm joking
and talking about how women like rough sex. That seems to be
the trend these days. I don't think that's controversial.
And so they say Nick says he loves really
Dave Rubin this I mean Nick
come on man come on
hold on I swear to God I have a I swear to God I have a soundboard
somewhere of him talking
where is it? Do I have this somewhere here? Is this a thing I
had at one point? Maybe it's gone now. I swear to God I have
like a soundboard. I know there's multiple clips of this guy
talking about rap. Okay, this guy talks about rape a lot. I don't
know why he's pretending that isn't the case.
>> This is a crime. >> He's only half joking when
he says he wants his gropers want when he says he wants his gripers
wanting to rap in his name. Okay,
RKD every time. >> This is like a prosecutable crime
>> him saying marital rape isn't real. I find me a different
link to the clip. I'm never promoting that. child
>> to take the child from their mother.
>> And Shapiro's friends with this guy, interviews this
guy, hangs out with him, drinks with him, smokes cigars with
him. So now tell me again that it's about clips from my show.
Tell me again that it's because I'm a Tell me again it's because
I'm a reprehensible person.
Ben Shapiro just got back from Israel where he met with Netanyahu.
Netanyahu has been prime minister of Israel for 20 years. How
many children has he been involved in the murder of? How many?
>> Those aren't humans, Nick. Those are
>> How's Nick not >> from the IDF? Has Netanyahu
been
>> What? What? Hold on. Apparently, this is him saying
marital rape isn't real. I think the age of consent should be
mo lower. I don't even really believe in the concept. You want
to know why? Because marriage is consent. You want to know what's
wrong with
being married means you consent to all the time. There's no such
thing as
>> why did he say it like a question? >> When you
marry a person, you have a marital obligation to give your spouse
whenever they want it. It's literally Catholic doctrine. So >> I
don't think that's true. >> You know, the only moral way
to have is within marriage, the only way to get married is to
consent to on demand. Uh and both >> GPT I think it's something
to do with the translation of it. >> Partners agree to
that.
It's a mortal sin to deny it.
>> So that's that's how's that for consent theory? That's
my that's my age of consent. It's not age of >> be fruitful
and m multiply. That doesn't mean you consent at all times,
dude. Are you serious?
How How could you possibly interpret that as universal consent
at all times? It's like free for use. That's crazy. >> It's
age of marriage. Age of consent. What is this? What is this?
Christians have no use for such Christians have no use for such
a concept. You get married. A Christian A Christian doesn't have
sex with anybody. Christian has with their spouse within marriage.
And nobody's getting married at a preubescent age. People get
married
when they're at a reproductive age, when they're adolescence.
And so that, you know, I'm just redefining it.
All you see may include dehumanizing rhetoric, calls for discrimination
or violence, misinformation, or other harmful language. Content
warning.
He is a war criminal according to the ICC and the ICJ. And by
the way, our own
a murderer, a killer,
a war monger, a war criminal.
So, let's back this up. Shapiro,
this I
uh he hasn't run with this for a long time.
This would have been
This is like actually a good narrative though. This is a good
like counter punch. Like why are you acting like I'm disgusting?
How many kids have I killed? You go buddy it up with Netanyahu.
Off. Like don't talk to me about morality. You're a total piece
of I don't care what you have to say. Palestinians are humans,
too, buddy. Palestinians are humans, too. That's that's a fantastic
what aboutism for for some of the clips.
You got a problem with jokes on a show. You got a problem with
edge lord jokes on a show by a guy, a talk show host. But you
sit with people that take children from their mother. You sit
with war criminals, bloodthirsty maniacs. He's on trial in five
different cases in his own country. His own people hate him.
That's okay.
Tell me again it's about clips. Tell me again it's about being
an edge lord or jokes. It's not. And it's never been about that.
And he sits there on his show smug. No, here's him being here.
He said this. He said, and it's a 10-second clip. You
>> And you know what that is? That is a coordinated
smear campaign.
People don't understand how this works.
You've got people at Daily Wire that get paid a salary to watch
my show.
Not because they like it, not because they're interested in it.
They get paid
every time I say something off color. They take the timestamp,
they download the clip, and they put that in the
What's the purp
There's definitely somebody like that. I don't think they're
working at the Daily Wire. Okay,
Nick, make sure you you got to keep your racism in order. Okay.
Is Ben Shapiro a super frivolous like penny pincher or is he
somebody who's going to spend like
is he going to spend religiously just trying to a log you? I
feel like you've already got a lot of a logs. He probably just
has that offloaded to some skitso somewhere. Okay, come on man.
>> Purpose of this
matter goes off the >> right-wing cope. There's just there's
enough money in farming Fuentes's content in a negative direction,
right? Just through Twitter, just through like making those clips
for Twitter basically, that somebody's going to be doing it.
You don't even have to pay. Reservation. If somebody becomes
an inconvenience, we're going to throw that out there and we're
going to air that out. Oh, well, you might think this guy's against
Israel, but look at this
It's dishonest. It's a lie.
This is what they do.
accuse, point the finger, blame. You said this, you did that,
you're don't listen to him.
This is how they operate. Set another way, this is what they
do to the politicians. That's blackmail.
You don't think that's what Jeffrey Epstein was involved in?
You don't think that's what the Mossad and the Shinbet are involved
in? Blackmail, intimidation, bullying. If you don't go with what
we say, we will destroy your reputation.
We'll blackmail you. We'll intimidate you. We'll hurt you. We'll
hurt people you love. We'll take your career. We'll take your
money. We'll hurt your life. So, you better go along with it.
That's what they do.
And the whole operation is built on dishonesty. So, let's just
stop with the games. We don't need to play games anymore.
Everybody knows what this is about. And it's not about clips.
You know what this is about? This is about Israel.
Everybody knows that. Here's the proof. And I can prove it to
you.
People think I'm going to come out and say, "Well, you know,
in this clip, I said this and I'm sorry about that." It's a bad
faith attack. It's a bad faith character assassination.
Everybody knows that. Everybody knows that's how they play. That's
why everybody's walking on eggshells and got to be so politically
correct cuz they're afraid of that. I'm not afraid of that. I
know what this is. You know what this is. Everyone knows how
they operate at this
This is about the fact that Ben Shapiro only cares about Israel.
He's a single issue voter.
If he thinks you're with Israel, he supports you. If he thinks
you're against Israel, he doesn't support you. That simple.
Israel is doing their make orb breakak
once and for all push to destroy Iran and all of Iran's proxies
and Lebanon and Gaza and Yemen and Iraq,
And they need all the support they can get. Right now in America,
support for this war and for Israel is collapsing. It's in freef
fall for the Democrats, for the Republicans, for Shapiro. This
is very >> Okay, I can't I literally can't anymore. I
Oh, it's just too much. My brain's like overloaded. I need a
pallet cleanser. Then I'm going to do something else. I might
watch the rest of this at some point later. I I can't anymore,
though. I'm I'm sorry. All right, I'm starting to zone out and
then it's not going to be good content.